GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WHILE SOME MEMBERS EIGHT WITH
SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES BURKE COMPUTERS.
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USE THAT RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE. IF PLEASE SELECT ON
YOU BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
OUR I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT
YOU BACK ON ME WHEN YOUR DONE
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
pMAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW IT WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE RIVERS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. BRAWL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THE NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN SIX ZERO NINE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS.
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU. AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND IN THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED. FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE YOUR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WHICH I'M
SURE WILL NOT HAPPEN. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS. WHO
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
AND WE NOW BEGIN THE HEARING
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE DIVIDED
INTO PARTS. PART A WILL COVER
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. VICTIMS COMPENSATION
BOARD CALIFORNIA'S CORBETT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC RESPONSE
EXPENDITURES. AND BUDGET
SPENDING AUTHORITY. AND PART B.
WILL COVER PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES.
BEFORE WE BEGIN OF MAY WE
PLEASE ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WELL
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR RAZA HERE SENATOR OTHER
HERE SENATOR CORTESE SENATOR
CORTESE ERE SENATOR GROW
SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATOR NEWMAN
HERE. A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED ALL VOTES WILL BE
TAKEN AT THE END OF THE HEARING
ONCE WE HAVE COMPLETED ALL
DISCUSSION AND PUBLIC COMMENT.
NOW SINCE ISSUES ONE THROUGH
FOUR ARE VOTE ONLY LET'S BEGIN
WITH ISSUE FIVE WHICH IS A
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD- AND THE ONGOING GENERAL
FUND BACK FEEL. WE HAVE FINANCE
PLEASE BEGIN. IT MORNINGS AND
WEBER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DUE
TO CHANGES IN THE CALIFORNIA
FIND IF YOU STRUCTURE THE REST
YOU CAN FIND A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
LAST YEAR ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
WAS INCLUDING THE BUDGET SIXTY
WHEN SOLVING. THE FIX THE ISSUE
ON ONGOING BASIS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
THIRTY NINE HAD MADE DOLLARS ON
GOING THERE AFTER TO BACK FOR
THE FUND. IS NOW WILL BE
ADJUSTED ANNUALLY THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS BASED ON ACTUAL
REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES. ALSO
THE JENNA MENTIONS VICTIM
SERVICES CONSOLIDATION PLAN
STILL REMAINS ON HOLD GIVEN THE
COVER NINETEEN BETTER AND
BETTER BUT OUR FOCUS IN OTHER
AREAS IT'S CURRENTLY ON HOLD
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
DEDICATE THE TIME ATTENTION
NECESSARY THE BEST A MAN TO
SUCCESSFUL IN WEALTH ON A
CONSOIDATION. ADVANCE ANY
QUESTIONS WE ALSO LINDA
GLEDHILL THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
FOR THE VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD ON. THE LINE FOR SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE WAR. OKAY
THE L. A. O. HAVE ANY COM. I
NEED ONLY WITH THE L. A. L. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL. OKAY COLLEAGUES.
ANYBODY QUESTIONS THE QUESTIONS
OKAY OF THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO HOLD OPEN- THIS ITEM. THE
ISSUE. SIX IF YOU SIX IS
OVERSIGHT FEMA REIMBURSEMENTS-
BOB CARROLL- YES PLEASE. SHARE
ESKEW MENTAL THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IT'S OKAY I'D LIKE TO
KICK THIS OFF ON THIS ISSUE-
JUST GOING TO GIVE A VERY BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF HOW THE FEMA PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROCESS IN A PLACE
WITH THE STATE BUDGET PROCESS-
THEY CAN. HELP US. OUT
INCONSTANT CONTACT FOR THE IF
YOU WERE REIMBURSED IT'S
DEFINITE- YES WILL COVER- THE
EXTENT OF THE OVER THIS
INTERPLAY BETWEEN THOSE TWO
PROCESS IS ACTUALLY VERY.
ASTERS IS INCREASED IN THE IN
RECENT YEARS OF. I'M JUST
GENERALLY SPEAKING WHEN THE
STATE HAS A MAJOR DISASTER
WHERE THE GOVERNOR DECLARED A
STATE OF EMERGENCY. WE MEET
MOST OF OUR FINE TUNING NEEDS
THREE THROUGH FOR DIRECT
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES USING THAT
IS OUR- WHICH IS WHICH IS HAVE
A COMPANY GENERAL FUND- THE
FEMA PUBLIC ASSISTANCE FUNDING
IS GENERALLY RECEIVED AS
REIMBURSEMENTS- SO ONCE HOSE
RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS TYPICALLY
DEPOSITED IN THE GENERAL FUND
TO BACK FILL. ARE USED TO TREAT
ALL FUNDING. AND THOSE DEPOSIT
SHOPPERS REVENUE TO THE GENERAL
FUND WITHIN HELLO YES BUDGET. I
GIVE THAT OVER YOU JUST TO KIND
OF HELP- SET THE STAGE FOR- IN
THE NEXT WILL POINTS WHICH IS.
SO THE- D. HE COULD NOT PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE FUNDING IS FREE
WITH. ONLY NOT. EVEN THE SAME
FISCAL YEAR. THAT THE ACTUAL
DISASTER RESPONSE COSTS OURS-
I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY IF YOU
COULD EXCUSE ME JUST A SECOND.
IT'S REALLY CUTTING IN AND OUT
HERE IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO-
YOU KNOW TWO. HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING BECAUSE IT'S GETTING CUT
OUT IS THERE SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN DO OR RECOMMEND THAT WE CAN
DO. WOULD IT BE HELPFUL IF I
TURNED OFF MY VIDEO. THAT
PEOPLE DON'T EVEN OKAY THAT
WITHOUT HELP. ALL YOU NEED A
VERY. NOW RIGHT OKAY TRY TO
LET'S TRY WE YOU TO W. AND OUT
OR WILL WE MIGHT ASK YOU AFTER
THIS SO WE'LL KEEP GOING. SO
CLOSER TO MY MAKERS IS NOT A
WHOLE. I'M SO THE FREE EVERY.
THE THING OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
FUNDING IS NOT RECEIVED IN THE
SAME FISCAL YEAR THAT THE
SPENDING IS DONE. AND SO THEY
DIDN'T THAT IMPACTS THE STATE
BUDGET IN IN THE SENSE THAT WE
HAVE TO DO KIND OF THEM ALMOST
A YEAR BALANCING OF. THE
EXPENDITURES ON DISASTER
RESPONSE WITH WHEN WE EXPECT TO
RECEIVE THAT REIMBURSEMENT
REVENUE IN. NOW THEN OBVIOUSLY
THE HIGHER THE AMOUNT OF
ESTIMATED FUTURE REIMBURSEMENTS
FROM DISASTERS THAT TAKE PLACE
THE LARGER THE IMPACT IS ON AN
INDIAN INTERPLAY WITH THE STATE
BUDGET. SO THAT KIND OF SITTING
CONTACTS FOR- EXPLAINING HOW
SOME OF THE COMPLEXITIES OF THE
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS. MAKE
MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT OF A
CHALLENGE. TO ESTIMATE AND-
PROJECT. THE IMPACTS AND WHEN
THEY'RE GONNA BE FELT SO SOME
OF THE FEMUR PROCESS IT IT'S
VERY COMPLEX AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF DETAILS THAT HAVE TO BE
ASSESSED AND CONSIDERED WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO DETERMINE WHICH
SPECIFIC COSTS ARE GOING TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR REIMBURSEMENT. AND
IT TAKES SOME TIME TO BE ABLE
TO DETERMINE THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE POTENTIAL BENEFITS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET FROM FEMA
REIMBURSEMENT AND- THAT KIND OF
GOES ALONG. ALONG WITH THE
RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT THAT FEMA
WOULD REIMBURSE A 100% FOR%
CERTAIN PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES.
GIVEN THE COMPLEXITIES OF
DETERMINING ELIGIBLE COSTS IT'S
IT IS THERE'S A PROCESS TO
CHALLENGE PROCESS AT THAT.
DETERMINE THE IMPACTS OF THE
CHANGE FROM SAY 75% A 100% AS
WITH THE OTHER CHALLENGES AND
JUST DETERMINING ELIGIBILITY
OVERALL- OTHER KIND OF
CONSIDERATION THIS IS MORE
COVERT SPECIFIC AND THEN IT IS
IN GENERAL DISASTER BUT ONE OF
THE OTHER CONSIDERATIONS IS
THAT IN THIS PARTICULAR
DISASTER FEMA REIMBURSEMENT
ISN'T THE ONLY SOURCE FOR
FINDING IN PLAY AND SO PART OF
THE COMPLEXITY IN THIS
PARTICULAR PROCESS IS BOUNCING
THE HIGHEST AND BEST USE OF
VARIOUS TYPES OF FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR EXAMPLE THE CURRENT VIRUS
REALLY FIND- AND A FEW OTHER
SOURCES OF FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE STATE TO HELP
WITH PUBLIC COSTS. BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING VERY
HARD TO MAXIMIZE OUR USE OF
FEDERAL FUNDING OVERALL FOUND
PART OF THAT IS JUST FIGURING
OUT WHERE THE PIECES OF THE
DIFFERENT FEDERAL FUNDING
PASSED THAT- AND THAT AND THAT
ALSO HELPS IS TO MINIMIZE THE
RISK OF HAVING FEMA CLAIMS BE
REDUCED OR DENIED BECAUSE OF
ANY SORT OF LEVEL OF AN
ELIGIBLE COSTS BE INCLUDED
WITHIN. A PARTICULAR CLAIM
APPLICATION. AND SO THERE'S A
COUPLE DIFFERENT AND VERY
ACCESS SEVERAL NUMBER. THAT CAN
AFFECT. THE AMOUNT A FEW MARIA.
I WILL GET ON JUST A COUPLE
HIGH LEVEL- PRIMARY
CONSIDERATIONS ARE OF COURSE
YOU TALK ABOUT ELIGIBILITY
LITTLE BIT- FEMA COSTS HAVE TO
BE. MEET THE FEMA GUIDELINES
WHICH ARE FAIRLY BROAD AND
THERE'S FAIR ROOM FOR
INTERPRETATION. AND I THINK
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT IN
COVERT NINETEEN. THIS IS A NEW
TYPE OF DISASTER FOR FEMALE
JUST LIKE IT IS FOR THE STATE
OF EVERY STATE AND LOCALS AND
EVERYBODY ELSE. SO SOME OF THAT
COMPLEXITY IS A LITTLE BIT
DEEPENED BY THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE ARE HAVING TO FIGURE.
OUT HOW TO APPLY CERTAIN
GUIDELINES. THANKS. TO THIS
KIND OF NEW SITUATION AS WELL.
I HAVE BEEN IN. IS THAT IT'S
ALSO THE CORPORATION WHICH IS
NOT. CONTINUE CONCEPT IT WE DO
AT THE STATE LEVEL TO WHERE
VARIOUS THINGS ARE ARE MADE
AVAILABLE SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION. BUT THAT MEANS
THAT- WITHOUT ADEQUATE YOU KNOW
FUNDING BEING PROVIDED BY.
CONGRESS THEN OBVIOUSLY THE
AVAILABILITY OF- FUNDING FOR
FEMA TO REIMBURSE US- I CAN IN
IMPACT THE TIMING I DON'T KNOW
THE MEANING- YES CAN TALK MORE
TO THIS WHEN THEY DO CAN BE
GENERAL OVERVIEW AFTER
QUESTIONS WITHIN GENERALLY IT'S
A MATTER OF TIMING AND THAT CAN
RELATE IN SOME OF THE DELAYS
WHICH ALSO IMPACTS THE- THE
STATE BUDGET. AND THEN ALSO
JUST KIND OF A LAST POINT TO
MAKE IS THAT FEMA FUNDING ISN'T
JUST AVAILABLE SPECIFIC TO COPE
WITH NINETEEN SO. THE FUNDING
THAT IS AVAILABLE TO FEMA TO
SUPPORT REIMBURSEMENTS- IS
AVAILABLE SUPPORT ALL TYPES OF
DISASTERS THAT WOULD INCLUDE
YOU KNOW WILDFIRES AND
HURRICANES AND TORNADOES
EARTHQUAKES FLOODS. YOU NAME
IT- AND THEN IT'S ALSO
AVAILABLE ACROSS IN ALL FIFTY
STATES SOME SOME OTHER US
TERRITORIES AND SO YOU KNOW
KIND OF. COMPETING FOR RESOURCE
PERSPECTIVE IT'S YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE WORKING. WITH OTHER
STATES IN AND LOCAL ENTITIES
WITHIN OUR STATE- THOSE ROCK
AND WORKING TOWARDS THE SAME
PART OF FEMA FUNDING SO THEIR
NUMBER A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES
IN TERMS OF THE TIMING.
RECEIVING A VETERAN RESPONSE.
AND COMPLEXITIES INVOLVED IN
ESTIMATING AMERICA
REIMBURSEMENTS. AND HOW THEY'VE
BEEN IN A PLACE WITH THE STATE
BUDGET SO WANTED TO USE THAT AS
A SETTING STAGE- AND I'LL TURN
OVER TIME NOW TO- YES TO TALK A
BIT. MORE ABOUT THE ACTUAL TO
THE PROCESS ITSELF. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CARACTERIZA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JUST
RESHAPE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FOCUS AND THE THING ABOUT
CONSTANCE OPENING ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC OF THE FEMA
REIMBURSEMENT I THINK THE
MESSAGE AT STEVENS AT WHAT'S
THAT WELL AS THE RULING
PROBABLY HAS PLACES THE GATEWAY
OR STEWARD OF THESE FUNDS IT'S
NOT A IT'S NOT SOMETHING IT'S
THAT SEND YOU GUYS I CERTAINLY
FOR WILD EARTHQUAKES FLOODS. HI
OR MARGIN SEES THAT WE SEE HOW
AND I KNOW EXEMPTION- IT OUT
FOR THE COLOR RESPOND OTHER
THAN A MAN OF THIS EVENT THE
DURATION HAS I'D REALLY HAVE
REQUIRED THAT A LOCK STEP
APPROACH WITH FINANCE WHICH
WORK AND GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP IN ORDER TO YOU
KNOW KIND OF UNDERSTAND HOW
THIS FINDING PEOPLE NAST'S WITH
THE OTHER FEDERAL FUNDING
SOURCES THE TIMING OF IT AND
THIS THE FLOORBOARDS OF IT
TOWARDS THE STATE BUDGET.
REALLY THAT'S THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING AFTER RECOVERY
PROGRAMS ALL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE BRAND VERIS ARE GET
THE DIRECTOR OF THAT AND
RECOVERY OPERATIONS GOING TO
DETAIL WE REALLY WANT TO BE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE ON SPECIFICS ABOUT THE
REIMBURSEMENT WE HAVE THE
EXPERTS HERE IN THE ROOM I JUST
KNOW THAT I THIS IS ONE OF THE
ROLES THAT THEY PROBABLY US
PLACES TO UNDERSTAND NAVIGATE
AND WILL BE TAKE PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE THAT'S THE NAME OF
THE PROGRAM FOR PEOPLE BUT IT'S
REALLY THE PUBLIC AGENCY.
SOURCE FOR- AND HELP TO RECOVER
ELIGIBLE COSTS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT GROUPS- THIS PATHWAY
THE STATE AGENCIES AS WELL AS
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND ADDS
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND TO SOME
DEGREE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
ARE ALL POTENTIAL APPLICANTS TO
THIS PROGRAM WE WORK WITH ALL
OF THEM EQUALLY IN ORDER TO
NAVIGATE ADDS- AND- MAXIMIZE
THAT REIMBURSEMENT ORACLE BID
AND ALL THE OTHER MULTITUDE ASK
FEDERAL DISASTER DECLARATIONS
THAT ARE IN PLAY AT ANY GIVEN
TIME IN CALIFORNIA. BUT THAT
JUST WANTED TO OPEN WITH THAT
REMEMBER TO BRING A CD ANTHONY
BRIEF OPENING REMARKS. AND
CERTAINLY GET YOUR QUESTION. IF
YOU SEEN OUR GEN. MANY MEMBERS
YOU FOR HAVING US HERE TODAY. I
JUST WANT TO GIVE A OVER. OF
JUST THAT THE NOT PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE. AND HOW WE ARE.
PLEASE- OUT OF AND THAT-
SEEKING FEMALE REVERSE IT
REALLY ON THE GO I ABOUT THE
IDEA MULTIPLE STEP PROCESS.
DRIVEN BY THE- GUIDED BY NO YES
AND OFFICIALLY APPROVED BY HIM.
TRACKS RECEIVED ACTIVITIES-
ANYTHING THAT'S ELIGIBLE FOR
OVER NINETEEN INTO- THE FEMA
SYSTEM WHICH IS PROBABLY BRANCH
FOR BOTH- SYSTEM. JIMA ASSIGNS
A- EIGHT SAY YES STAFF MEMBER
TO EACH APPLICANT TO GUIDE THEM
THROUGH TIS PROCESS- ONCE THE
DOCUMENTS HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED
INTO THE GRASS PORTAL SYSTEM
OUR TEAM REVIEWS EACH PROJECT.
EVERYBODY THAT HAPPENED REALLY
QUICK WITH LESS THAN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS EVERYTHING IS WHERE
IT NEEDS TO BE. REPLACED AT OFF
TO. THE MATH YEAH THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT STILL NEEDS TO
BE ANSWERED THAT ARE LACKING WE
WORK DIRECTLY WITH APPLE
AGAINST A SYSTEM TO GET IT INTO
THE SYSTEM. ONCE IT LEAVES US
IT GOES TO A REGIONAL
CONSOLIDATED RESOURCE CENTER-
WHICH IS LED BY FEMA. BUT
ACTUALLY THEY WERE OF A REVIEW
OF THE DOCUMENTS TO ENSURE
ELIGIBILITY. ONCE IT PASSES
THIS YEAR C. IN REVIEW AND TWO
THINGS HAPPEN ONE DIFFERENCE A
SMALL PROJECT WHICH CAN BE
RETURNS IS LESS THAN
1-003-100-0100 DOLLARS- IT'S
REVIEWED BY THE REGION. AND
ONCE APPROVING IT- GOES
DIRECTLY BACK TO THE APPLICANT
IS AN APPROVED PROJECT ANYHING
THAT'S A LARGER PROJECT.
ANYTHING EQUAL STILL MORE THAN
1-003-100-0100 ACTUALLY DOES
THE FEMALE- BOB DECHIARA
REVIEW. INDEPENDENT ON THEM OUT
ANYTHING ABOVE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS AS A I WOULD BE REVIEW
ARCTIC STEP BACK TO US. BOB OR
GROUP TO DATE YES IS REVIEWED
OVER ONE THOUSAND FIFTY
PROJECTS- WHICH IS YOU KNOW
QUITE A BIT ROBERT S. THE
TIENEN BODICE DEPENDS- YOU KNOW
FEMALE IS LIKE ALL OF US FACE
IN A PANDEMIC EVERY. STATE
EVERY CITY COUNTY IS IMPACTED-
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
WORKING GROUP IS PRIORITIZING
CERTAIN PROJECTS FOR US WHICH
INCLUDES THE VACCINE ROW. I
THINK YOU'RE GONNA NATIONALLY
AND HERE IS THE OF CALIFORNIAN
ALSO UNDER ASSISTANT US WITH
GETTING. ANY PROJECTS THAT WE
HAVE IN THE SYSTEM TO WORK.
PROPERLY- SO. OUR COMMENTS. I
BELIEVE MY COLLEAGUE JERRY SORT
OF BURKE IS COMMENTING ON I
DON'T. SORT OF BORED A I- WE
DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC COMMENTS ON
THIS ITEM BUT WE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE OKAY I HAVE A JUST
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS OF. ALL
OF THE APPLICATIONS THAT COME
FROM WITHIN CALIFORNIA. DO THEY
HAVE TO GO THROUGH CAL- YES IN
THAT PROCESS OR GET CAL OVS
GUIDANCE IN ORDER TO SUBMITTED
TO FEMA OR- OR THAT YOU KNOW
CAN THEY GO DIRECTLY DO YOU
HAVE ANY SENSE OF THE IF THEY
CAN GO DIRECTLY DO YOU HAVE ANY
SENSE OF WHAT. THAT AMOUNTS TO.
SERVICE GENERAL SERVICES
ARRIVED ARE YES ALL PROJECTS
ARE REVIEWED BY NO YES THE-
APPLIQUE THE STATE EVERYBODY
WILL EVERYONE ELSE AND
BEAMINSTER OF THESE AFRICAN SO
WE WERE. ALL MATERIALS ARE NOT.
INSURANCE NUMBER OFFICER. OKAY
SO PEOPLE TAKE A NAP BUT FROM
ANOTHER. ENTITY WITH THE STE
WITHOUT GOING THROUGH CARILLO
YES. THAT IS CORRECT OKAY OKAY.
AND- LET'S SEE. I KNOW YOU MAY
THE PRESIDENT'S RECENT AND
COULD YOU HAVE ANY IDEA A
PORSCHE OR ALL OF ALL OF THE
FOR PROGRAMS PRIDE ROOM KEY THE
PEOPLE PER. HOW THAT WILL BE
OVER. SO THEY WERE OPENING
GUIDANCE. YEAH HOUSE MA'AM
ENGINER TWENTY. WE'RE STILL
GUIDANCE FOR FEMA OF WHAT
THEY'RE GONNA WOULD BE ENTITLED
FROM THE REIMBURSE- THEY HAVE
US THAT OUR WHOLE EMERGENCY
WORK AB WORK. IS NO THAT WAS
ALLEN FROM THE YEAR LAST YEAR
GONNA BE BACK A HUNDRED. FOR
ALL ACT. BUT WE WAITING ON FEMA
FIRST GUIDANCE. FROM THAT
GENERATE TWENTY WHEN I ABOUT.
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS DURING
THIS TIME I'M SURE YOU'RE- A-
WORKING A LOT. HARDER THERE
WOULD YOU DO ESPECIALLY A PRE
EMERGENCIES SO WE'RE PRETTY
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY WE
MOVE ON TO ISSUES SEVEN OF-
OVERVIEW OF COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC SPENDING. WILLIAMS
STEVEN BENSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE- SO SINCE
THE ONSET OF THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA'S TAKEN A
LOT OF DIFFERENT ACTIONS TO
SAVE LIVES BY HELPING TO
MITIGATE THE SPREAD OF THE
NINETEENTH AND THAT'S BEEN DONE
UNDER THE VERY THREE THE
REGISTRY SERVICES ACT AND OTHER
LAWS THAT GOVERN PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES. IN THIS EFFORT AND
BEEN LED- JOINTLY BY CALLAWAY
GAS IN THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
BERMAN AND USING THAT STRATEGY-
THE STATE'S ACTED VERY SWIFTLY
TO COORDINATE WITH LOCAL AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE
STATE MUTUAL AID RESOURCES TO
HELP TO RESPOND ACROSS THE
STATE- AND THAT COULD NINETEEN
PANDEMIC RESPONSES INCLUDED A
LOT OF DIFFERENT CORE RESPONSE
EFFORTS REACTIVE THESE- I KNOW
THAT THE AGENDA TODAY INCLUDED
A CHART THAT WE- ARE PROVIDED
IN IN THE BUDGET AND THE B. C.
P. THAT WAS- POST. THAT SHOWED-
THE KIND OF MAJOR COST
CATEGORIES AN ESTIMATED COST
FOR THAT SO I WON'T GO INTO ALL
THE DETAIL IN TERMS OF WHAT
THOSE VARIOUS STRINGS OF
ACTIVITY HAVE BEEN AND THAT
CERTAINLY AND I'M HAPPY TO TALK
ABOUT AND EVEN IF PEOPLE HAVE
QUESTIONS BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
RANGED FROM CANOPY IN A MEDICAL
SURGEON. MAXINE'S AND OTHER
VARIOUS- MS NOW BUT POPULAR. IN
AND A LOT OF FOOD WASTE. SO IN
THE JANUARY TWENTY ONE GOT DIED.
WE REFLECT THAT AS- DIRECTORS
BY COSTS OF THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS- IN ABOUT TWO POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL
FUND IMPACT FROM THAT. TO DATE
SINCE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
FINANCES ALSO PROVIDED UPDATES
WRITTEN NOTIFICATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE- REGARDING SORT OF
A CASH FLOW BEHIND THAT IF YOU
WILL SO. SO FAR WE PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IN VARIOUS TRANSFERS AND
APPROPRIATIONS- I'M IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEARS THE
ROSTER AUTHORIZED THROUGH A
COMBINATION OF- THE JURY OFF ON
THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER. I'M
CONTROL SECTION THIRTY SIX FROM
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT. AND THEN THERE WERE
A FEW- RELATED APPROPRIATIONS
NEW TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
SO OF THE THIRTEEN BILLION-
ABOUT EIGHT POINT ONE BILLION
AND I KIND OF A CASH FLOW BASIS
HAS BEEN PROVIDED OUT TO-
DEPARTMENTS TO HELP WITH
VARIOUS ACTIVITIES. SO SPECIFIC
TO THE ACTUAL BCP THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS OF
ONE TIME CHEN FOR OFFLINE. IT
FOR THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THAT. IS ACROSS
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS AND IT
REFLECTS A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
DIRECT RESPONSE EXPENDITURE
ACTIVITIES- OF THAT ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION. THE REQUESTED
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION IN
SPECIFIC DEPARTMENT BUDGETS AND
SO THERE WE SET UP SOME CODE
SPECIFIC ITEMS APPROPRIATIONS
THAT WE CAN- AND THE FUNDING
AUTHORIZED UNTRACKED
INDEPENDENTLY OF OTHER THINGS
TO CAN HELP WITH. WHEN TRACKING
PROCESS IS THAT THE ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION SHOWS UP IN THOSE
PUBLIC SPECIFIC PICK ITEMS WITH
PROLIFERATION. I'M REMAINING
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION ABOUT ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION. IS
ESTIMATED FOR STATEWIDE-
ACTIVITIES THAT RANGE FROM THE
HOSPITAL SURGEON- TESTING IN
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
MINISTRATION BUT THEY'RE ALL
ACTIVITIES WHERE THERE IS A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF- UNCERTAINTY
STILL IN REGARDS TO WHICH
DEPARTMENT SPECIFICALLY WILL
NEED TO MAKE THE EXPENDITURES
AND SO WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS.
KEPT THAT PART OUT SEPARATE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT SPECIFIC
APPROPRIATIONS AND THROUGH ONE
OF THAT WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
THE BUDGET CONTROL SECTIONS IN
LATER- ITEMS OF THE AGENDA HERE
SO I WON'T GET INTO THOSE
SPECIFICALLY BUT THEY'RE ONE OF
THOSE CONTROL SECTIONS- IS THE
MECHANISM THAT WOULD BE USED.
TO EXPAND OUR ALLOCATE AND
EXPAND THE OTHER FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS- A PAST WEEK COSTS. I'M
SO I JUST WOULD KNOW THAT-
MINISTRATION HAS BEEN PROVIDING
A REGULAR FISCAL UPDATES- WE DO
SO IN APRIL MAY AUGUST
NOVEMBER. AND THEN IN THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN JANUARY SO.
PROXIMALLY EVERY COUPLE OF
MONTHS WE'VE BEEN DOING EVERY
TWO MONTHS WE'VE BEEN DOING.
ESTIMATED FISCAL UPDATES AND AS
A PART OF THOSE FISCAL UPDATES.
WE PROVIDE AN ESTIMATED SPLITS
BETWEEN FUND SOURCES SUCH AS
THE GENERAL FUND ANTICIPATED
FEMA REIMBURSEMENTS- USES
SIERRA FUNDS AND OTHER FEDERAL
FUNDS OF PRIVATE FUNDS- AND YES
I'M TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
SPENDING THAT'S KIND OF. WHERE
WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ASSUMES LOOKS
AT THIRTEEN BILLION AND WE
PROPOSE ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
IN- TWENTY TWENTY ONE THROUGH
BCP. WE ALSO NOTED THAT THE CPM
WHICH STILL RINGS TRUE- GIVEN
THE DYNAMIC NATURE OF COVERT
NINETEEN AND THE RESPONSE
EFFORTS. THAT WE ANTICIPATE
THAT THE PROPOSAL WILL BE
UPDATED AS PART OF A MAJOR
REVISION AS WE CONTINUE TO
REFINE. COST ESTIMATES AND AS
DIFFERENT- STREAMS OF ACTIVITY
EVOLVE- I THINK EVERYBODY'S
AWARE THAT BECOME THE STREAMS
OF ACTIVITIES INVOLVED
RELATIVELY QUICKLY. OVER THE
PAST YEAR AS WE RESPONDED OPEN.
WITH THAT I WILL- SEE THE TIME
FOR QUESTIONS- COMMENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- DOES THE L. A.
O. HAVE ANY COMMENTS- YES TRUE
SORT OF OR LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- THE
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO WANT TO
EVALUATE THE MERITS OF EACH OF
THE VARIOUS PROPOSALS MAKING
OUT THE ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
IN PROPOSED SPENDING. INCLUDING
WHETHER THE PROPOSAL IS
JUSTIFIED AND CONSISTENT WITH
ITS PRIORITIES AND REFLECTS THE
LEVEL OF RESOURCES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE BELIEVES IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO CARRY OUT ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES- I'D ALSO NOTE
THAT OUR TO OUR- THE L. A- PUT
TOGETHER A- HAND OUT ON THE-
SPENDING PROPOSED FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND- SPECIFICALLY THAT.
PROPOSAL WHICH MAKES UP OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION OF TH
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION AND I'M
HAPPY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
RECEIVED A COPY OF THAT IF
THAT'S SOMETHING. THAT YOU'D BE
INTERESTED IN HAVING OUR
COMMENTS WERE PRESENTED IN THE-
HELPS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES ON
THAT. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
OKAY THANK YOU SO- COLLEAGUES
IN THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
YES SENATE QUARTERS THE FIGURE
BENCHER- JUST I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS ONE OF THEM IS VERY.
OF VERY SPECIFIC LINE ITEM TYPE
OF QUESTION HOW MUCH. OF THESE
COSTS- ACTUALS ARE INCREASES OF
WOULD CUT BACK OVER TIME AND I
AYE ASSET ONLY BECAUSE I WOULD.
ANTICIPATE THAT THAT WOULD BE
THE CASE THAT I'M- I'M NOT
JUDGING WHETHER OR NOT OVER
TIME- YOU SHOULD OR SHOULD NOT
BE A OF AN ISSUE IN TERMS OF
THESE DOLLARS BUT I JUST WANT I
DON'T SEE A LINE ITEM. THAT
BREAKS THAT OUT. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY- FISCAL SORGEN
STEVENS WITH DEPARTMENT FINANCE
THE FISCAL TABLE- DOESN'T GO
INTO THE LEVEL OF GRANULAR
DETAIL OF OVER TIMES THAT THERE
IS THAT TOP CATEGORY OF STATE
RESPONSE OPERATIONS. TO THE
OVERTIME THAT'S BEING- WORKED
BY VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS AND WILL
BE A PART OF THAT LINE ITEM.
AND CERTAINLY YOU KNOW THE
AMOUNT OF OVERTIME THAT'S
THAT'S BEING WORKED OUT VERY
STRONG DEPARTMENTS DEPARTMENT
THAT MEAN FOR EXAMPLE- YES THIS
YEAR AND- AND THEY'VE GOT STAFF
THAT ARE WORKING YOU KNOW.
FUSON LOTS OF OVERTIME AND
CERTAINLY AND CDPH ANOTHER HHS
AGENCIES AS WELL- IF IT AFFECTS
IT IN. VARIOUS FROM DEPARTMENT
TO DEPARTMENT BUT CERTAINLY
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
OVERTIME. HE SAID HAS IT BEEN.
HOW MUCH OF THAT HAS BEEN
DRIVEN BY- YOU KNOW ABSENCE AND
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC OR DO WE
KNOW. I DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC
NUMBERS THAT QUANTIFY THAT
RIGHT NOW AGAIN I THINK IT
WOULD VERY SUBSTANTIALLY FROM
DEPARTMENT TO DEPARTMENT SO FOR
EXAMPLE LIKE CDC ARE IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT OKAY BACK FILLING
POSTS YOU KNOW WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT DRIVER OVER TIME
FOR THEM- IT MAY BE LESS OF AN
ISSUE FOR OTHER DEPARTMENTS I
THINK IT'S- YOU KNOW KIND OF
BACKFILLING ASPECT. WOULD KIND
OF COME INTO PLAY WITH MORE
WITH DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE KIND
OF SET HOST HI YOUR
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR WE HAVE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO BE ON
CERTAIN DUTIES IN CERTAIN SPOTS
AT CERTAIN TIMES. AT SOME POINT
THAT INFORMATION MIGHT BE OF
INTEREST NOT. CONCERNED BUT IN
TERMS OF SUPPORTING THE ITEM
TODAY AND- I GUESS AT ONE LEVEL
IT IS WHAT IT IS BUT IT- IT
WOULD BE. OF SOME INTEREST TO.
TO UNDERSTAND THE BREAK DOWN
HOW MUCH OF IT DRIVEN BY.
INCREASED- INTENSITY OF CARE
ACUTE CARE DRIVEN BY INMATES
HOW MUCH. THE IN TERMS OF.
ABSENCES IN THE LEGISLATURE
SERVICE TAKING A BROADER ISSUES
IN TERMS OF PAID SICK LEAVE AND
SO FORTH AND- MY HELP. HELP US
UNDERSTAND SO. I WOULD JUST
EIGHTY OF. THAT BREAK BREAKDOWN
IS- IN IN SOMEBODY'S HR-
SPREADSHEET SOMEWHERE AND IT
CAN BE EASILY DISSEMINATED TO
THE COMMITTEE I'M SURE IT WOULD
BE OF INTERESTTO EVERYONE- YOU
KNOW IN THE NEAR TERM. BUT
AGAIN NOT. I'M I'M NOT. HINGING
MAYA. SUPPORTER UNDERSTANDING
OF THE ISSUE ON THAT. THAT THE
BIGGER QUESTION I HAVE REALLY
IS ONE THAT I THINK. I COULD
PROBABLY BRING UP. ANYWHERE IN
THE NEXT SEVERAL ITEMS WHICH HE
DID MENTION THE CONTROL CONTROL
SECTION. IN IT I THOUGHT IF OF
ARE YOU READY WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE REMAINING ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION. WOULD BE-
ESSENTIALLY REPORTED OUT
PURSUANT TO THE TO THE CONTROL
SECTION ACT I'M NOT SURE WHICH
ONE AND TWO OTHERS- I THINK
TWENTY CONTROL SECTION TWENTY
EIGHT MIGHT HAVE SOME. SOME
RELEVANCE OR THIRTY SIX BUT-
LET ME JUST SAY CONTROL SECTION
WHAT I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
IS. WHAT DOES THAT ACTUALLY
LOOK LIKE. YOU KNOW I CAN
UNDERSTAND ATTEMPTED COMPLIANCE
TO THE CONTROL SECTION AND I
APPRECIATE THAT I TAKE YOU. OF
YOUR FOR YOUR TO COMPLETE
CREDIBLE IN THE HEAD BUT WHERE
DOES IT GO WHAT IS THE PATH
INTO THIS SUBCOMMITTEE. HIS
HEARING THIS ITEM TODAY BECAUSE
OSTENSIBLY WE HAVE JURISDICTION
TO SOME DEGREE OVER. OVER THE
SUBJECT MATTER- BUT I'M NOT
CLEAR IF THE CONTROL SECTION.
WOOD ESSENTIALLY CLOSED LOOP
WITH THIS SUB COMMITTEE IN
TERMS OF ONGOING OVERSIGHT I'M
I'M A LITTLE WORRIED THAT THIS
THE COMPOSITION OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE IS DIFFERENT THAN.
OTHER LEGISLATIVE SUB BODIES OR
POLICY COMMITTEES YOU KNOW
WHERE THAT INFORMATION MY VERY
WILL SHOW UP- BUT IT MAY NOT BY
INCLUDE A IS THE SAME THE SAME
MEMBERS WHO HAVE- SERVE WEIGHED
IN ON THE ON TODAY'S ITEM FOR
EXAMPLE SO I'M I'M JUST TRYING
TO. UNDERSTAND HOW. IT'S REALLY
THE PATHWAY FOR INFORMATION I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HERE. YOU
KNOW IT. IT WITH A CONCERN ON
MY PART ABOUT HOW DO I DO MY
JOB IN TERMS OF ONGOING
OVERSIGHT WHAT WHETHER I'M-
WHETHER I'M IN AGREEMENT EVERY
SINGLE TIME THAT THIS IS A GOOD
EXPENDITURE. OR AN APPROPRIATE
EXPENDITURES SWORD BESIDE THE
POINT FOR THE QUESTION I'M
ASKING. I THINK. IN GENERAL
PROBABLY LEGISLATIVE
COLLABORATION AROUND THESE
ISSUES WHEN WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF PANDEMIC IS PROBABLY GOING
TO BE THE NORM IS PROBABLY
APPROPRIATE- GIVEN THAT- YOU
KNOW THE MONEY HAS TO GO OUT
THE DOOR SO TO SPEAK BUT GOOD
WITHIN THE OTHER END OF THE
CONTINUUM OF ON THAT OR THE
PENDULUM IS- IF. IF WE HAVE A
RULE THAT SAYS A CONTROL
SECTION THIS IS. OTHERS A SORT
OF A RIGHT TO LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OR- THEY DID THAT IT
SHOULD HAPPEN WITH THE PATHWAY
DOESN'T. YOU KNOW NAVIGATE
RIGHT BACK TO THE SAME
LEGISLATORS WHO HAVE BEEN
TRACKING THE ISSUE UP TO THIS
POINT IF YOU SEE WERE MY
CONCERN IS THERE AND I'M I
WONDER WHAT YOUR UNDERSTANDING
IS I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE. A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING THAT I DO
OF. HOW THAT INFORMATION GETS.
BACK TO THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE- YOU KNOW OKAY I
WOULD I WOULD ASSUME IT. ONE
POSSIBLE LEGISLATIVE RESPONSE
TO THAT WOULD BE AT THE CALL OF
THE CHAIR- YOU KNOW WE COULD
RECONVENE NO AROUND INFORMATION
THAT CAME INTO THE CONTROL
SECTION BUT I'M I'M NOT SURE IF
THAT AWARENESS IS GOING TO BE
CREATED BY. THE INFORMATION
PATHWAY ON THAT SO THANK YOU
I'M SORRY FOR THE LONG QUESTION
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU
UNDERSTOOD WHERE I WAS COMING
FROM THERE. YEAH ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE THE CONTEXT- YES I
THINK I CAN ADD SOME CLARITY
THERE. SO THE WAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OUT FRAME WORK
FOR THE BUDGET YEAR WORKS. IS
THAT THE ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION PROPOSED FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR. ONE POINT FOUR BILLION IS
ACTUALLY PROPOSED IN SPECIFIC
DEPARTMENTS BUDGETS LIKE WE
WOULD ANY OTHER BUDGET ITEMS.
SO ALL OF THOSE WILL BE HEARD.
THROUGH THIS REGULAR BUDGET
PROCESS THE HEARINGS AND
ENACTING THE BUDGET JUST LIKE
EVERY OTHER BUDGETS REFLECT
THAT'S ONE POINT. FOUR OF THE
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION. THAT'S
HOW THAT WILL BE. AND HANDLES
RELIGIOUSLY OVERSIGHT. AND THE
LEGISLATIVE. PERSPECTIVE DURING
ANY PIECE FOUR HUNDRED. THAT'S
THE PART WHERE YOU DON'T CRY
HAVE CLAY AROUND WHICH
DEPARTMENT SPECIFICALLY NEED TO
MAKE. HE SPENT A HUNDRED YEARS
AND SO RATHER THAN PUT THE
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY INTO
DEPARTMENTS BUDGETS WE DON'T
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THEY NEED
IT YET. THE PROPOSAL WAS TO
KEEP THAT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS SEPARATE AND IT'S
ACTUALLY CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN
POINT NINE TWO THAT WOULD BE
THE MECHANISM THAT WE WOULD USE
FOR THAT. WHAT AND WHAT CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN POINT NINETEEN
DOES IS IT AUTHORIZES THE
CONTINUED USE OF THE DRILL
MECHANISM IN THE BUDGET. TO GET
A LITTLE MORE CLARITY AROUND
THAT SO AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
THREE L. I. IS THE FUNDING
MECHANISM THAT THE STATE
PRIMARILY USES WHENEVER IT'S
RESPONDING. TO MAJOR DISASTERS.
SO WITH WORKS IS THE AND YOU
MISTER PART OF FINANCE FRANKLY-
PROVIDES ALLOCATION NOTICES.
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WHENEVER IT IS GOING
TO ALLOCATE FUNDING. INTO THREE
ARE. FOR USE BY DEPARTMENTS TO
RESPOND TO DISASTER. SO TH WAY
THAT IT WORKS. IN A PRACTICAL
SENSE WITH A QUARTER MILLION
DOLLARS. IS ONCE WE DETERMINED.
WHICH DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO SPEND
A PORTION OF THAT. THERE WOULD
BE A NOTICE SENT TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
THAT SAYS WE ESTIMATE WE DIEM
THERE'S- X. AMOUNT OF DOLLARS
THAT WOULD BE USED FOR. AND
WHICH DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO.
AND THAT WOULD BE OUR NOTE TO
SAY THIS THIS IS HOW IT
PLANNING ON USING IT IT WOULD
BE USED FOR COSTS THAT ARE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATE
OF COST CATEGORIES THAT WE SAW
IN FISCAL UPDATES WE DO THAT
BLUE TABLE THAT YOU SEE IN THE
AGENDA. THAT WOULD. BE USED
TOWARDS THOSE TAXES COST
ACTIVITIES. TYPICALLY WHAT
WE'VE DONE ANY TIME WE HAVE A
NEW ACTIVITY THAT'S OUTSIDE OF
WHAT'S OUTLINED IN THAT UPDATE
IS WE- ARRANGE TO DO. BRIEFINGS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
IDENTIFY HATE WHATEVER EXCEPT
FOR EXAMPLE- GOOD RECENT
EXAMPLE BUT YEAH FOR IN
DECEMBER FOR EXAMPLE- THERE IS
A NEED TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR SMALL
BUSINESS ASSISTANCE- AND FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS WAS MADE AVAILABLE FOR
THAT PURPOSE. WE ARRANGED-
MEETINGS AND BRIEFINGS WITH
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE WITH
STAFF AND IN PROVIDE
NOTIFICATION LETTERS TO EXPLAIN
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND WHAT THE
ESTIMATED COST WAS. BUT THE
MECHANISM TO ACTUALLY MAKE THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE. TO THE TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS A
BUSINESS AND OVERSIGHT. OF
THIS. IS A MESS UP WITH THEIR
ACTUAL NAME IS SORRY I GET TO
PLAY WITH THE ACRONYMS- BUT
MECHANISM FOR PROVIDING THE
FUNDING WAS THROUGH THE FIRST
THREE HOURS AND SO THAT'S HOW
WE WOULD. WE'VE PROPOSED
CONTINUING THAT SAME MECHANISM
THAT WE'VE BEEN USING.
THROUGHOUT COATED- AND TO
CONTINUE TO DO OUR FISCAL
UPDATES THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
BRIEFINGS WITH- STAFF MEMBERS
TO EXPLAIN NEW NEW ISSUES AND
NEW ACTIVITIES AS THEY ARISE. I
THINK IT COULD BE- SECRETARIES
THE THAT IN THE NEXT- THE NEXT
ISSUE OF BUNDY BUDGET SPENDING
AUTHORITY WILL GET AN OVERVIEW
OF THAT AND MAYBE THAT WILL
HELP AS WELL. YEAH I DIDN'T I
DIDN'T WANT TO JUMP AHEAD IT
WAS JUST LIKE YEAH YEP THE
OPPORTUNE OF FULL UP ON HIS ON
THE MISTER BENSON'S CONTROL
SECTION COMMENT YEAH WHILE WE
WERE STILL ON THIS ITEM YES BUT
YEAH I WILL I WOULD LIKE TO GO.
THROUGH TO UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
BIT. MORE LATER WHEN WE GET TO
THE ITEM AMID OF THE- IT TOO
HOW MUCH OF IS. AND TO. GRIEF
YOU KNOW THE LARGEST VERSUS
AFTER THE FACT SO FOR FOLKS WHO
WERE LISTENING IN AND- THERE IS
YOUR FORESHADOWING OF WHAT- I
THINK I WOULD BE ASKING ABOUT
WE GET TO THAT ITEM THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU- THANK YOU
SENATOR I AM. I AGREE WITH YOU
THERE IS THE IS THERE A
PARTICULAR EXAMPLE HERE BUT I
THINK- HOPEFULLY OVERALL ONCE
WE GO THROUGH ALL THE VARIOUS
MECHANISMS- THAT WOULD PROBABLY
WILL JUMP BACK TO THIS WITH
WITH SOME MORE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. SIR NEWMAN. OKAY ALL
RIGHT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET'S MOVE ON THEN. TO AND I
ALREADY ASKED BELIAU. FOR THAT.
SORT OF BORED- LEGISLATIVE
ANALYSTS OFFICE- YES WE I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO- ANSWER SENATOR
CORTESE'S QUESTION A BIT MORE
IN THE NEXT- ITEM ON THE
CONTROL SECTION WHERE WE CAN
TALK A BIT ABOUT THE EXACT
LEVEL OF INFORMATION THAT'S
REQUIRED AND AS WE'LL TALK
ABOUT IN GREATER DETAIL AT THAT
POINT OUR OFFICE DOES HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE LEVEL OF
INFORMATION THAT IS REQUIRED TO
BE PROVIDED TO THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT I'M HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
THAT LATER IN THE YEAR GREATER
DEATH. AND WE HAVE SEVERAL-
ISSUES ARE CONNECTED AND
RELATED TO THIS FROM THE-
BUDGET SPENDING AUTHORITY TO
SPECIFIC BUDGET CONTROLLED
SECTION SO. I THINK THIS WILL
ALL ADD UP I THINK HOPEFULLY.
ONE GREATER CLARITY ON OUR
PART- AND ALSO WHAT DO WE
BELIEVE- THE AUTHORITY SHOULD
BE AND- WHAT ARE THE CONDITIONS
ARE REQUIREMENTS FOR THAT
AUTHORITY. SO LET'S MOVE ON IF
WE CAN TO- ISSUE EIGHT. OF
BUDGET SPENDING AUTHORITY.
WHO'S GOING. TO SORT OF BORED-
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS OFFICE. I
BELIEVE BY YOUR AND RICK THAT
WE PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
VARIOUS EMERGENCY SPENDING
AUTHORITIES AVAILABLE TO THE
GOVERNOR AND SOME BRIEF
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW THEY'VE
YEARS BEEN USED RELATED TO COPE
WITH NINETEEN- TO BEGIN WITH
THERE'S TWO MAIN STATUTORY
PROVISIONS THAT GET THE
GOVERNOR EMERGENCY SPENDING
AUTHORITIES ARE THE FIRST ALL
TALK ABOUT IS THE CALIFORNIA
DISASTER ASSISTANCE SACKS EVA.
IT WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR AND LATER AMENDED
TO CREATE THE DISASTER RESPONSE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS ACCOUNT
THIS IS THE JURY- ACCOUNT THAT
MR BENSON HAS BEEN REFERENCING
STATUTE GIVES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE AUTHORITY TO
ALLOCATE FUNDS FROM DARIO OFFER
EMERGENCY RELATED COSTS UPON
NOTIFICATION TO JAIL BC HOWEVER
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENTS ON THE
AMOUNT OR TYPE OF INFORMATION
THAT MUST BE PROVIDED WITH THAT
TYPE OF NOTIFICATION. I THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINE ALLOCATED
SEVEN POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN THIS MANNER FROM- AS OF
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH FOR CODE
NINETEEN RELATED RESPONSE- CDA
AND NATIONALLY LIMITS THE USE
OF DREAMLAND TO ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS. TO WITHIN A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS OF THE
DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY
HOWEVER THAT- AUTHORIZATION TO
USUARIO AND CAN BE EXTENDED AND
NINE HUNDRED TWENTY DAY
INCREMENTS. THROUGH THE END OF
THE FISCAL YEAR IN WHICH THE
FIRST EXTENSION WAS NAY. SO
WITH RESPECT TO CORBETT
NINETEEN THAT MEANS THAT TRIO
UP. WILL BE UNAVAILABLE FOR
KOBE NINETEEN RESPONSE- AT THE
END OF THIS FISCAL YEAR BECAUSE
THE FIRST EXPANSION TOOK PLACE
ON JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY- THE
INTENT BEHIND THIS TIME LIMIT.
WAS THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAD
INTENDED FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
TO SEEK FOR US FUNDING FOR
ONGOING EMERGENCIES THROUGH THE
STATE BUDGET ACT IF THEY'RE
GOING TO EXTEND BEYOND THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT TRIO- ISN'T
IT CAN BE USED FOR. ON THE NECK
MAJOR OF STAB THAT- EMERGING
SPENDING AUTHORITY COMES FROM
THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT WHICH WAS CREATED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY. THE
CALIFORNIA REGENCY SERVICES ACT
PROVIDES THE ADMINISTRATION A
WIDE RANGE OF EMERGENCY POWERS
ARE WITH RESPECT TO EMERGENCY
SPENDING POWERS IT ALLOWS THE
ADMINISTRATION TO SPEND ANY
AVAILABLE FUNDS TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCY. IT ALSO ALLOWS THE
ADMINISTRATION TO RE DIRECT
STATE DEPARTMENT PERSONNEL
PROPERTY APPOINTMENT AND
APPROPRIATIONS TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCY UNDER CAESAR THERE IS
NO APPROVAL OR NOTIFICATION
REQUIRED- IT'S BEEN USED IN
DIFFERENT WAYS TO RESPOND TO
COPE WITH NINETEEN. FOR EXAMPLE
FUNDS- THAT WERE FREED UP DUE
TO THE DECREASE AND THEY MAY
POPULATION WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION'S. WE'RE
REDIRECTED TO MITIGATE THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS AND PRISONS
IN ADDITION ABOUT NINETEEN
HUNDRED STATE EMPLOYEES WERE
REDIRECTED TO CONTRACT RACING-
DUTIES. ALSO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS- USE THE GOVERNOR'S
POWERS UNDER THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT TO ADD ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO THREE HOURS AND THEN
SUBSEQUENTLY ALLOCATED THAT
FUNDING OUT THREE THREE HOUR.
IN ADDITION TO THESE BROAD
EMERGENCY POWERS THAT APPLY TO
ALL EMERGENCIES THERE'S ALSO
CASES WHERE THEY EMERGED WHERE
THE LEGISLATURE HAS PROVIDED
THE ADMINISTRATION WITH.
EMERGENCY SPENDING AUTHORITIES
FOR SPECIFIC EMERGENCIES- THIS
HAPPENED WITH RESPECT TO COVERT
NINETEEN WHEN CONTROL SECTION
THIRTY SIX WAS ADDED TO THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TO. TWENTY
BUDGET ON MARCH SEVENTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY. THAT CONTROL
SECTION MADE UP TO ONE BILLION
AVAILABLE FOR COVERT NINETEEN
RELATED PURPOSES IT REQUIRED A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR ADVANCE
NOTIFICATION POURED TO JAIL B.
C. THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE BEFORE THE FUNDS
COULD BE SET SPENT. BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALLOCATED
EIGHT HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
POINT EIGHT MILLION THROUGH
CONTROL SECTION THIRTY SIX. BUT
IT WAS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
THE CURRENT BUDGET PHAM AND SO
IT IS CURRENTLY UNAVAILABLE TO
THE ADMINISTRATION. ON ANOTHER
IMPORTANT SOURCE OF EMERGENCY
SPENDING IS- AUTHORITY TO SPEND
FEDERAL FUNDS- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
AUTHORIZED TO SPEND FEDERAL
FUNDS WITHOUT PROVISION BEING
MADE FOR IT THROUGH THE BUDGET
ACT. FROM IN CERTAIN CASES THE
LEGISLATURE HAS MADE SPECIFIC
PROVISION TO SPEND FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT WRE PROVIDED FOR
KOBE NINETEEN FOR EXAMPLE
CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN NINETY
WAS ADDED TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET TO GIVE THE
ADMINISTRATION. AUTHORITY TO
ALLOCATE NINE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN BONDS FROM THE
FEDERAL CORONAVIRUS RELIEF ARM
FUND. THE CONTROL SECTION LAID
OUT ALLOWABLE USES OF THOSE
DOLLARS ON HOWEVER IT DID ALLOW
THE ADMINISTRATION TO REDIRECT
THOSE FUNDS TO OTHER PURPOSES
BUT REQUIRED A TEN DAY
NOTIFICATION. TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET- COMMITTEE
FOR SUCH RE ALLOCATIONS. AT
THIS POINT ALL OF THE MONEY
AUTHORIZED BY ELEVEN- CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN POINT NINETY HAS
BEEN ALLOCATED. THE LEGISLATURE
ALSO ADDED CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN POINT NINE FIVE TWO THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT TO
GIVE THE ADMINISTRATION AT THE
READY TO ALLOCATE FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR TESTING AND
CONTRACT TRACING. IT WAS LATER
AMENDED TO ALLOW FOR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE TO REFLECT NEW
FEDERAL LEGISLATION MAKING
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR THOSE
PURPOSES. TROLL ELEVEN POINT
NINE FIVE REQUIRES A TEN DAY ON
NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE-
HOWEVER IN. OFTEN IT'S THE CASE
THAT FEDERAL FUNDS WILL BECOME
AVAILABLE FOR AN EMERGENCY FAN.
AND IT WILL BE CONTEMPLATED IN
THE BUDGET AND IN THOSE. CASES
THE BUDGET TYPICALLY INCLUDES
CONTROL SECTION TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH IS TO GIVE THE
ADMINISTRATION FLEXIBILITY TO
ALLOCATE- ON ANTICIPATED
FEDERAL OR PRIVATE FUNDS. TO
DEPARTMENTS THAT THEY CAN BE
SPENT SO LONG AS THEY MEET
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS-
SPECIFICALLY THEY OBVIOUSLY
HAVE TO BE ON ANTICIPATED AT
THE TIME OF THE BUDGET- THEY
CAN ONLY BE SPENT FOR SPECIFIED
PURPOSES CONSISTENT WITH STATE
LAW. AND THEY CAN'T IMPOSE A
REQUIREMENT TO SPEND OTHER
STATE FUNDS ON. FUNDS ABOVE A
CERTAIN THRESHOLD CAN ONLY BE
ALLOCATED DEPARTMENTS WITH A
THIRTY DAY NOTIFICATION TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. HOWEVER THAT WAITING
TIME CAN BE WAIVED- BY THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND OFTEN HAS BEEN
WITH RESPECT TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN AND CONTROL SECTION
TWENTY EIGHT IS BEEN USED TO
ALLOCATE ROUGHLY SIX BILLION IN
FUNDS RELATED TO. PROVIDE
NINETEEN. THAT COVERS THE
MAJOR- THIRTIES FOR EMERGENCY
SPENDING I'M HAPPY. TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY DO WE WANT TO
HEAR FROM. OKAY FIFTY. I HAVE A
COUPLE OF WE DON'T HEAR FROM
ANYBODY ELSE RIGHT- FINANCE
THAT'S RIGHT THANK FINANCED.
THANK YOU MANAGER CAN SEE
BENTSEN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAVE NOTHING SPECIFIC TO ADD TO
THAT I THINK THAT WAS A GOOD
COULD ARGUE WITH THE RECENT
STORIES- AGES WOULD NOTED THAT-
WE'RE WE'VE RECEIVED THE L. S.
REPORT AND RECOMMENDATIONS AT
THIS WEEKEND SO WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THOSE- PRECIADO. IT
INFORMATION PUT OUT- THIS MAKE
UP A WE GET THROUGH TO THE-
PROPOSED BUDGET CONTROL
SECTIONS BUT I WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO GET A SORT OF A SUMMARY
OF HOW ALL OF THESE-
MECHANISMS- FOR SPENDING HAVE
BEEN USED OVER THE LAST YEAR.
OF WHAT WHAT IS THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT HAS BEEN
USED THROUGH THIS- AND I
NOTICED SOME OF COURSE ARE
EVERYWHERE FROM. NO NOTICE TWO
THREE DAYS NOTICE TO TEN DAYS
TO THIRTY DAYS- THEY'RE ALL
OVER. THERE ALL OVER THE LOT
AND IT IT APPEARS THAT IT'S
MOSTLY. NOTICE TO THE
LEGISLATION THAT- BUT THAT'S
ABOUT IT RIGHT IT'S NOT A
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE MERGING SEA-
THAT THEN THEY CAN JUST GET
SPENT WITHOUT ANY KIND OF
FURTHER APPROVAL BY THE
LEGISLATURE SO IT'S NOTICED. I
GUESS I'M TRYING TO GET A
PICTURE OF HOW MUCH AUTHORITY.
IN TERMS OF AMOUNT OF MONEY AND
HOW IT CAN BE SPENT WHERE DOES
THE VOICE OF THE LEGISLATURE-
COME INTO THIS PROCESS- BECAUSE
THE- HE SAYS THEIR PIECES OF
LARGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY. SORT OF
BORED- THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'D BE HAPPY
TO SPEAK A BIT TO THAT- ONE
PIECE OF CONTEXT THAT I THINK
IS HELPFUL TO KNOW IS THAT ON
WALL STATUTE SAYS THAT ONLY
NOTIFICATION IS REQUIRED IT IS
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT-
TYPICALLY IF JAIL B. C. RAISES
OBJECTION TO SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOTIFYING
THEM ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL OFTEN RECONSIDER IT THOUGH
IT'S CRITICAL TO KNOW. THEY ARE
NOT LEGALLY REQUIRED TO
RECONSIDER IT SO IN SOME WAYS
THAT CAN'T THAT DOES PROVIDE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO RAISE CONCERNS
THAT CAN INFLUENCE THE PROCESS
THOUGH AS I MENTIONED IT'S NOT
REQUIRED FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
TO ADHERE TO ANY OBJECTIONS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT HAVE.
IN TERMS OF THE ROLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY VARIES
DEPENDING ON WHAT SPECIFIC
AUTHORITY- YOU'RE YOU'RE
SPEAKING ABOUT- WHEN IT COMES
TO FOR EXAMPLE CONTROL SECTION
THIRTY SIX. ARE THE MAIN ROLE
OF THE LEGISLATURE THERE WAS TO
DETERMINE THE TOTAL AMOUNT TO
MAKE AVAILABLE THROUGH THE
CONTROL SECTION AS WELL AS- TO
OVERSEE IT THROUGH THE
NOTIFICATION PROCESS- ON THAT
SORT OF ONE ON ONE END OF THE
EMERGENCY- SPENDING SPECTRUM ON
THE OTHER END OF THE EMERGENCY
SPEND. SPENDING SPECTRUM IS THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY SERVICES
ACT WHICH REALLY CONTEMPLATES
VERY LITTLE ROLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND AS WE TALK
ABOUT FURTHER WE- WE DO HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT- THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE OF EMERGENCY
SPENDING BE ADJUSTED TO CREATE.
A GREATER ROLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE BUT I'LL BE
SPEAKING ABOUT THAT LATER IN
TODAY'S HEARING OKAY- OKAY WILL
HAVE MRE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS- AND GENEROUSLY FRANK.
ALL I'M SORRY AND THIS WAS
GONNA ADD TO THAT IS DOUBLE THE-
YEAH- SO JUST WANTED TO
CURRENTLY HERE YOUR QUESTION
LITTLE BIT ASKED AND ON HAVE
BEEN ALEX THROUGH THE NECK. I
AND EARLIER- THAT ABOUT EIGHT
BILLION. HAS BEEN ALLOCATED
THROUGH THE MECHANISMS THAT ARE
AUTHORIZED TO THE MERCHANT
SERVICES ACT SO UNDER THIRTEEN
BILLION WITH ESTIMATED COST.
ABOUT EIGHT MILLION HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED THROUGH THE USE OF
THE EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT
ESSENTIALLY. THAT HAS ALL BEEN
DONE. THROUGH A COMBINATION OF
SO ABOUT- SEVEN. FIVE SEVEN
POINT TWO BILLION OF THAT HAS
BEEN DONE THROUGH THE THREE
ALONG WITH THE DISASTER
RESPONSE EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
ACCOUNT THAT MECHANISM ALL OF
THE FUNDING WE'VE BEEN
UTILIZING IT EMERGENCY ROOMS
ACT SERVICES ACT HAS BEEN DONE
THROUGH THE TRIO MECHANISM THE
CODE NINETEEN OF LAST YEAR AND
THAT HAS TOTALED ABOUT SEVEN
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS. AND
THE REMAINDER OF THAT- EIGHT
POINT ONE ROUGHLY IS WHAT WAS
DONE THROUGH THE CONTROL
SECTION THIRTY SIX IN THE
BUDGET AFTER THOSE NINETEEN AS
WELL AS A COUPLE OF-
APPROPRIATIONS THE LEGISLATURE
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
BY STAFF. IN TERMS OF AMOUNTS
THOSE ARE THE AMOUNTS. THAT
HAVE BEEN USED TO THIS PROCESS.
TERMS OF NEW. I THINK THE L. A.
O. IS CORRECT IN THAT. THE
STATUTE. OF THE BAR THAT IT
SETS IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
REQUIRED- IS PRETTY LOW BUT I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS. GONE
WELL ABOVE. THAT BAR BY MAKING
SURE THAT WE- DO WHAT'S
REQUIRED NOTIFICATION LETTERS
BUT WE'VE ALSO SET UP THE EVERY
TWO MONTHS WILL UPDATES WE'VE
DONE BRIEFINGS. AND THE L. O.
U. S. HAS DONE- REGULAR
BRIEFINGS WITH MEMBERS ON
VARIOUS ACTIVITIES THROUGHOUT
THE LAST YEAR. AS THINGS
INVOLVED WITH CODE NINETEEN.
AND FINANCES DONE- BRIEFINGS
WITH NUMBERS. AS A NEW
ACTIVITIES HAVE BEEN ANNOUNCED
INCOME FORWARD. AND THEN WE
CONTINUE TO THE FISCAL SO I
THINK THE IN THE ONLY WORK.
WHICH IS ON THE STUDENTS ME
THAT LIKE SUPER. WE GET THAT
MANY PRECIADO MEDIA DISCUSS
MORE. WITH LAW REQUIRES BUT
ALSO TO MAKE SURE THIS CAN THAT
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING WELL
BEYOND JUST THAT BARE MINIMUM
IS ALLEGED THAT THE LAW.
REQUIRES YOU KNOWLEDGE IN THE
NEED. TO WORK IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. OF COURSE
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW THAT.
SOMETHING LIKE THE PANDEMIC
THAT NOBODY HAS ANY IDEA FROM
WEEK TO WEEK MONTH TO MONTH A
LOT OF THINGS THAT WILL BE
HAPPENING AND WE'RE TRYING OUR
BEST THAT. MINISTRATIONS TRYING
THEIR BEST. OF BUT WE ALL
REPRESENT DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE WHERE- THE ISSUE
COULD HAVE A DIFFERENT IMPACT.
A DIFFERENT PART OF THE
POPULATION IN THE RESIDENTS AND
SO- IT IT REALLY MAKES A
DIFFERENCE TO BE ABLE TO VOICE
THAT. WE COULD SEE THAT EVERY
IN EVERY ISSUE AND- IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC- OKAY POLICE ANY
OTHER ON THIS WE'LL WE'LL GET
THROUGH THE- REST OF THE-
FUNDING MECHANISMS AND
AUTHORITY. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON
THEN THAT'S THE- NUMBER. YOU
SHOULD NINE. DO WE GO TO EVERY
YEAR WE GET THAT OKAY ISSUE NO
NINE ISSUE NINE OKAY YES LIST
WAUKESHA NINE PLEASE. IN STEVEN
APARTMENT- ISSUE NINE IS IN
REGARDS TO CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN POINT NINE ONE. THAT WAS
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THAT CONTROL SECTION
INCLUDES TWO COMPONENTS THAT
ARE BOTH AIMED AT FACILITATING
ADAPTING THE STATE SCHOOL WOULD
NINETEEN DIRECT RESPONSE
FUNDING ANY. NEEDS AT THEIR
FUNDING AS THE NEEDS OF ALSO
MENTIONED. PREVIOUSLY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
INCLUDES ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS THAT- PROPOSED IN ITEMS
APPROPRIATION WITHIN SPECIFIC
DEPARTMENT BUDGETS. THE FIRST
COMPONENT OF CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN POINT NINE ONE. PROVIDES
THE ABILITY FOR THE FUNDING TO
BE TRANSFERRED BETWEEN THE
ITEMS FOR RESPECTIVE
DEPARTMENTS AND THE REASON
BEHIND THAT PROPOSAL. IS THAT
WE HAVE FOUND THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC IS THAT
SOMETIMES THE DEPARTMENT THAT
WE THINK IS GOING TO BE NEEDED
TO SAY CONTRACT FOR A SIMPLE
EXAMPLE PERHAPS SHOULD BE
CONTRACTING FOR NURSING STAFF
THAT'S BEEN USED FOR BOTH
HOSPITAL MEDICAL SURGE IN THIS
AND RECENTLY FOR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION ADMINISTRATION. SO
THOSE CONTRACTS ARE TYPICALLY-
HELD BY EITHER DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WERE THE ANSWER.
AND SOMETIMES WHICH DEPARTMENT
NEEDS TO BE IN A CONTRACT CAN
CAN VERY SO THE IDEA BEHIND
THIS PROVISION IN THE CONTROL
SECTION IS TO SAY THAT IF WE
WERE. REVERBERATED FUNDING FOR
AN ACTIVITY IN STATE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH BUDGET BUT IT
TURNS OUT THAT MS A NEEDS TO BE
THE DEPARTMENT TO ENTER THE
CONTRACT ACTUALLY EXPEND THE
FUNDS. IT GIVES US THE ABILITY
TO MOVE THE FUNDING BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENTS IT WOULD BE FOR THE
SAME ACTIVITIES BUT IT ALLOWS
IT TO BE MOVED BETWEEN
DEPARTMENTS IF THE DEPARTMENT
THAT NEEDS TO MAKE THE
EXPENDITURE CHANGES. AS THE
ENDEMIC KIND OF EVOLVES.
RESPONSE RESPONSES PENTECOST-
IT ALSO WOULD ALLOW FOR THE-
DEPARTMENT FINANCE TO DECREASE
THE AMOUNT THREE IN THOSE ITEMS
I KNOW THAT IT DOES NOT.
PROVIDE THE ABILITY TO INCREASE
I THINK THAT'S WORTH NOTING BUT
IT DOES ALLOW THAT. THE ABILITY
TO DECREASE AND THE IDEA BEHIND
THAT IS TO SAY THAT. YOU KNOW
WE KNOWLEDGE THAT OUR COST
ESTIMATES ARE JUST THAT
ESTIMATES- YOUR FINGERS
CROSSED. THINGS WILL GO EVEN
BETTER THAN THE ESTIMATES
ASSUME AND MAYBE WE WON'T NEED
TO SPEND ALL OF THE ESTIMATED
FUNDING. AND IF THAT'S THE CASE
IT WOULD GIVE US THE ABILITY TO
REMOVE SOME OF THAT FORTY FROM
DEPARTMENTS BUDGETS IF IT'S NOT
IF IT DOESN'T NEED TO BE THERE.
BASED ON HOW THAT THE ENDEMIC
EVOLVES. THE SECOND COMPONENT
OF CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN POINT
NINE ONE IS SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO FEDERAL AND PRIVATE
FUNDS- MR SODERBERGH- LOOTED
EARLIER TO- THERE FREQUENTLY
pCOMES. AVAILABLE OUTSIDE OF THE
PERIOD WITHIN THE BUDGET CAN
ANTICIPATE- CONTEMPLATE. THIS
INCLUSION- NORMALLY THAT WOULD
BE HANDLED THROUGH CONTROL
SECTION TWENTY EIGHT I THINK.
WE PROPOSED THIS PORTION OF A
LOT CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN
POINT NINE ONE- BECAUSE SECTION
TWENTY EIGHT KIND OF TYPICALLY
IS CONTEMPLATING IN A ONE OFF
DEPARTMENT SPECIFIC INCREASES
AND GENERALLY NOT TO THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE A LARGE
FEDERAL PACKAGE LIKE THE KERRS
ACTOR OTHER THINGS THAT COME
OUT NOT THAT IT COULDN'T BE
ADAPTED TO. BE USED THAT WAY
BUT OUR PERSPECTIVE WAS THAT.
WITH THE PANDEMIC LONG THIS
FUNDING IS COMING IN FOR
ACTIVITIES THAT NEED TO BE.
ROLLED OUT FIRST WANTED TO
IMMEDIATELY AND THE SCALE IN
TERMS OF BOTH THE NUMBER OF
DEPARTMENTS IMPACTED AND THE
RELATIVELY LARGE SO WE PROPOSED
THIS CONTROL SECTION AS A
ALTERNATIVE MEANS OF. BEING
ABLE TO MAKE FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT HAS IDENTIFIED FOUR
SPECIFIC PERSON PURPOSES.
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE SPECIFIC
PURPOSES- A LITTLE BIT MORE
SWIFTLY- THE CRITERIA OF
CONDITIONS THAT NEED TO BE MET.
FOR THIS CONTROL SECTION BE
USED ARE VERY SIMILAR. TO
CONTROL SECTION TWENTY EIGHT SO
IT STILL REQUIRES THAT IT THE
FUNDS THAT ARE- BEING EXPENDED
SPECIFICALLY TO SUPPORT THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO COVERT
NINETEEN. I WOULD REQUIRE THAT
THEY BE CONSISTENT WITH THE
LAW. WE WOULD REQUIRE THAT THE
FUNDS ARE BEING PROVIDED
SPECIFICALLY FOR AND ARE BEING
EXPANDED SPECIFICALLY FOR. THE
NINETEEN- AND THEN FINALLY- IT
HAS TO BE REQUIRES THAT THE
ACCEPTANCE OF THOSE FUNDS WOULD
NOT REQUIRE THE STATE TO COMMIT
OR EXPAND IN ANY OTHER STATE
FUNDS. SO VERY SIMILAR
REQUIREMENTS OR CONDITIONS TO
CONTROL SECTION TWENTY EIGHT-
OUR THOUGHT PROCESS ON THIS
COMPONENT AGAIN WHICH WAS TO
ALLOW FOR. A WAY TO BRING IN
AND USE QUICKLY WHAT WE EXPECT
TO BE CAN BE LARGER THAN THE
TYPICALLY- INTUBATED TYPE OF
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE LIKE THE
CARS AFTER SOMETHING LIKE THAT
IF IT WERE IF ANOTHER PACKAGE
WOULD COME. FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE LA- PLEASE. SORT OF
BORED LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE ON SO THE FIRST
COMPONENT ELEVEN POINT NINE ONE
THAT ALLOWS THE ADMINISTRATION
TO SHIFT FUNDS BETWEEN TWELVE
DEPARTMENTS- WHAT MADE MY
COMMENTS WILL BE FOCUSED ON
THAT FIRST WEEK WE THINK IT'S
REASONABLE TO PROVIDE THE
ADMINISTRATION SOME FLEXIBILITY
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A LOT
ON KNOWN ABOUT THE PANDEMIC.
HOWEVER WE FEEL THAT THIS
SECTION PROVIDES SO MUCH
FLEXIBILITY THAT WOULD BE
DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO KNOW HOW BUDGETED FUNDS WILL
ACTUALLY BE SPENT OR EVEN WHICH
DEPARTMENTS WILL ULTIMATELY
RECEIVE THE FUNDS AS THE
CONTROL SECTION DOES NOT
REQUIRE A NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENT. IN OUR IN ADDITION
THE SECTION ALLOWS FUNDS TO BE
PROVIDED TO THREE DEPARTMENTS
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY. AND
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT WHOSE
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES HAVEN'T
BEEN IDENTIFIED YET AS SUCH THE
LEGISLATURE ONE HAVE A SENSE OF
HOW THE FUNDS WOULD BE USED IF
THEY WERE PROVIDED TO THOSE
DEPARTMENTS- ACCORDINGLY WE
RECOMMEND MODIFYING THE
SECTION. TO REQUIRE THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE NOTIFIED WHEN
FUNDS ARE TRANSFERRED AND BE
PROVIDED INFORMATION ABOUT- HOW
THE FUNDS WILL BE USED WHEN
THEY'RE TRANSFERRED. WITH
RESPECT TO THE SECOND COMPONENT
THAT GIVES THE ADMINISTRATION
FLEXIBILITY TO RECEIVE. FEDERAL
AND PRIVATE FUNDS WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING THIS COMPONENT OF
CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN NINE
ONE- BECAUSE IT REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION OF WHAT'S
REALLY ALREADY A VERY VERY
BROAD AUTHORITY UNDER CONTROL
SECTION TWENTY EIGHT- WE- ARE
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT SOME OF
THE FOUGHT BEHIND- THE CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN NINE ONE
FLEXIBILITY TO RECEIVE FEDERAL
FUNDS. WAS THAT IT WOULD
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS. BUT WE
REALLY FIND THAT THERE'S NO
NEED TO EXPEDITE THE PROCESS-
BECAUSE THAT'S ALREADY
AVAILABLE UNDER CONTROL SECTION
TWENTY EIGHT- THE OTHER THING
THAT'S REALLY CRITICAL TO NOTE
ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN NINE ONE
AND CONTROL SECTION TWENTY
EIGHT IS ELEVEN NINE ONE WOULD
NOT REQUIRE ANY LEGISLATIVE
NOTIFICATION. WORDS CONTROL
SECTION TWENTY EIGHT WOULD IF
IT'S A BUT IF IT'S FUNDING
ABOVE A CERTAIN THRESHOLD. ON
AND SO WE FEEL THAT THE CURRENT
PROCESS IS SUFFICIENT
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE IT HAS
SAFEGUARDS BUILT IN TO ALLOW
FOR EXPEDITED APPLICATIONS AS
NECESSARY AND THOSE THOSE-
EXPEDITED ALLOCATIONS HAVE BEEN
MADE THROUGHOUT THAT CODE
NINETEEN. PANDEMIC AS NEEDED.
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ON
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF SO
ALONG THOSE LINES IF WE COULD
GET THE DEPARTMENT OF- FINANCE
BUT WHAT IS THE PROBLEM WITH
USING THE EXISTING BUDGET
CONTROL SECTIONSTO. ALLOCATE
OR REALLOCATE ON GENERAL FUND
MONEY. SO WE FOUND IN VARIOUS
THINGS DURING THE PANDEMIC
THAT- SOME OF THE RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES REQUIRED FOR
IMMEDIATE ACTION AND SO THAT'S
THAT'S WHERE W WERE COMING
FROM WHERE POSING A LOAN POINT
NINE WONDER THAT THAT COMPONENT.
END OF IT IS THAT IT ALLOWS FOR
A MORE IMMEDIATE. USE OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDING AS THEY COME IN
THAT WAS THAT'S LARGELY THE AND
THEN AS I MENTIONED EARLIER- I
THINK TYPICALLY CONSTRUCTION
TWENTY EIGHT OF THE BUDGET ACT.
TYPICALLY DOESN'T CONTEMPLATE-
I THINK ASK FEDERAL PACKAGES OF
THE OF THE MAGNITUDE OF THAT WE
WOULD YOU KNOW THAT YOU MAY GET
FROM CODE NINETEEN NINETY CAN
THINK WITH CARES ACT NUMBER
DEPARTMENTS IMPACTED IN THAT
AND THE SIZE OF THE AMOUNT THAT
COMES IN- AND THEN AGAIN BAKER
SAID BEING ABLE TO UTILIZE IT
ON A- MEDIA BASIS FOR IMMEDIATE
NEEDS. AND COVERED THAT WAS THE
CONTEXT WERE COMING FROM- AND
AGAIN YOU KNOW WE'RE WE WERE
DRAFTING THIS CONTROL SECTION
IN MID DECEMBER- WHEN WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT TO FACE- AND THE
MOST RECENT SURGE WE HAD AND
THE OTHERS. AND CONTINUED
UNCERTAINTIES ONE WAY SO WE'RE
COMING FROM A CONTEXT AND IS
WELL. OF THE MEDIA. MEDIA
ATTENTION NEEDED THEIR- I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW THE CA SEX WELL IT
DOESN'T SPECIFY- NOTIFICATION.
EXPECTATIONS THE MINISTRATION-
OUR THOUGHT PROCESS WAS THAT WE
WOULD PROVIDE INFORMATION IN
TERMS OF HOW FUNDING WAS
SHIFTED IN PROVIDED AND USE OF.
THE FEDERAL FUNDING AUTHORITY.
PORTION OF THAT YOU ARE A
REGULAR FISCAL UPDATES AND
BRIEFINGS PROCESSES THAT WE'VE
DONE WE ANTICIPATE TO CONTINUE
DOING THOSE THINGS AND SO
THAT'S THE PROCESS THAT WE
WOULD ANTICIPATE TO CONTINUE
USING TO SHARE THE INFORMATION.
SO IN TERMS OF WHY ARE YOU
ASKING FOR THIS BROADER THE
AUTHORITY. WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
NOTIFICATION YOU THINK THAT
THEIR REPORTS EVERY COUPLE OF
MONTHS WOULD COVER THAT. I
MENTIONED EARLIER TYPICALLY
WHEN WE'RE DOING ANY SORT OF
NEW ACTIVITY WE HAVE BRIEFINGS
AND HOLD DISCUSSIONS WITH
MEMBERS AND STAFF PRIOR TO
LAUNCHING THOSE ACTIVITIES-
RIGHT WE WOULD CONTINUE TO
THINK THAT ACTIVITY ON THAT
LEVEL OF CONGESTION
NOTIFICATION INVOLVEMENT. MADAM
CHAIR IF I IF I GET A YES MR
SODERBERGH. ON WE THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAKE AN
EXPLICIT NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENT- DIDN'T TO MAKE
NOTIFICATION EXPLICITLY
REQUIRED BECAUSE THAT ENSURES
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL GET
THE INFORMATION. IT FINDS TO BE
NECESSARY IT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
OFTEN EXCEEDED- THE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS ON THE LEVEL OF
INFORMATION PROVIDED BUT WE
THINK THAT- THERE'S NO HARM IN
REQUIRING THE INFORMATION BE
PROVIDED AND WE THINK IT'S
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT. THAT
THIS INFORMATION BE PROVIDED
RELATED TO LARGE FEDERAL FUNDS
AND THAT'S WHY WE THINK THE
CONTROL SECTION TWENTY EIGHT
PROCESS WHICH INCLUDES THAT
NOTIFICATION- WOULD BE
PREFERABLE TO THE- ELEVEN NINE
ONE PROCESS PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- COLLEAGUES. NINETY
YES SENATE QUARTERS. THANK YOU
BUILT YOUR RADIO MIGHT. MY LEAN
ON THIS EARLY SO THE FIRST IS
THAT EITHER ELEVEN NINETY ONE
SHOULD REPLICATE THE
NOTIFICATION PROCESS AND TWENTY
EIGHT AS AS A MINIMUM OR- OR
THE- IT SHOULD JUST BE
DETERMINED AT TWENTY EIGHT. IS
THE RULE- THAT SAID GO. A. I.
BASED ON SOME THINKING- AND I
AND I APPRECIATE MR BENTSEN
YOUR YOUR CANDOR REGARDING. YOU
KNOW PUTTING THIS TOGETHER IN
DECEMBER- YOU KNOW ALL THROUGH
THIS PANDEMIC YOU KNOW I THINK
WE'VE HEARD POLICYMAKERS SAY
YOU KNOW THE LAST MONTH OR TWO
MONTHS AGO WAS- LIKE A
DIFFERENT WORLD BUT WE WERE IN
A DIFFERENT WORLD- IN IN. A
THINK OF. WHERE WE WERE IN
DECEMBER. IN WHERE WE ARE NOW
IT IS REMARKABLY DIFFERENT IN A
GOOD WAY- IN MANY WAYS- SO I
CAN ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR CANDOR
MISTER BENSON AND YOU KNOW
REPEATEDLY USING. THE WORD SOME
YOU KNOW SOME ROLL UP USED TO
BE DONE IMMEDIATELY- I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD WAY WHICH THE
QUESTION BECOMES HOW ABOUT THE
SOME. THINGS THAT DON'T NEED TO
BE ROLLED OUT IMMEDIATELY BUT
ARE PART OF- ALONG A LONGER
GAME. SO TO SPEAK NO THIS IS A
GAME BUT A LONGER. APPROACH A
LONGER RANGE APPROACH THAT
WOULD BE STEEPED IN POLICY THE
LEGISLATURE FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE
TAKEN UP BILLS SUCH AS SB
NINETY ONE AND JUST- THIS
MORNING S. B. EIGHTY SIX WHICH-
WHICH COMPLEMENT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH- IN
TERMS OF REOPENING- RELOCATING-
TENANTS BACK ON THEIR FEET
LANDLORDS BACK ON THEIR FEET IN
THE FIRST CASE OR- WITH EIGHTY
SIX- OBVIOUSLY. OUR SCHOOLS
REOPENED- THERE'S AN URGENCY-
BUT I WOULDN'T CALL IT
INTERMEDIACY OF THAT TO THAT
APPROACH. CONVERSELY IF YOU
WERE TO MAKE THE ARGUMENT TO ME.
WITH YOU KNOW UNDER EITHER
ELEVEN NINETY ONE OR TWENTY
EIGHT TAXI ROLLOUT. SHOULD
SHOULD REQUIRE YOU KNOW
ABSOLUTELY MINIMAL LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT BECAUSE WE NEED TO
MOVE ON THAT. YESTERDAY SO TO
SPEAK- WE IT'S OF EXTREME.
URGENCY AND- THE IMMEDIACY OF
MAKING DECISIONS ON HOW TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS AND HOW TO
IMPLEMENT- AND PAY FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THAT TO ME.
HAS A MUCH GREATER URGENCY BUT
ALL OF ALL THAT SPEAKS TO THE
TIME THAT WERE IN WORK. WE SEEM
TO BE LEAVING. THANK GOD- A- A
WORLD WHERE EVERYTHING- UNDER
UNDER THE EMERGENCY DECLARATION
NEEDED TO HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY
BECAUSE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
WERE INTO BASICALLY A NEW
REALITY NOW WHERE. WE'RE WE'RE
ENTERING RECONSTRUCTION RE
OPENING IN- YOU KNOW IT'S
ALMOST BY AN ELEGY IS NOT A
GOOD ANALOGY BUT- YOU KNOW IF
WE WERE FIFTH AT THE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL TO ARGUING ABOUT
THE WAR POWERS ACT WHETHER OR
NOT. THE ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
HAVE THE RIGHT TO ACT NOW- IN
THE CASE OF. YOU KNOW A GLOBAL
EMERGENCY WHICH THIS IS- IN AND
AT WHAT POINT DO YOU ENTER A
RECONSTRUCTION PHASE SORT OF A
MARTIAL HACK PHASE WHERE.
FRANKLY POLICY- IS OF HUGE
IMPORTANCE NEW ONCE BECOMES
IMPORTANT DOESN'T MEAN THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE. HOLDING
BACK FOR MONTHS AT A TIME BUT-
EIGHT AT LIKE TO HEAR WHETHER
OR NOT THE L. A. O. PROTECTOR
FEELS THAT. GIVEN WHERE WE ARE
TODAY AND IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- IN WHETHER CO
AILES- OPINION THAT. WOULD BE
EXPENDITURES FORTHCOMING TO BE
ESSENTIALLY SPLIT INTO THREE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES THOSE
THAT. HOME ARE IMMEDIATE IN
THOSE- WHERE THERE WILL BE TIME
FOR- A LITTLE BIT MORE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS TO BE
APPLIED. IN THE- WITH THAT-
OCCURRED LIKE TO ALSO
UNDERSTAND PROCEDURALLY WHETHER
YOU KNOW I'M NOT SURE HOW THIS
HAPPENED THAT THE NOTIFICATIONS
UNDER. THESE CONTROL SECTIONS
BASICALLY LEFT TO. THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE. BUDGET COMMITTEE I
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH HIM
GETTING NOTIFICATIONS BUT WHAT
I DO UNDERSTAND. IS WHAT SEEMS
LIKE A DISCONNECT WITH WITH THE
RULES COMMITTEE PROCESS IN OUR
SYSTEM IT SEEMS LIKE. IF YOU'RE
IF THINGS ARE HAPPENING
QUICKLY. AND NOTIFICATIONS NEED
TO HAPPEN THAT IN OUR SYSTEM
THEY WOULD WE WOULD WANT THEM
TO GO TO RULES THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND WHAT THE RULES
COMMITTEE DISPATCH OUT MAKE THE
DECISIONS AS TO WHO NEEDS TO BE
BRIEF WHICH COMMITTEES OR
SUBCOMMITTEES NEED TO BE
CONVENE I MEAN IT'S REALLY THE
RULES COMMITTEE IN OUR SYSTEM.
THAT SETS THE AGENDA FOR THAT
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT PROCESS
OR POLICY PROCESS SO. I GUESS.
I'M I'M STARTING TO LOOK SORT
OF LEAN INTO. OF A POSITION
THAT. WE NEED NOTIFICATION ADAM
AT A MINIMUM- NOT A LACK OF IF
IT PERHAPS IN ADDITION TO.
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE IT SHOULD ALSO BE
SORT OF- RACKET THAT RULES
COMMITTEE AS WELL IN CASE. THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES LIKE THIS
ONE RATHER- OR OTHERS NEED TO
BE CONVENE BUT IF I CAN JUST
NOW TO THE CHURCH GET BACK TO
THE L. A. AND- JUST ASK FOR
YOUR PERCEPTION OF WHERE WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS IN TERMS OF THIS
NEED FOR IMMEDIACY OR NOT. SORT
OF BORED LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE. YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THEY'RE THERE ARE GOING TO BE
SOME EXPENDITURES. THAT NEED TO
BE DONE ON AN IMMEDIATE BASIS-
AND WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT FACT
AND IN THE NEXT SECTION I WILL
OUTLINE A SERIES OF REFORMS
THAT WE THINK SHOULD BE PUT IN
PLACE- THAT WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE'S SOME SPENDING THAT
NEEDS TO OCCUR ON AN IMMEDIATE
BASIS. WE THINK EVEN IN THOSE
CASES LEGISLATIVE NOTIFICATION
IS APPROPRIATE. HOWEVER THERE'S
ALSO SPENDING- THAT- NEEDS TO
BE SUBJECT TO GREATER
LEGISLATIVE REFLECTION
PARTICULARLY IN CASES WHERE
THERE'S SORT OF. LARGE AMOUNTS
BEING MADE AVAILABLE FOR
EMERGENCIES THAT AREN'T NEEDED
ON A PRICING BASIS AND IN THOSE
CASES WE THINK THAT. THE LONGER
NOTIFICATION TIME. ALLOWING
THE- THE LEGISLATURE GREATER
TIME TO REFLECT ON IT AND
PROVIDED INPUT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE APPROPRIATE-
IN TERMS OF YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
THE- JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE- THE LEGISLATURE E.
AS A LEGISLATURE YOU'D BE
ABSOLUTELY. FREE TO SET UP
WHATEVER SORT OF NOTIFICATION
PROCESS SEEMS APPROPRIATE TO
YOU. TRADITIONALLY MADE YOUR
BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS ARE.
REVIEWED BY THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE IN
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES AND THAT'S-
WHY SOME OF THE ONES CREATED
FOR KOBE AND PROBABLY ARE.
USING. THAT SORT OF SET
STRUCTURE. FROM HERE BUT YOU
CAN HAVE. INTERNET I DIFFERENT
STRUCTURE OFTENTIMES THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE-
IS PUT IN THE PLACE OF- DOING
IN THE REVIEWS THE
NOTIFICATIONS- SO THAT THERE'D
BE A COMMITTEE AVAILABLE. TO
TAKE A LOOK AT IT EVEN IN CASES
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE IS OUT OF
SESSION BECAUSE OFTENTIMES
EMERGENCY SPENDING WILL NEED TO
TAKE PLACE AND THAT AND SO THE
IDEA IS HAVING A- SMALLER
COMMITTEE- TAKE TAKE A LOOK AT
THOSE AND BE ABLE TO. REVIEW
THOSE NOTIFICATIONS WITHOUT THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDING TO BE IN
SESSION BUT CERTAINLY THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE FREE TO
CREATE WHAT'S OR WHATEVER SORT
OF REVIEW AND NOTIFICATION
PROCESS- EIGHTEENS TO BE
APPROPRIATE JUST BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST
DOESN'T. TIE THE HANDS OF THE
LEGISLATURE GOING FORWARD.
THROUGH THE TOURNAMENT A THE
ONE BELABOR THE POINT BUT I AM
HOPING YOU UNDERSTAND THE
DISTINCTION I'M MAKING I I'M
ALL FOR THE NIMBLENESS OF. THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- BUT PART OF THEIR
PER IS MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT
WHETHER. OTHERS NEED TO BE
INVOLVED IN OVERSIGHT ONLY ONLY
THE RULES COMMITTEE IN OUR
SYSTEM. OF CAN. SORT OF PLAY
QUARTERBACK TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS- IN IN THE SYSTEM AND
I'M- IT WOULD IS THAT TRUE WORD
OR DO YOU. IS YOUR UNDERSTAND
OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE. ONE THAT THAT THAT
PART OF THE RESPONSIBILITY IS
TO IS TO NOT JUST PROCESSES
NOTIFICATIONS TO MAKE DECISIONS
AND SEND MESSAGES BACK WITH YOU
MINISTRY SHOULD ALSO MAKE A
DETERMINATION WHETHER OR NOT-
OTHERS IN THE LEGISLATURE NEED
TO BE CONVENE. EQUITIES IF I
COULD- I MIGHT BE ON OFFER A
CLARIFICATION AS WELL. SO I
JUST I WANTED TO NOTE AND IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR COMMENTS THAT
WHEN THESE NOTIFICATIONS ARE
SENT TO THE JOINT WILL JUST
LITTLE BUDGET COMMITTEE THEY'RE
ALSO SENT TO BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEES
AND COMMITTEES ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SO I JUST TO
CLARIFY IT'S NOT JUST JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET ME TO GET
SOMETHING THEY GO TO MULTIPLE
COMMITTEES WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDING THE
BUDGET COMMITTEES. AND THE
OTHER THING IS- ONE AND WANTED
TO NOTE- SORRY I JUST IN MY
BIKE SO I KNOW ALL THE WITH
THAT BUT YEAH IF YOU JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE YOU KNEW THAT THE
OTHER COMMITTEES WERE ALSO
GETTING- GETTING THESE
NOTIFICATIONS AS WELL THAT'S
HELPFUL NOT ONLY STARTED. THE
CITY I THINK I WOULD I WAS
GONNA NOTICE I'M SORRY YOUR
EXAMPLES IN EARLY ON WERE
ACTUALLY GOOD I THINK
ILLUSTRATE EXAMPLES OF. HOW THE
MINISTRATIONS APPROACH- IN
TERMS OF IMMEDIACY- HAS BEEN
HAS BEEN GOING SO. AGAIN NOTING
THAT. THE PACKAGE ON RE OPENING
SCHOOLS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
THOSE ARE. WHAT FOR IT IS KIND
OF EARLY ACTION NEEDED ACTION
BUDGET REQUEST. I THINK IT'S IN
REFLECTION YOU KNOW- KNOWLEDGE
MEANT THAT THOSE WERE THINGS
THAT YEAH THERE PORTANTINO NEED
TO GET DONE QUICKLY BUT- YOUR
WEBSITE IS IN SESSION WERE IN A
BUDGET. OUT PROCESS. AND WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ENGAGE IN
THAT AND THAT'S THE ROUTE THAT
WAS USED. WE TRY AND USE THE
OTHER ROUTES IT'S PRIMARILY THE
TRUE A ROUTE- FOR THINGS THAT
ARE DISTINCTLY IMMEDIATE NEED.
EMERGENCY RESPONSE THINGS AND
THEN I THINK IS AS MR
SODERBERGH ALLUDED TO LIKE
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE IS NOT IN SESSION.
AND THINGS NEED TO BE REACTIVE
TO AND RESPONDED. TO AND SO WE
TRYING YOU SLICE AND THAT WAY
AGAIN THE FRAMEWORK FOR A B. C.
P. THIS YEAR WAS. TO TRY AND
REFLECT THAT BALANCE OF WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS IN SESSION AND
NOT EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE
DOING. ANY TO DO IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. IS LIKE IMMEDIATE. ACTION
STUFF WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
USE THE REGULAR BUDGET. PROCESS
AND WE'RE TRYING TO UTILIZE THE
REGULAR BUDGET PROCESS TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE- AND THEN
BALANCING THAT WITH THE CASES
WHERE WE CAN OPERATE. RECOGNIZE
ARE ANTICIPATE. THERE WILL BE
THINGS OUTSIDE THE BUDGET
PROCESS THAT WILL STILL
REQUIRES IMMEDIATE ACTION IN
THE IN YOUR EXACT APPLE OF.
FAXING DISTRIBUTION IS X. IS
RIGHT. ON LIKE THAT'S EXACTLY
THE TYPE OF THING WHERE. YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO BE A TO MOVE
IMMEDIATELY- TO HELP. HEALTH IF
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE AND
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU.
JUST JUST ALONG THOSE LINES-
THE WE'VE NEVER USE THESE
EMERGENCY OF THIS EMERGENCY
AUTHORITY- IN A SOME IN A
SITUATION THAT'S OUTSIDE OF A
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED WE HAD
TO RESPOND TO IT WHERE THERE
WAS A FIRE IS THAT NOBODY
EXPECTED AMIT HAPPENED THAT'S
BEEN LET'S GO IN AND FIX AND
HELP- A NURSE QUICK YOU KNOW
YOU GO IN IT'S A BIG THING THAT
HAPPENED WE HAVE TO. RESPOND WE
HAVE TO HELP. THIS IS NOW A
YEAR AFTER- HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE STARTED TO RESPOND TO. TO
THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE A BETTER
SENSE AND EVERY TIME WE SPEND
DOLLARS IT'S A REFLECTION OF A
POLICY IT'S NO LONGER JUST.
LET'S GO IN AND SPEND THE MONEY
THAT'S NEEDED TO HELP PEOPLE
THIS IS NOT REFLECTIVE OF A
POLICY SO THOSE ARE MY-
CONCERNS AS FAR AS- OF THE KIND
OF NOTICE THAT SHOULD BE GIVEN
TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE- RESPONSIBLE FOR. AND
WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR IT BY
REFLECTING ON WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THIS ART ARE PART OF THE
STATE AND PUTTING IT ALL
TOGETHER SO THAT WE COULD SPEND
THE DOLLARS IN A WAY THAT
ADDRESSES- ARE DISTRICTS BUT
ALSO THE WHOLE STATE SO- IT'S A
YEAR LATER. WE'VE LEARNED A
LOT- STILL DON'T KNOW WHERE
WHAT THIS IS GONNA THIS IS
GOING TO MEET IN OUR AND OUR
COMMUNITIES BUT- WE HAVE A
SENSE OF IT AND NOW WE NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD AND I THINK. WE'RE
IN A DIFFERENT PLACE FROM WHERE
WE WERE A YEAR AGO WE GAVE THAT
KIND OF- ACCORDING. THE THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH- WE'RE GOING
TO ISSUE. TEN RIGHT OKAY MOVING
ON TO ISSUE TEN BUDGET CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN NINETY TWO.
LOGIN STEVEN BENSON WITH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE- CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN POINT NINE TWO.
REVISE FOR THE CONTINUED USE OF
THE DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT AFTER JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FOR ANTICIPATED COSTS RELATED
TO COVER NINETEENTH AS I NOTED
PREVIOUSLY THE BUDGET PACKAGE
THE ADMINISTRATION PUT FORWARD.
INCLUDES ABOUT FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF ESTIMATED COSTS THAT
WE DON'T YET HAVE SUFFICIENT
INFORMATION TO KNOW EXACTLY
WHICH DEPARTMENTS WOULD NEED TO
MAKE THE EXPENDITURES AND SO WE
HAVE PROPOSED TO MAKE THE
THREE- I THOUGHT MECHANISM. AND
CONTINUE TO BE AVAILABLE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO THAT WE
COULD ADMINISTER AND THAT
FUNDING AND CAN OR ANY OTHER
KIND OF SORT OF UNKNOWN
UNANTICIPATED THINGS THAT WOULD
COME UP SIMILAR TO WHAT HAS
BEEN DONE. SO FAR. M. OKAY.
WITH THAT THANK YOU MISTER
BENSON- THE L. A- PLEASE. SORT
OF BORED LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- SO GIVEN THE SCALE AND
THE NATURE OF THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE DO THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO PROVIDE THE
GOVERNOR FLEXIBILITY TO- SPEND
ON THE BILL. PANDEMIC BUT I
THINK AS OUR DISCUSSION HAS
HIGHLIGHTED WE THINK THAT THERE
ADDITIONAL CHECKS AND BALANCES
THAT NEED TO BE PLACED ON THIS
FLEXIBILITY ON EVERYTHING THESE
CHECKS AND BALANCES ARE
APPROPRIATE NOT ONLY FOR COVERT
NINETEEN BUT REALLY FALL FUTURE
STATE EMERGENCIES BECAUSE MANY
OF THE- SIGNIFICANT EMERGENCY
SPENDING AUTHORITIES SUCH AS
THOSE UNDER SEASIDE- IT WOULD
APPLY TO ALL STATE EMERGENCIES
AND REALLY PROVIDE VERY LITTLE
ROLE FOR LEGISLATIVE. OVERSIGHT
SO TO ADDRESS THAT BOTH THE
THAT PROBLEM BOTH AS IT APPLIES
TO COPE WITH NINETEEN AND OTHER
STATE EMERGENCIES. WE RECOMMEND
A SERIES OF STATUTORY CHANGES-
TO PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH
GREATER OVERSIGHT EMERGENCY
SPENDING- FIRST WE'D RECOMMEND
REQUIRING ALL EMERGENCY
AUGMENTATIONS COME FROM THREE-
THIS WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL
AUGMENTATIONS ARE SUBJECT TO
SIMILAR REQUIREMENTS- WE KNOW
THAT WE WOULD STILL. UNDER OUR
RECOMMENDATION ALLOW THE
ADMINISTRATION TO USE ITS
POWERS UNDER C. SAID TO
REDIRECT FUNDS BUT IN ORDER TO
MAKE THOSE AVAILABLE
DEPARTMENTS THE ADMINISTRATION
WE NEED TO DO A HOT DEPOSITED
THREE OFFERS. AS MR BENTSEN
DESCRIBED EARLIER THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THEY'RE
ALREADY DOING- THIS WOULD SORT
OF ENSURE THAT THE- ALLOCATIONS
PROVIDED TO DEPARTMENTS LIKE I
SAID ARE. SUBJECT TO ALL THE
SAME REQUIREMENTS. THIS CHANGE
WITH RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR ESTABLISH AN AMOUNT
FOR DARIO AND THE BUDGET. THIS
WOULD GIVE THE LEGISLATURE
INPUT INTO THE LEVEL OF FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR EMERGENCY
EXPENDITURES. IT WOULD ALSO
MINIMIZE THE CHANCE THAT
EMERGENCY SPINE- SPENDING ENDS
UP UNDERMINING. THE STATE
BUDGET STRUCTURE OR CONDITION
FROM OR TO THE EXTENT THAT IT'S
NECESSARY THAT'S THAT SPENDING-
DRAMATICALLY CHANGE THE BUDGT
THE LEGISLATURE IS- INVOLVED AT
THE FRONT ABOUT THE AMOUNT
AVAILABLE FOR EMERGENCY
SPENDING. THE THIRD CHANGE WE'D
RECOMMEND IS REQUIRING ADVANCE
NOTIFICATION TO TRANSFER FUNDS
INTO TRIO- SEVEN SOME YEARS OF
THE ADMINISTRATION MAY NEED TO
EXCEED THE AMOUNT BUDGETED
INJURY- AND TO ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AS PART OF THIS
DECISION WE- DEMAND THAT START
TO BE CHANGED TO. REQUIRE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE
ADVANCE NOTIFICATION TO JAIL
BC. THEN THE NOTIFICATIONS
WOULD. BE A DIFFERENT TYPES
DEPENDING ON THE SITUATION- FOR
EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
ESTABLISH A SHORTER
NOTIFICATION PERIOD FOR SMALLER
TRANSFERS THAT ARE TIED TO
ONGOING EMERGENCIES. FOR
EXAMPLE THIS COULD BE A SEVENTY
TWO HOUR NOTIFICATION- THIS
WOULD BE REASONABLE SINCE THE
AMOUNTS WOULD BE SMALL THE
EMERGENCY WOULD BE ONGOING AND
THEREFORE VERY LIKELY TO BE
URGENT. AND WOULD BE
ACCOMPANIED BY SPECIFIC DETAILS.
ON HOW THE DOLLARS WOULD BE
SPENT. FROM WE WOULD RECKON IS
DOUBLE A- NO. PERIOD FOR LARGER
TRANSFERS OR TRANSFERS THAT ARE
MADE PROACTIVELY BEFORE
EMERGENCIES- THIS GETS BACK TO-
THE QUESTION THAT SENATOR
CORTESE ASKED AS TO WHETHER
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
FUNDING THAT'S URGENT AND SOME
FUNDING THAT. LAST SURGEON THIS
WOULD FALL INTO THE LESS URGENT
CATEGORY- AND BECAUSE OF THAT
WE RECOMMEND THAT THERE BE A
THIRTY OR FORTY FIVE DAY
NOTIFICATION PROCESS TO ALLOW
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONDUCT MORE
OVERSIGHT FOR EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD BE CONVENE. A
BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING TO
WEIGH WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE THING TO DO-
HOWEVER IN ALL CASES WE DO.
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ALLOW THE ADMINISTRATION TO
REQUEST A WAIVER OF THE
NOTIFICATION TIME FRAME- IF
URGENT CIRCUMSTANCES ARISE-
SUCH AS IF THERE IS A NEED TO
SPEND. FUNDS IN ORDER TO
PREVENT THE LOSS OF LIFE OR
DAMAGE TO PROPERTY- UNDER THESE
CASES OF JAIL B. C. APPROVED
THE WAIVER THE FUNDS WOULD BE
EITHER TRANSFERRED IMMEDIATELY.
OR UNDER WHATEVER SHORTEN TIME
FRAME WAS SPECIFIED BY JAIL BC.
ANOTHER CHANGE WE RECOMMEND IS
THAT- THERE BE INCREASED
REPORTING ON DRIEL ALLOCATIONS
AND EXPENDITURES- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW AS WE HAVE
SAID A COUPLE TIMES IN TODAY'S
HEARINGS THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
ABSOLUTELY EXCEEDED. THE LEVEL
OF INFORMATION THAT'S REQUIRED
BY STATUTE THROUGHOUT COULD
NINETEEN NONETHELESS WE STILL
THINK THAT THE OVERALL AMOUNT
OF INFORMATION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS PROVIDED IS
INADEQUATE FOR A CHAT- TO.
UNDERTAKE ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT OF
THE NINETEEN EXPENDITURES. SO
WHAT WE RECOMMEND IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE BE NOTIFIED WHEN
ALLOCATIONS ARE MADE FROM THREE
OO TO DEPARTMENTS- THIS WOULD
BE DONE AT THE TIME THE
ALLOCATION IS MADE AND THEN
THIS WOULD BE- THE NOTIFICATION
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO HAVE
SPECIFIC INFORMATION LIKE THE
AMOUNT BEING TRANSFERRED TO THE
DEPARTMENT. AND THE SPECIFIC
USES IT WOULD BE USED FOR. WE
ALSO RECOMMEND EXPLICITLY
REQUIRING IN STATUTE THAT
MONTHLY REPORTS BE GENERATED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ALL PLANNED AN ACTUAL SPENDING.
THIS WOULD APPLY TO ALL
EMERGENCIES. AND WHAT OUTLINED
THE EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS
ALLOCATED FROM REAL WORLD
FEDERAL FUNDS PRIVATE FUNDS AS
WELL AS EXPENDITURES OF FUNDS
BUDGETED FOR EMERGENCY RESPONSE
FOR FUNDS THAT ARE REDIRECTED
UNDER C. SO AT THE READY- IN IT
IN ADDITION TO JUST DESCRIBING.
THE AMOUNTS OF FUNDS WE ALSO
RECOMMEND THAT THIS REPORT
INCLUDE A DESCRIPTION OF THE
SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES FUNDED. SO
IF ALL OF THE SAFEGUARDS THAT I
MENTIONED WERE PUT IN PLACE- WE
THINK THAT IT COULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO EXPAND THE USE OF THREE-
UPPER CODE NINETEEN THROUGH THE
END OF THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR-
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE WELL
POSITIONED TO. EXECUTE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OF THAT
CODE NINETEEN RESPONSE. HOWEVER
WE DO APPRECIATE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT GREATER
INVOLVEMENT GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE
OF THE CODE NINETEEN SPENDING.
IN THIS CASE THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER INSTEAD
REJECTING CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN POINT NINE TWO AND
CREATING A DIFFERENT BUDGET
CONTROL SECTION PROCESS. TO
ALLOCATE CODE NINETEEN FUNDS
WOULD BE VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
WAS DONE THROUGH CONTROL
SECTION THIRTY SIX. IN THIS
CASE THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
SPECIFY THE TOTAL AMOUNT
AVAILABLE. AND OUTLINED THE
PROCESS TO NOTIFY THE
LEGISLATURE SUCH AS THROUGH
NOTIFICATIONS PROVIDED TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- AND IN THIS CASE.
THE THE TOTAL AMOUNT AVAILABLE
FOR CODE SPENDING COULD ONLY BE
CHANGED IF THERE WAS AN
AMENDMENT TO THE BUDGET ACT AND
SO THAT WOULD PUT CONSIDERABLY.
MORE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER
THE TWELVE MONTHS SPENT ON
CORPORATE NINETEEN. WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. WE APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT WENT ON THE FACT
THAT WENT BEHIND THAT- DOES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WANT TO
RESPOND OR HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
ABOUT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
MISTER BENSON. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR APPRECIATE THAT NOW YOU
JUST VERY BRIEFLY. YEAH SO LIKE
AS MENTIONED EARLIER WE'RE
STILL REVIEWING THE REPORT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS- THAT YOU JUST
RECENTLY CAME OUT AND- WE JUST
NOTE PRELIMINARILY THAT TO THE
EXTENT ANY OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS LIMITS THE
STATE'S ABILITY. TO RESPOND
IMMEDIATELY TO DISASTER EVENTS
WHEN CIRCUMSTANCES REQUIRE
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE NOW THAT'S
WHERE OUR CONCERN WOULD LIKELY
LIE- BUT WE DO REALLY
APPRECIATE- YOU KNOW THAT THE
LAW TELESALES REPEAT KNOWLEDGE
MEANT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
APPEARED TO YOU KNOW NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS AND INFORMATION
SHARING AND LAW AND EXCEEDED
THAT MANY CASES AND- AND- YOU
KNOW WE'RE- WE'RE VERY OPEN TO.
HAVING THE DISCUSSION IN
CONTINUING THEIR DISCUSSION
BASED ON REPORT. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE NEW UNDER ANY
JUSTICE IS A COMMON ENEMY INTO
THE KNOWLEDGE OF. THE COVERED
NATURE OF THE OF THE PRESENTERS
THEMSELVES- YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THIS A LITTLE BIT IN
THE ABSTRACT IN MY OPINION- IT%
TO THE EXTENT THAT THESE BUDGET
CONTROL SECTIONS ARE ARE THERE
LONG TERM TO ENSURE A TO YOUR
EARLIER COMMENTS ABOUT. WHAT WE
DEALING WITH MAX AND AT WHAT
TIME AND WHAT FUTURE
ADMINISTRATION EARTHQUAKE-
FIRES AGAIN FLOOD- IT'S NOT
PERSONAL TO WHETHER OR NOT-
RIGHT NOW- THE ADMINISTRATION
IF YOU KNOW IN OVER THE PAST
YEAR HAS BEEN DOING A STELLAR
JOB OF KEEPING THE LEGISLATURE
INFORMED OR- APPLY GOD
JUDGMENT TO IT WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THIS IS A BLACK LETTER SET
OF RULES THAT WE PASS ON TO
OTHERS OURSELVES. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THAT THAT WOULD
SURVIVE EVEN OUR OVERSIGHT IN
OUR JURISDICTION ALSO THAT
SOMEDAY SOMEBODY'S NOT A
SITUATION- YOU KNOW WHERE. AN
EXECUTIVE ISN'T- SO GENEROUS
WITH YOU KNOW WITH HER THEIR
COLLABORATIVE NATURE SO I JUST
WANTED TO. SAY THAT IN THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT IN EXPLAINED
PERHAPS- WHY- FROM EXPRESSING
CONCERNS THAT THEY GIVE THANK
YOU. OKAY WE'VE COME TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY OKAY SO WE WILL- TAKE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY I'LL READ THE
INSTRUCTIONS FOR THAT AFTER
WHICH WE WILL TAKE A THIRTY
MINUTE BREAK AND WE WILL THEN
ARE. TAKE UP PART B. SO OF WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN SIX ZERO NINE. DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE CHAIR MAY IS A
TWO TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY
TODAY I'M GOING TO ASK THAT
EACH MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
PROVIDING COMMENT KEEP THEIR
REMARKS TO WITHIN ONE MINUTE.
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SCENE NONE. OF ROOM ONE
TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE. SEEN
NONE OF. C. OF IS OF THE
OVERFLOW OKAY THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES-
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
IS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
TWO ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO.
TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT NOW.
ONE MOMENT FOR FIRST COMMENT
MEDICARE MODERATE IT BEFORE
YOU- I NUMBER THAT I'M SORRY
BEFORE YOU DO THAT COULD YOU
GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY. WE
DID HAVE ONE PERSON MADAM CHAIR
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR OF YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND SENATORS
BUSINESS ANTHONY DIMARTINO
CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND CRIME SURVIVORS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. FOR CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNMENT PROPOSAL TO LOG BACK
WHILE DECLINING. CAL BE COULD
BE RESTITUTION FONG AND WE
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE THE
GOVERNOR TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
FOR WAYS TO BACK FILL THAT THE
DECLINE IN REVENUES FOR THE
RESTITUTION FUND. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND THE
DIALOGUE DAY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FOR MODERATOR TOM ADAMS
HERE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
AND COULD YOU PLEASE CALL IN
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WANTS
MORE. YES MADAM CHAIR ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE ZERO FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS
NOW. IN AT THE TIME AND HERE WE
HAVE NO ONE TO ONE UP THANK YOU
MODERATOR. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
VOTE ON THE BOAT ONLY ITEMS- WE
HAVE ISSUES ONE THROUGH FOUR DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THESE
ISSUES TO APPROVED THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. FOR THE
COURTESY OF. THIS IS THE ISSUE
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
CORTEZ HE WILL SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATOR RAZA YES
SENATOR SENATOR OTHER AYE
SENATOR CORTESE SENATOR CORTESE
AYE SENATOR GROW SENATOR NEWMAN
SENATOR NEWMAN AYE. WE HAVE THE-
THREE ZERO OKAY- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE INCORPORATED
CORPORATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
PART EIGHT OF THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING OF WE WILL
RECESS FOR THIRTY MINUTES AND
WE CAN BEING TO HEAR PART B. OF
THE AGENDA SO FROM THAT SAY
TWELVE THIRTY. AT TWELVE THIRTY
WE WILL RESUME WITH PART B.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
MOVE
ON TO PART B. WHICH WILL COVER
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES IMPACTING
YOUTH AND ADULTS. COLLEAGUES WE
WERE INFORMED OF A SCHEDULING
CONFLICT WITH ONE OF OUR
PRESENTERS THEREFORE WE WILL
FIRSTSTART WITH PART B. ISSUE
TEN TO AVOID THIS COMPLEX AND
THEN PROCEED WITH DISCUSSION
FOR ISSUES ONE THROUGH NINE IN
THAT ORDER. LET US BEGIN WITH
ISSUE TEN THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMISSION'S PROPOSAL
FOR THE COMMITTEE ON REVISION
OF THE PENAL CODE WE HAVE THE
COMMITTEE'S CHAIR MICHAEL
ROMANO. RICK OWEN AND THE C. L.
R. C. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR BRIAN
HEBERT WITH US THANKS FOR
JOINING AND WILL YOU PLEASE
PRESENT THIS PROPOSAL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS MY NAME IS MIKE ROMANO
AND I'M THE CHAIR OF THE PENAL
CODE REVISION COMMITTEE OR THE
COMMITTEE ON THE REVISION OF
THE PENAL CODE. B. WHICH WILL
COVER PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES
EMPANEL THIS HAPPENED BEFORE.
ALI WE WERE INFORMED OF A
SCHEDULING CONFLICT WITH ONE OF
OUR PRESENTERS USE ME MISTER
ROMANO HOLD HOLD ON A SECOND BE
SURE TO PROVIDE THIS COMPLEX
AND THEN PROCEED WITH
DISCUSSION FOR ISSUES ONE
THROUGH NINE IN THAT ORDER.
YEAH MISTER ROMANO. YES THE
COMPANY'S CARE MIHAEL ROMANO
RICK I THINK THE QUESTION. MARK
STAFF IS DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER
DEVICE ON. THIS HAPPENED TO
THIS WAS ONCE BEFORE I DO I DO
NOT. THE RULES OR IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD OF ROOM MY NAME IS
MIKE. THAT'S ALL THAT'S ALL
THAT. WE'LL FIND OUT OKAY-
CONTINUE HONEST ROMANO ARE YOU.
I APOLOGIZE CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW
YES GO AHEAD WE HEARD YET WE
JUST ONE ELIMINATE THAT ECKEL
SURE I'LL PUBLIC THOUSAND OKAY.
GO AHEAD THANK YOU. THANK THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME AND- I WANT TO
GIVE YOU A HELPFUL- A BRIEF
UPDATE ON THE COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE ON THE
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE
WHICH IS NESTED WITHIN THE- LAW
REVISION COMMISSION I'M HERE
WITH- BRIAN HUBERT AND
WRIGGLING WHO ARE TO STAFF
ATTORNEYS WHO WORK ON- IN THE
COMMISSION- THE COMMITTEE
BECAME EFFECTIVE THIS PAST
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY IT
HAS FIVE GOVERNOR APPOINTEES
INTO LEGISLATIVE APPOINTEES- I
REQUEST. FOR THE LEGISLATURE IS
TO ADD TO STAFF ATTORNEYS AND-
A PARALEGAL OR EXECUTIVE
ASSISTANT OR ADMINISTRATIVE
ASSISTANT- TO OUR STAFF WHICH
IS CURRENTLY MADE UP OF THREE
TOURNEY THREE ATTORNEYS- WE-
RESPECTFULLY SAY THAT WERE YOU
KNOW HUGELY UNDERSTAFFED AND
OVER WORK AND- I THINK THAT
WE'VE DONE A GREAT AMOUNT OF
WORK. THE LEGISLATIVE MANDATE
OF THE COMMITTEE IS TO SIMPLIFY
AND RATIONALISE SUBSTANCE A
PROCEDURE OF CALIFORNIA'S
ENTIRE CRIMINAL CODE OVER THIS
PAST YEAR- WE ESTABLISHED
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES. ARCHER
TO COMMIT OUR WORK WE- L.
THIRTEEN DAYS OF PUBLIC
HEARINGS WE BEGIN A STATE WIDE
AGGREGATION OF EMPIRICAL DATA
WE ENDED IN DECEMBER WE
APPROVED TEN SUBSTANTIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF REFORMS TO
THE PENAL CODE PUBLISHED AN
EIGHTY PAGE REPORT NINE BILLS
CURRENTLY PENDING IN THIS
ASSEMBLY AND STATE- IT INCLUDES
MOST OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE'VE ALSO- SUPPLEMENTED OUR
CURRENT STAFF WITH A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF OUTSIDE
SUPPORT OFTEN FROM
PHILANTHROPIES THAT PAY FOR
DATA ANALYSIS OF EXTRA LEGAL
SUPPORT AND EVEN SOME VOLUNTEER
HELP- COMPARED TO OTHER SIMILAR
COMMISSIONS I THINK WITH IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO IN OTHER
STATES- OUR STAFF IS QUITE
SMALL WERE EXTRAORDINARILY
PROUD OF EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE
DONE AND THEY'VE ACCOMPLISHED-
BUT WE REALLY COULD USE THE
EXTRA SUPPORT. OKAY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO HAVE ANYONE ELSE.
SPEAKER MADAM CHAIR SENATORS
I'M BRIAN HUBERT ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LAW
REVISION COMMISSION OKAY- WELL
WHICH IS ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
THEIR COMMITTEE ON REVISION OF
THE PENAL CODE. I DON'T HAVE
ANY PREPARED REMARKS JUST WANT
TO BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE OF MR MONO
THAT YOU WANT TO INTRODUCE. I'D
LIKE TO DO SO RICK- IN WHO IS
ARE A STAFF ATTORNEY AND ACTING
LEGAL DIRECTOR- WHO IS REALLY-
RIGHT NOW THE ONLY ATTORNEY WHO
IS A SUBSTANTIVE EXPERT FULL
TIME ON OUR STAFF. IT IS SEVEN
AND ANY QUESTIONS THAT HE
BRIAN- MYSELF MY TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER FOR YOU WOULD BE HAPPY
TO. THANK YOU- TERREMOTO AND
GOOD MORNING. MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS- LIKE MISTER HUBERT I
DO NOT HAVE ANY PREPARED
REMARKS BUT I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. WELL MISTER ¡N AND
WANTED TO JUST SHARE- YOU KNOW
ANYTHING THAT YOU WANT TO I
KNOW IT'S NOT PREPARED BUT IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU WOULD
WANT US TO KNOW. I DON'T HAVE
ANY PARTICULAR QUESTIONS BUT IF
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT YOU WANT
TO SHARE WITH US FROM YOUR
EXPERIENCE. SURE HIGH- AS AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING ON THE- COMMITTEE
TO REVISE THE PENAL CODE IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT- AT
ESPECIALLY AT THIS TIME- IN OUR
IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY- THE-
PENAL CODE WE LEARNED THIS PAST
YEAR IS INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED.
AND HAS BEEN. ADDED TO IT
AMENDED OVER THE YEARS AND WE
ARE. HOPING TO DO THE WORK-
THAT WILL PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WILL- INTO
UNNECESSARY IN CARS
INCARCERATION BUT ALSO CONTINUE
TO. IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY IN
THE STATE- SO. WE ARE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE TASK BUT AS
YOU COULD IMAGINE IT'S QUITE A
BIT OF WORK- IN. REALLY JUST
CONSULTING WITH SO MANY. GROUPS
THAT ARE COMMITTED TO- PENAL
CODE REFORM AND- TO PUBLIC
SAFETY IN THE STATE. AND SO IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW OF THE IDEAS THAT WE PUT
FORWARD AS A COMMITTEE. ARE
COMING FROM JUST A STAFF
ATTORNEY LIKE MYSELF IT REALLY
TAKES A LOT OF TIME TO CONSULT
WITH THESE OTHER GROUPS
INCLUDING- GROUPS THAT GROUPS
AND INDIVIDUALS THAT WE'VE
CONSULTED WITH AND IN OTHER
STATES. ABOUT DIFFERENT PENAL
CODE ISSUES- AND- I FOR ONE AM
EXCITED TO CONTINUE DOING THIS
WORK I'M EXCITED ABOUT WHAT WE
HAVE PLANNED FOR THIS YEAR. AND
I'M HOPEFUL THAT- WE COULD HAVE
ADDITIONAL. MEMBERS OF OUR TEAM
JOINT SOON. OKAY WELL FOR YOU-
AND- LA- DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. WITH NEARLY AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
DON'T HAVE THE CONCERNS OF THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOUNG OKAY. MR
OSBORNE. HI CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
SO LONG WE'RE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL. OKAY SENATE
COURTESY ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
NOT FOR ME THANK YOU THANK YOU
OKAY WELL THIS WAS KIND OF AN
EASY THING FOR YOU I THINK YOU
COULD DO WHAT YOU CAN TAKE AWAY
IS THAT WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
YOUR WORK WE CAN ONLY IMAGINE
THE- AMOUNT OF WORK AS YOU'RE
DESCRIBING THAT. HOW MASSIVE IT
IS BUT WE APPRECIATE THAT YOUR
DEMAND AND DOING THAT AND THAT
YOU ALSO INCLUDING OTHERS. THE
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AND- KINDA
LIKE THIS BROAD COALITION SEEMS
TO APPEARS TO BE WITH
DEVELOPING HERE SO. IF ANYBODY
WANTS TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
REMARKS MR IS IT HE BURKE I'M
SORRY. YES THAT'S RIGHT- YEAH I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT- YOU KNOW
TWENTY TWENTY WAS OUR INAUGURAL
YEAR FOR THIS BODY AND I'LL WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIMES SORT OF
STANDING IT UP- AND
ESTABLISHING WORK PRACTICES
AND- DOING ALL THAT DURING THE
PANDEMIC WAS CHALLENGING- AND
WE LEARNED A LOT AND INCLUDING
THE- THE FACT THAT. WE REALLY
WOULD BENEFIT FROM ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR THE REASONS THAT
ARE STATED IN THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL. OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING AND LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THERE AND NEXT REPORT
AND MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AN SO
WE'RE MOVING NOW TO THE TOP OF
THE AGENDA BACK TO ISSUES ONE
THROUGH NINE- WE'RE GOING. TO
GO TO ISSUE ONE OF THE
OVERSIGHT ITEM WHICH IS THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
SPECIAL REVIEW OF THE CDC OURS
NEW PROCEDURE FOR HANDLING
GRIEVANCES INVOLVING STAFF
MISCONDUCT. MISTER INSPECTOR
GENERAL. MISTER WESLEY GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS GOOD I'M ROY
WESLEY THE CALIFORNIA INSPECTOR
GENERAL THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME HERE TODAY TO BRIEF YOU ON
THE O. I. G. REVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION'S PROCESS FOR
REVIEWING AND INVESTIGATING.
INCARCERATED PERSONS
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
AND THE FORMATION OF THE NEW
UNIT TO HANDLE SUCH ALLEGATIONS
THE NEW UNIT IS CALLED THE
ALLEGATION ENQUIRY MANAGEMENT
SECTION FOR GAMES FOR SHORT.
THE GRIEVANCE PROCESS THAT WE
LOOKED AT CAME ABOUT AS A
RESULT OF A REVIEW MY OFFICE
COMPLETED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AT SALINAS VALLEY
STATE PRISON. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
PRISON LAW OFFICE ASKED US TO
LOOK AT HOW THE GRIEVANCES WERE
PROCESSED. AT SALINAS VALLEY
STATE PRISON. WE FOUND A SYSTEM
THAT WAS UTTERLY AND COMPLETELY
BROKEN. THE INCREASE CONDUCTED
BY INSTITUTIONAL STAFF AT
SALINAS VALLEY WERE RIFE WITH
BOTCHED INTERVIEWS OFFICER BIAS
AND NO SEMBLANCE OF FAIRNESS.
AS A RESULT WE MADE A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING THE
GRIEVANCE PROCESS. TO BE
IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE. THESE
RECOMMENDED THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT INCLUDED REMOVE
WARDENS AND INSTITUTIONAL STAFF
FROM THIS PROCESS. REGIONALI IS
THE PROCESS JUST AS THE OFFICE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS HAS
REGIONAL ICED ITS STAFF
MISCONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS. USE
TRAINED INVESTIGATORS TO
COMPLETE THESE ENQUIRIES AND
CREATE AN AUDIT FUNCTION TO
ENSURE DISCIPLINARY ACTION
RESULTING FROM ENQUIRIES WAS
ACTUALLY APPLIED. AFTER OUR
SALINAS VALLEY REPORT WAS
ISSUED THE DEPARTMENT PROFESSED
TO AGREE WITH OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS THE DEPARTMENT
REPRESENTED THAT THE INCREASE
WOULD BE REMOVED FROM THE
INSTITUTIONS AND THAT THE
WARDENS AND INSTITUTIONAL STAFF
WOULD NOT BE INVOLVED. IN THE
PROCESS. FOLLOWING OUR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN SALINAS
VALLEY REPORT THE DEPARTMENT
REQUESTED MONEY TO CREATE AND
STAFF THE AMES UNIT. JAMES WAS
SET UP TO BE A REGIONAL
ORGANIZATION WITHIN THE OFFICE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS TO PROVIDE
A CADRE OF PROFESSIONAL
INVESTIGATORS TO INVESTIGATE
INCARCERATED PERSONS COMPLAINTS
OF STAFF MISCONDUCT OUTSIDE THE
COMMAND STRUCTURE OF THE
PRISONS. IN THE 200-019-2000
TWENTY BUDGET THE DEPARTMENT
REQUESTED AND WAS GRANTED FORTY
SEVEN POSITIONS AND NINE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING. THE DEPARTMENT
STOOD UP AIMS TO CONDUCT THESE
INVESTIGATIONS. IN THEIR
REQUEST FOR FUNDING THE
DEPARTMENT PROMISED THAT THE
AIMS UNIT WOULD PERFORM FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
INCREASE PER MONTH. EQUALING
FIVE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND
NINETY INCREASE PER YEAR. THE
ALLEGATION INQUIRY MANAGEMENT
SECTION BECAME FULLY
OPERATIONAL ON APRIL FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY. IN ADDITION OUR
STATUTE THE O. I. G. STATUTE
WAS AMENDED TO DIRECT THE ORGY
TO MONITOR AND REPORT ON AIMS.
IN FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE ISSUED OUR FIRST REPORT.
UNFORTUNATELY AS OUR LATEST
REPORT DOCUMENTS THESE PROBLEM
PROMISES WERE NOT FULFILLED. BY
THE CONCLUSION OF THIS HEARING
I'D LIKE TO LEAVE YOU WITH THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT FINDINGS FIRST
WARDEN'S REMAINS CENTRAL TO
THIS PROCESS AND UNDERMINE THE
PURPOSE OF AIMS BY NOT
REFERRING CASES AND KEEPING
INCREASE WITHIN THE INSTITUTION.
TO THE DEPARTMENT HAS LIKELY
GROSSLY UNDERCOUNTED THE ACTUAL
NUMBER OF ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. BY ALLOWING WARDENS
TO SIMPLY RE CATEGORIZE
COMPLAINTS OF ALLEGATIONS OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT TO ROUTINE
GRIEVANCES. AND FINALLY WARDENS
RARELY FOUND MERIT IN THE
ALLEGATIONS THEY RESOLVED
ESSENTIALLY EXONERATING THEIR
STAFF. MORE THAN 98% OF THE
TIME. WE REVIEW THE ACTIVITIES
OF AIMS FOR A FIVE MONTH PERIOD
STARTING APRIL FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THROUGH AUGUST THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS WAS A
PERIOD WHEN AIMS WAS FULLY
FUNCTIONAL. DURING THIS FIVE
MONTH PERIOD THE UNIT ACCEPTED
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
INCREASE OR ABOUT ONE FIFTH. OF
WHAT. WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
PROPOSED IT WOULD HANDLE. WE
FOUND THAT WARDENS DETERMINED
DURING THIS PERIOD THAT TWO
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE GRIEVANCES ALLEGED
STAFF MISCONDUCT BUT WARDEN'S
ONLY REFERRED FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE OF THESE TO AIMS.
HOWEVER ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S OWN ANALYSIS WHEN
REQUESTING THE BUDGET
AUGMENTATION FOR AIMS. THAT
APART THE UNIT COULD HAVE
HANDLED ALL OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS. IF AIMS HAD
FULFILLED ITS PROMISE IN THE
NUMBER OF INCREASE THAT WOULD
HANDLE THE ANNUALIZED COST PER
ENQUIRY WOULD BE APPROXIMATELY
ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS. BASED ON THE
WORK THEY ACTUALLY DID THE
ANNUALIZED COST PER ENQUIRY IS
APPROXIMATELY NINE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
DOLLARS. WE ALSO FOUND THAT THE
WAY THE INCREASES ARE CONDUCTED
IS FLAWED. AIMS INVESTIGATORS
DO NOT PERFORM A COMPLETE AND
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION INSTEAD
THEY WORK TO A NEBULOUS
REASONABLE BELIEF STANDARD.
THAT IS A REASONABLE BELIEF
THAT MISCONDUCT MAY HAVE
OCCURRED. AND THEN STOP THEIR
INVESTIGATIVE ACTIVITIES WRITE
A REPORT AND SUBMIT THE REPORT
TO THE WARDEN. IF THE WARDEN
DISAGREES WITH THE CONCLUSION
BY THE INVESTIGATOR THE
ENQUIRIES OVER. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE DEPARTMENT
INFORMED THE LEGISLATURE THAT
THE WARDENS AND THE
INSTITUTIONAL STAFF WERE
REMOVED FROM THIS PROCESS.
HOEVER UNDER THE DEPARTMENT'S
REGULATIONS DEVELOPED AS A
RESULT OF OUR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN REPORT WARDENS AND
INSTITUTIONAL STAFF REMAINED
CENTRAL TO THIS PROCESS.
CURRENTLY WARDENS OR THEIR
CHIEFS REVIEW EVERY CLAIM THAT
POTENTIALLY CONTAINS A
GRIEVANCE ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. AND DETERMINE
WHETHER THE CLAIM MEETS THE
DEPARTMENT'S DEFINITION OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT AND WHETHER IT
WILL BE REFERRED OUTSIDE THE
PRISON. NOTHING GETS REFERRED
TO AIMS FOR INQUIRY WITHOUT THE
WARDEN MAKING A REFERRAL.
CONTRARY TO WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
ASSERTED IN AN ASSEMBLY HEARING
ALMOST TWO YEARS AGO. WARDENS
AND INSTITUTIONAL STAFF ARE
MOST ASSUREDLY NOT OUT OF THIS
PROCESS. WE ALSO FOUND THAT THE
CRITERIA THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPED FOR REFERRING
GRIEVANCES TO AIMS FOR THE
COMPLEX CALCULUS THAT WORKS TO
EXCLUDE MOST BECAUSE MOST
CLAIMS OF MISCONDUCT FROM BEING
INVESTIGATED BY AIMS. EXCLUDE
COMPLAINS THAT ALLEGED.
SERRATED PERSON'S CLAIM OF
UNNECESSARY OR EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE REPORTED BY STAFF BUT
THAT DID NOT RESULT IN SERIOUS
BODILY INJURY. SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT OR SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AGAINST AN INCARCERATED PERSON.
STAFF INVOLVEMENT IN DUE
PROCESS VIOLATIONS DURING THE
INMATE DISCIPLINARY PROCESS.
AND INCARCERATED PERSONS
ALLEGATIONS OF IMPROPER STAFF
DECISIONS DURING THE INMATE
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS. BUT
INCARCERATED PERSONS
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF ISSUANCE
OF FALSE RULES VIOLATIONS
REPORTS. AND IT INCARCERATED
PERSONS ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT IN CONNECTION WITH
THE AMERICANS WITH DISABILITY
ACT REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION
PROCESS. AS I NOTED EARLIER
WARDENS IDENTIFIED TWO THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE
GRIEVANCES AS STAFF MISCONDUCT
DURING OUR REVIEW PERIOD.
HOWEVER THEY ONLY REFERRED 23%
OF THOSE CASES TO AIMS. THEY
HANDLED THE BALANCE OF THE 77%
OF THE CASES INTERNALLY AT THE
PRISONS. IN ADDITION WE HAVE
UNCOVERED EVIDENCE THAT THE TWO
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE GRIEVANCES
IDENTIFIED BY THE WARDEN SAYS
STAFF MISCONDUCT. IS GROSSLY
UNDERCOUNTED. WE SUSPECT TAT
INCARCERATED PERSONS FILED
THOUSANDS MORE ALLEGATIONS OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S RECORDS SHOW.
UNDER THE PROCESS DEVELOPED BY
THE DEPARTMENT A GRIEVANCE IS
FIRST REVIEWED BY A GRIEVANCE
COORDINATOR WHO REFUSE TO SEE
IF THERE'S AN ALLEGATION OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT. AFTER THAT
REVIEW THE GRIEVANCE GOES FOR A
FINAL REVIEW TO THE WARDEN TO
CONCUR OR NOT WITH THE
GRIEVANCE COORDINATOR THAT THE
GRIEVANCE ALLEGES STAFF
MISCONDUCT. WARDENS
COUNTERMANDED THEIR GRIEVANCE
COORDINATOR 65% OF THE TIME AND
FOUND ONLY 35% OF THE
GRIEVANCES FORWARDED TO THEM.
ALLEGED STAFF MISCONDUCT. THE
GRIEVANCES THAT WARDENS FOUND
NOT TO BE STAFF MISCONDUCT
CLAIMS WERE SIMPLY RE
CATEGORIZED BY THE WARDEN AS A
ROUTINE GRIEVANCE. NEXT A FULL
TWO YEARS AFTER SURE INCE'S
WERE GIVEN NO AUDIT FUNCTION IS
ANYWHERE IN SIGHT. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS NO VISIBILITY ON
WHETHER THE GRIEVANCE PROCESS
IS WORKING. THE DEPARTMENT HAS
NO SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS ITSELF TO
PRODUCE REPORTS IDENTIFYING ALL
OFFICERS WHO HAVE BEEN ACCUSED
OF MISCONDUCT. OFFICERS WHO HAD
THOSE ACCUSATIONS CORROBORATED
OR WHO HAVE BEEN PUNISHED.
FINALLY JUST AS AT SALINAS
VALLEY TWO YEARS AGO THIS
PROCESS EXONERATE STAFF AT AN
ASTONISHING RATE. STAFF WERE
EXONERATED NINETY EIGHT POINT
3% OF THE TIME IN THE CASES
LOOKED AT EITHER BY AIMS OR
THOSE HANDLED IN HOUSE AT THE
PRISONS. IN FACT UNDER THIS
PROCESS THE RATE OF
EXONERATIONS EXCEEDS WHAT WE
FOUND AT SALINAS VALLEY TWO
YEARS AGO. THE ISSUES ARE
RAISED ABOVE ARE SYSTEMIC AND
NOT ISOLATED TO A PARTICULAR
PRISON. THE SHORTCOMINGS ARE
ENSHRINED IN REGULATIONS THAT
THE DEPARTMENT PROMULGATED
ALMOST A YEAR AGO. TO CORRECT
THESE DEFICIENCIES I BELIEVE
THE DEPARTMENT MUST COMPLETELY
OVERHAUL ITS PROCESS. IN MY
OPINION THE DEPARTMENT SHOULD
TAKE A CLEAN SHEET APPROACH TO
REVAMP THIS PROCESS. EMPHASIS
NEEDS TO BE ILL BE ON ALLOWING
AGGRIEVED PERSONS TO FORWARD
THEIR COMPLAINTS DIRECTLY TO
THE AIMS UNIT. AND THE AIMS
UNIT SHOULD CONDUCT ALL
ENQUIRIES NO MISCONDUCT
INCREASE SHOULD BE RETURNED TO
THE INSTITUTION. IN THE CASE OF
USE OF FORCE MISCONDUCT
COMPLAINTS THERE SHOULD BE NO
ARTIFICIAL DIFFERENTIATION
BETWEEN MISCONDUCT THAT CAUSES
PHYSICAL INJURY AND MISCONDUCT
THAT BY A STROKE OF LUCK DIDN'T
CAUSE PHYSICAL INJURY. THERE
SHOULD BE NO ARTIFICIAL
DIFFERENTIATION OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT GRIEVANCES. THE AMES
UNIT NEEDS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS IT OPENS
AND IT NEEDS TO DO MORE
THOROUGH INVESTIGATIONS.
INSTEAD OF WHAT WAS PROMISED
TWO YEARS AGO THE DEPARTMENT
DESIGNED A SYSTEM WITH MANY OFF
RAMPS THAT PREVENT A FAIR AND
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION OF
INCARCERATED PERSONS
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT.
DESPITE PROFESSING TO AGREE
WITH OUR PRIOR RECOMMENDATIONS
THE DEPARTMENT IMPLEMENTED FEW
IF ANY OF THEM. SINCE THE
LATEST REPORT ISSUED I'D LIKE
TO NOTE THAT THE SECRETARY AND
I HAD A VERY POSITIVE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THESE ISSUES
LAST WEEK AND IN RESPONSE TO
HER IMITATION I LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ON THESE AND OTHER
ISSUES. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER WESLEY.
I'M. ALL RIGHT. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SECRETARY I DON'T
SEE ON THEM ON MY. OKAY
SECRETARY ALISON. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE KATHLEEN
ALISON SECRETARY FOR CDC ARE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO SPEAK TO THESE VERY
SERIOUS ISSUES I'M THANK YOU
SEE OUR TAKES EVERY ALLEGATION
OF STAFF MISCONDUCT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WE ARE COMMITTED
TO ENSURING ALL ALLEGATIONS ARE
PROPERLY AND FAIRLY AND
THOROUGHLY REVIEWED. WE WELCOME
THE OFFICERS INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S REVIEW WE'VE SPOKEN
MANY TIMES SINCE REPORTS
BASICALLY ABOUT HIS REPORT WE
SPEAK OFTEN BUT WE SPOKEN
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT HIS REPORT
AND I CERTAINLY FIND HIS
INSIGHT VERY VALUABLE- OKAY
MINISTRATION AND THIS AGENCY
HAS DEMONSTRATED A COMMITMENT
TO SEEKING OUTSIDE INDEPENDENT
REVIEWS AS EVIDENCED BY ASKING
THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
TO DO THAT I TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN WRESTLERS VALERIE
REPORTS- ON. REVAMPING OUR KILL
SYSTEMS VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART WHEN I WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE ADULT
INSTITUTIONS AND TRAVERSES
REALIZE THAT THEY'RE. TOO DARK-
I KNEW FROM MY MANY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WELL OVER THIRTY- IF
THIS BUSINESS THAT. THERE OR
THERE WAS A DISCONNECT BETWEEN
OUR STAFF ALLEGATIONS- PROCESS
AT FIRST SAYS ARE- INTERNAL
AFFAIRS WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS
WE HAVE NUMEROUS INMATES- STAFF
COMPLAINTS. MOST AS AS THE
OPTION INSPECTOR GENERAL STATED
MOST ARE WITH NO FINDINGS
HOWEVER. I HAVE WELL OVER TO AN
AVERAGE OF TWO THOUSAND CASES
ANNUALLY THAT ARE REFERRED FOR
INVESTIGATION SO THERE'S A
DISCONNECT SOMEWHERE. AND ALL
OF THAT OVER TWO THOUSAND-
REFERRALS TO OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS ANYWHERE FROM TWELVE TO
FIFTEEN HUNDRED OF THOSE
RESULTS IN FORMAL- ADVERSE
ACTION ON OUR STAFF. SO THERE
WAS THERE WAS A DISCONNECTED
THE DEPARTMENT WENT THROUGH I'M
AND DEVELOPED A PROCESS THAT
WAS IMPLEMENTED IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY. INITIALLY AND
THEN FULL IMPLEMENTATION IN
APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY IN THE
THROES OF COKE. THEREFORE IT.
EIGHT AND I ALSO HAVE TO SAY
THIS THAT I ALSO THINK THAT WE
MADE IT TOO COMPLEX THE PROCESS
WAS VERY VERY COMPLEX AS AS
THE- IG REPORT HIGHLIGHTS- WITH
A VARIETY OF CONCERNS. AND SO
I'M HERE TO COMMIT TODAY TO
MAKE YOU VERY SPECIFIC CHANGES.
TO THIS PROCESS- AND REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD- TO HAVE IN A
SEAMLESS PROCESS THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYBODY I JUST. IT'S VERY
TROUBLING- ANYWAY I APOLOGIZE
SO- THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE MADE
IT WE MADE IT TOO DIFFICULT FOR
THE INSTITUTIONS AND WE WERE
ALREADY IN THE PROCESS OF
EVALUATING OUR- OUR- PROCESS
EARLY EARLY ON. AND WE MERE
SOMEWHAT WE CAME UP WITH SOME
OF THE SAME SOLUTIONS OF THE- I
CHEATED I WILL SAY THAT WE
FOUND NO EVIDENCE THAT WARDENS
WERE NOT- PROPERLY REFERRED.
WHAT W FOUND BECAUSE THAT IT
WAS THE DEFINITION ON HOW THEY
GOT THERE AND EXCLUSIONARY
CRITERIA WHICH WERE. SOME OF
THE PRIMARY CONCERNS THAT WE
NEED TO FOCUS OUR ENERGY ON
GOING FORWARD. WE ALSO FOUND
THAT THE AMOUNT OF TIME FAR
EXCEEDED THE ORIGINAL ESTIMATES.
SC'S CONCERT WE'RE CURRENTLY
DOING NEXT TIME AND MOTION
STUDY- THE FIGURE OUT EXACTLY
HOW LONG IT TAKES AND SOME OF
THE REASONS WHY I WILL SAY
THAT- AS I READ THESE REPORTS
FIRST IS WHAT I USED TO READ AT
INSTITUTIONAL LEVEL WHEN A
LIEUTENANT PROVIDING MERE
REPORT- ARE MUCH MORE DETAIL
NOW. BEING IN A LOT OF
INTERVIEWS BY LOTS OF. NOT ONLY
THAT THE COMPLAINANT BUT ANY
WITNESSES OF OTHER OFFENDERS OR
STAFF IS- PART OF THE PROCESS.
I WILL SAY IF YOU HAVE CAMERAS
IT MAKES IT TOTALLY DIFFERENT
REPORT. AMR'S REALLY HELP US TO
IDENTIFY REAL TO FIND YOU KNOW
IT WHETHER THE ALLEGATION IS
TRUE OR NOT- SO I WILL SAY THAT.
I'M SO SOME OF OUR VERY
SPECIFIC COMMITMENTS FIRST TO
THE INCONSISTENT APPLICATION OF
THE SCREENING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. I HAVE DIRECTED MY TEAM
FOR IMMEDIATE STRATEGY
IMPLEMENT A STATEWIDE.
ACTUALIZE GRADING PROCESS FOR
ALL ALLEGATIONS AGAINST STAFF.
BY THE INCARCERATED POPULATION
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF PREAH-
WHICH WE ALREADY HAVE A VERY
ROBUST PROCESS MONITORED BY THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL AS
WELL AS AUDITED BY THE-
GOVERNMENT. RE ONE OF THE
PRIMARY REASONS FOR THAT IS IN
ANY KIND OF PRE ALLOCATION YOU
HAVE TO HAVE REAL TIME EVIDENCE
YOU ONLY HAVE SO. MUCH TRYING
TO GET SOMEBODY TO- FOR THE
FULL PHYSICAL EXAMINATION THAT
WOULD NEED TO BE DONE- SO
THAT'S PART OF THE PROCESS AND
THAT IS CURRENTLY NEARED BY THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL.
BUT OUR SCREENING PROCESS WILL
THIS WILL BE A SINGLE
INDEPENDENT SOURCE TO ENSURE
THE CURRENT REGULATIONS ARE
CORRECTLY APPLIED IN
DETERMINING WHETHER STAFF
COMPLAINTS WOULD BE REFERRED.
FOR PROCESSING AND REMOVED THE
INSTITUTION FROM THE LOOK FROM
THE I'M PROCESS FROM SCREENING
FOR THE GO OUT OF THE SCREEN
BY- THE HEADQUARTERS THEY'LL
MAKE A DETERMINATION ON WHO
BEST TO HANDLE THAT COMPLAINT.
THIS WOULD INCLUDE ALL
ALLEGATIONS OF EXCESSIVE OR
UNNECESSARY FORCE. THIS WOULD
ALLOW THE LOCAL GRIEVANCES
ALREADY SKEWS ME LOCAL
GRIEVANCE CORNERS TO SIMPLY FOR
ANY GRIEVANCE RECEIVED. THAT IS
A STAFF COMPLAINED TO THE STATE
WIDE CENTRAL ASIA FOR
PROCESSING. OUR CURRENT
PRACTICES TO FOLLOW. I
APOLOGIZE OUR CURRENT PRACTICE
AT THIS POINT HAS BEEN THAT THE
LOCAL INSTITUTION INSTITUTIONS
TO DETERMINE. IF A STAFF
COMPLAINT WAS FOLLOWED SKEWS ME
I APOLOGIZE IF IT'S STAFF
COMPLAINT WAS FOUND TO BE TRUE
AND HAS LUCK WITH THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT ADVERSE ACTION
WOULD RESULT. IN THOSE GO
FORWARD AGAIN TO COMPLEX- GOOD
THIS COMMITMENT OVER
CENTRALIZED SCREENING UNITS A
LOCAL INSTITUTION WILL NO
LONGER APPLY THIS COMPLEX
CRITERIA ENSURING ALL STAFF
COMPLAINTS GO TO INDEPENDENT
OUTSIDE AREA. APPLY THIS POLICY
STANDARD SECONDLY. WE CURRENTLY
PROCESS ALLEGATIONS OF
EXCESSIVE OR UNNECESSARY FORCE
WITH SERVICE BODILY INJURY AS
IN AMES ENQUIRING. RECOGNIZING
THAT SERVICE BODILY INJURY DID
NOT ACCOUNT FOR ALL OTHER
INJURIES OUTSIDE OF THE
DEFINITION OF SERVICE VOLLEY
INJURY AS A RESULT. ARE THE
FIRST STEP. I HAVE DIRECTED MY
TEAM TO INSTITUTE AN EXPANSION
OF THIS PROCESS WHERE ALL
ALLEGATIONS OF UNNECESSARY OR
EXCESSIVE FORCE WITH ANY INJURY.
ARE REFERRED TO THE AIM SHUNET
INCLUDING THOSE THAT DO NOT
MEET SB I. THIRD I HAVE
DIRECTED MY STAFF TO.
IMMEDIATELY IMPLEMENT A PROCESS
WORKS PAINS INQUIRE RES WILL
PROVIDE A CLEAR. CONCLUSION
THAT WILL. INDICATE TWO
POSSIBLE OUTCOMES ONE A
THOROUGH AND COMPLETE INQUIRY
HAS BEEN COMPLETED TO INCLUDE
ALL FAX. THEY BELIEVE AVAILABLE
TO. REASONABLE BELIEF THAT
MISCONDUCT HAS OCCURRED AND MAY
LEAD FOR ADVERSE ACTION WHEN
REASONABLE LEAVE HAS REACHED
IMMEDIATE FIRST STEP TO CHANGE
OUR PROCESS A REQUEST FOR
INVESTIGATION WILL BE INITIATED
BY THE AIMS UNITS. REFER TO THE
HIRING AUTHORITY- OUR SIGNATURE.
THIS WILL ALLOW MORE SWIFTLY
PROCESS WERE REQUIRED TO
INVESTIGATE. MY EXPECTATION IS
THAT SHOULD A HIRING HISTORIAL
LOCAL LEVEL DISAGREED WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR
INVESTIGATION THEY ARE TO MEET
LEE REFERRED THAT TO THE AIMS
TO YOU FOR RESOLUTION ALLOWING
FOR MONITORING OVERSIGHT AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL. IF THERE IS
CONTINUED DISAGREEMENT THEN
THEY ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR- WOULD
ALSO GET INVOLVED AND TO
RESOLVE ANY DISPUTE. IN
ADDITION TO THE FIRST REACTIONS
I PENSION THE- THIS THIS
AFTERNOON WE ALSO AGREED THAT
THE DEFINITION- NEEDS TO BE
ABOUT ARE YOU WAITED. AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
GETTING IT RIGHT THIS TIME THAT
WE SLOW DOWN ENOUGH TO GET IT
RIGHT THAT WE LOOK AT NATIONAL
BEST PRACTICES- WE LOOK AT
THEIR JURISDICTIONS EVEN IN
CALIFORNIA. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN HAVE THE BEST ALLEGATION
QUERY PROCESS AVAILABLE- I'M SO
I'D ASK MY STAFF TO START DOING
SOME SURVEYS. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET THIS RIGHT- WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE DEFINITION. WE
ARE WE ARE ALSO- LOOKING AT
THAT TIME LINE AS IT RELATES TO
ALLEGATIONS THAT ANY POTENTIAL
IMPACT OTHER TIME. THAT ARE
IMPACTED SO DEFINITELY OPEN TO
SOME ADDITIONAL CHANGES THERE.
FURTHERMORE THE DEPARTMENT
RECOGNIZES THAT MULTIPLE
ISOLATED DATA SYSTEMS ARE NOT
PERFORMING OPTIMALLY. BAKER
RECORDING OF END TO END PROCESS
IS DIFFICULT. UNFORTUNATELY DUE
TO THE FOCUS OF RESOURCES
RESPONDED OVERHEAD NINETEEN
PANDEMIC DID YOU SEE OUR WAS
UNABLE TO INVEST INTERNAL.
INTERNAL RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THAT. ISSUE DURING DURING THE
INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION OF
BANKING. AS A SITUATION
REGARDING THAT PAT AND EMMITT
CONTINUES TO IMPROVE IN THE
COMING WEEKS SHIFT OF OUR
ATTENTIONAL RESOURCES TO FIND
OUT- WORKABLE IT SOLUTION. WILL
BE UNDER WAY. I AM COMMITTED.
FOR THESE EITHER TO READ THE
REVIEWS AND THOROUGHLY. FINALLY
WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF
THIS COMMITTEE. IN OUR
ADDITIONAL CAMERA- SYSTEMS THAT
ARE G. LANCASTER'S STATE PRISON
FACILITIES B. AND D. WHICH IS
INCLUDED IN THAT ARMSTRONG
COURT COMPLIANCE PROPOSAL. I
FIRMLY BELIEVE CAMERAS WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY BENEFIT THE
REDUCTION OF STAFF COMPLAINTS
THAT WE'VE SEEN THIS AT OUR
INSTITUTIONS THAT CURRENTLY
HAVE CAMERAS WE HAVE CAMERAS AT
HIGH DESERT STATE PRISON- CCW
AFTER A SURGE OF CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S FACILITY IN CHOWCHILLA.
WE HAVE A SPECIFIC MENTAL
HEALTH- HOUSING UNITS AT CSP
SACRAMENTO- ABOUT A STATE
PRISON HAS A FEW CAMERAS OF
COURSE NOW R. J. D. HAS CAMERAS
I WILL BE IMPLEMENTED IN APRIL.
OF THIS YEAR AND THE CORE AND
WE ACTIVATED BODY CAMERAS IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR I DO
BELIEVE AND THERE IS EVIDENCE
TO SHOW A REDUCTION OF STAFF
COMPLAINTS- SO CERTAINLY ASK
FOR YOUR. SUPPORT WHERE- I
WONDER REITERATE TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE MY RECOGNITION THAT
THERE IS MUCH TO IMPROVE IN THE
CURRENT PROCESSES LAID OUT BY
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL. MY
COMMITMENT TO CREATE A SWIFT
CHANGE TO APPROVE THE PROCESS
BY OPENNESS TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. WHILE DOING SO. I
WOULD NOW LIKE TO TURN IT OVER
TO FISCAL SERVICES DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ERICA SWANSON DIRECTOR
AMY MILLER AND ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR MARION SPARE MENTORED
BY THE BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR
ARMSTRONG COURT COMPLIANCE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR. ACTUALLY I
THINK WE CAN GET TO ARMSTRONG
IN THE NEXT ISSUE SO WE CAN DO
FOR OUR COMMENTS FOR NOW ON
THAT ISSUE YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SWANSON THANK YOU
SECRETARY ALISON WILL WILL HOLD
OFF ON ARMSTRONG. FIRST THE
ADDRESS THIS AND THEN WE'LL
MOVE TO THE NEXT. THE NEXT
ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SECRETARY ALLISON- I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THAT THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT. BEING HAD BETWEEN
YOURSELF AND THE- INSPECTOR
GENERAL- AS AS A WE TRY TO MOVE
FORWARD AND MAKE A LOT MORE
PROGRESS I WANT TO ASK THE- THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL A FEW
QUESTIONS. MISTER WESLEY YES
MA'AM- EIGHT YOU MADE REFERENCE
TO YOU YOU FELT THAT THESE
ISSUES AND PROBLEMS- WERE-
VERSUS A SPECIFIC PROBLEMS THAT
SPECIFIC OF FACILITIES- COULD
YOU DESCRIBE WHAT YOU SAY THAT.
IN OUR REVIEW OF THE- THAT WAS
HIGHLIGHTED IN OUR LATEST
LATEST REPORT- WE LOOKED AT WE
LOOK ACROSS THE- DEPARTMENTS-
SPECTRUM OF PRISONS AND WE
FOUND THE SAME ISSUES. OVER AND
OVER AGAIN- THE BIGGEST ISSUE
THAT WE FOUND WAS THAT- WARDENS
RECOUNTED RAISED STAFF
MISCONDUCT COMPLAINTS AND
APPEARED NOT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE CRITERIA WAS FOR- FOR
REFERRAL TO AIMS AND EVEN WHEN.
THEY CLEARLY MET THE REFERRAL
CRITERIA- MOST OF THEM 77% AND
THAT'S A NUMBER FROM ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM WERE KEPT IN THE
PRISON AND DONE LOCALLY-
ACCORDING TO THE REGULATIONS
DEVELOPED BY THE DEPARTMENT
THOUGH SHOULD HAVE BEEN
REFERRED TO AIMS- SO IT WAS IT
THIS WASN'T SOMETHING THAT WAS
JUST ISOLATED TO ONE PRISON- WE
SAW THE SAME ISSUES- AT PRETTY
MUCH EVERY PRISON- IN THE STATE.
FROM ARE THERE ANY RESOURCES
THAT YOUR OFFICE MAY NEED TO
HELP OUR CONTINUE TO OUR REPORT
ON THIS PROCESS. YES MA'AM THE-
OUR OFFICE IS. SERIOUSLY UNDER
RESOURCE TO REVIEW THE NUMBER
OF COMPLAINTS AND PROVIDE THE
MONITORING- THAT WE THINK IS
APPROPRIATE- WE HAVE FIVE
PEOPLE STATE WIDE ONE OF THOSE
AS A SUPERVISOR SO WE HAVE FOUR
PEOPLE OUT IN THE FIELD WHO DO
THIS KIND OF MONITORING- AND SO
WE CAN DO NOTHING MORE THAN-
ANECDOTAL MONITORING OF THE- OF
THE QUALITY OF THE OF THE
INQUIRY'S- WE RECOMMEND THAT-
AS IN OUR OTHER MONITORING
ACTIVITIES THAT WE MONITOR
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT- 25%
OR MORE OF. THE ENCOURAGED TO
GO FORWARD WE THINK THAT GIVES
A GOOD STATISTICAL MODEL TO
DRAW CONCLUSIONS FROM- WHAT WE
ARE- WHAT OUR FIRST REPORT HAS
FOCUSED ON IS THE IS THE BONES
OF THE PROCESS HOW IT'S SET UP
AND HOW THAT'S WORKING WE HAVE
NOT FOCUSED ON THE QUALITY OF
THE INTERVIEWS- SIMPLY BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE PEOPLE TO DO
THAT- I'M I- HAVE- WE WORKED UP
SOME. SOME NUMBERS- AND I'M
HAPPY TO SHARE THOSE WITH YOU-
BUT BUT BASED ON THE RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE- THERE IS THERE
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH MONITORS TO-
ACTUALLY PROVIDE GOOD
INFORMATION ON HOW THE PROCESS
IS WORKING- IN A QUALITATIVE
SENSE OF ONE OTHER THING I'D
LIKE TO CLARIFY- IN THAT IS THE
PRE A PIECE I'D LIKE TO- SORT
AMPLIFY ON WHAT THE SECRETARY
NOTED- SHE NOTED THAT WE
MONITOR PRIA THAT'S NOT
PRECISELY TRUE- OUR- OUR
STATUTE. REQUIRES A HER NAME'S
US AS THE PRE OP OMBUDSMAN- AND
SO THE DIFFERENCE IN THAT IS
THAT WOULD YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO IS THE VICTIM OF A PRIA.
COMPLAINS ABOUT- THE
INVESTIGATION OR HOW THAT HOW
THAT. ALLEGATION WAS HANDLED BY
THE DEPARTMENT. THEN WE LOOK AT
IT BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
MONITORING PROCESS THAT
INDEPENDENTLY LOOKS AT HOW THE
DEPARTMENT DOES ITS PRE A
PROCESS- OURS IS VERY MUCH.
DRIVEN BY IF SOMEBODY
COMPLAINS- WHO HAS BEEN PART OF
THE- WHO IS MADE OF A PRE A
COMPLAINT- SO AGAIN I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY WHAT OUR PRIA
OF MONITORING IS THANK YOU AND
IF THE LEGISLATURE WERE TO
ADOPT YOUR- COMMENDATIONS. WHAT
WHAT WHAT WHAT KIND OF WOULD
THERE BE A NEED TO CHANGE YOUR
RESPONSIBILITIES AS THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. BOB FOR THIS
PROCESS- THE RESPONSIBILITIES
WOULD REMAIN THE SAME AS
OUTLINED IN THE STATUTE CHANGE
FROM TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY. WE WERE- OUR STATUTE
PROVIDES THAT WE WOULD MONITOR
THIS PROCESS AND- THE ONLY
THING THAT'S REALLY KEEPING US
FROM DOING A ROBUST MONITORING
IS THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WE HAVE
TO DO IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FROM AND THE MY QUESTIONS WERE
C. D. C. R- OF WHETHER IT'S
SECRETARY ALISON OR ANYONE
ELSE- IT YOUR RESPONSE TO THE
REPORT IS ARE YOU PREPARING A
RESPONSE TO THE REPORT OR- TO
REPORT BY THE O. I. G. WE
PREPARE A CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLAN WE DID DRAFT INITIAL
LETTER ACKNOWLEDGING THE REPORT
BUT WE PREPARE CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLAN. ON ANY OF THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORTS AND WE PROVIDE REGULAR
FOLLOW UP. BUT THEY WILL BE
PART OF OUR PROCESS- AS WE
DEVELOP SOME OF OUR SUBSEQUENT
CHANGES THAT ARE ALREADY UNDER
WAY BE HAPPY TO SHARE THIS WITH
YOU AS WELL AS MR- WHAT YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU MENTIONED
THAT YOU WERE- LOSING TO MAKE
CHANGES. ARE YOU GOING TO MAKE
THOSE CHANGES THROUGH AIMS- IS
THAT WHERE YOU PROPOSED TO DO
IT OR- YEAH SO CHANGES THE
FIRST THE FIRSTCHANGE THAT
THAT ABSOLUTELY HAS TO BE MADE
IS IN THE SCREENING PROCESS WE
MADE THAT VERY VERY TO COMPLEX
I'M JUST SAYING IT'S SO COMPLEX
I DON'T. YOU'RE READING IT- SO
WERE THE FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A CENTRAL A
SCREENING PROCESS. OUTSIDE OF
THE INSTITUTIONS M. M. AND
CURRENTLY THAT WILL BE IN OUR
AIMS UNITS. SPECIALIZED TRAINED
STAFF TO SCREEN THOSE MAKE A
DETERMINATION ON WHAT'S THE
BEST WAY TO HANDLE. ONE OF THE-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL REFERRED TO
WAS THAT THERE WAS A- THE
SYSTEM SUPPOSED TO EXCLUDE THE
INSTITUTION. ON FROM THE
INVESTIGATIONS FROM THE UNIT
FROM THE- ACCEPTANCE OR NON
ACCEPTANCE OF THE COMPLAINTS-
AND THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE THE
CASE HERE SEEMS TO BE THAT THE
WARDENS ARE FULLY INVOLVED
ACTIVELY INVOLVED. IN DECIDING
WHICH CASES ARE AIRED
GRIEVANCES OR IF THEIR
INVESTIGATIONS OF SO HOW DO YOU
RESPOND TO THAT BECAUSE IS AS
HE DESCRIBED IT. THE
INSTITUTION OF THE WARDENS WERE
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE A PART OF
THIS. AND YET THEY ARE. I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR THE PRIOR- AGENCY
LEADS AS FAR AS WHAT THEIR
AGREEMENTS FOR I CAN I CAN TELL
YOU FROM MY PERSPECTIVE WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO GO FROM HERE-
AND HONESTLY THIS. THAT THE
DEFINITION WILL LIKELY TO LEAD
TO ADVERSE ACTION. IS
RELATIVELY COMPLEX WITH THE
INFORMATION YOU HAVE IN FRONT
OF YOU YOU NEED ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION I WILL SAY THAT THE
WARDENS WERE NOT INTENTIONALLY
NOT SENDING THINGS OFF TO AIMS
IT JUST SOMETIMES DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH BASED ON ALL THE VARIOUS
DEFINITIONS AND EXCLUSIONARY
CRITERIA THAT'S WHAT MADE IT
MADE IT SO DIFFICULT. SO I DO
THINK THAT RESOLVING THAT
PROBLEM BY HAVING A CENTRALIZED
PROCESS OUTSIDE OF THE
INSTITUTIONS WILL BE HELPFUL
BUT AS I SAID THERE WE FOUND NO
EVIDENCE THAT WARNS WERE
INTENSELY NOT SENDING ANYTHING
OFF TO AIMS I MEAN AND I CAN
AND I WANT TO JUST REITERATE
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE WELL OVER
TWO THOUSAND INVESTIGATIONS
FORMAL INVESTIGATIONS AT
WHARTON CENTER EVERY SINGLE.
YEAR. OF THE OF THE TWO
THOUSAND- ALLEGATIONS THAT WERE
SENT TO THE WARDEN'S ONLY FIVE
HUNDRED WENT TO AMES. WHAT I
CAN HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE. IT'S
VERY SIX CLOSURE CRITERIA THAT
WE HAD. THAT DAY THEY GO ONCE
INTO DIFFERENT BUCKETS AND ALL
ALL USE- WHETHER IT'S- A RULES
VIOLATION REPORTS THAT MIGHT
HAVE HAD- A DUE PROCESS
VIOLATION BUT NOT NECESSARILY
YOU KNOW LIEUTENANT JONES WAS
DISRESPECTFUL. IT'S A PROCESS
ALLEGATION VERSE SAYS- YOU KNOW
WHAT MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS- SO
THERE'S A VARIETY OF REASONS
WHY THINGS GOT SCREENED OUT
BASED ON THE SCREEN OUT
CRITERIA AS WELL AS THE
DEFINITION THAT MADE IT VERY IT
MADE IT TOO COMPLEX FOR THE
INSTITUTIONS. TO START WITH I
MEAN THAT'S THAT'S THE BOTTOM
LINE FOR THE ISSUE AND I DO
FEEL LIKE THIS PROCESS OTHER
MAYBE SOME THAT ARE GOING TO BE
RETURNED TO THE INSTITUTIONS
FOR ANALYSIS OF THE RULES
VIOLATION REPORT FOR- DUE
PROCESS VIOLATION IN THE JUST.
MAKE DISCIPLINARY PROCESS- AND
OF COURSE AS WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT YOU KNOW PRIA AND OTHERS
YOU KNOW- THEY'RE DONE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND THEN OF COURSE
YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE A VERY
ROBUST- PROCESS AS RELATES TO
OUR USE OF FORCE- AND- I. G.
BEARS ARE USED TO FORCE
PROCESSES WELL. AND SO YOU KNOW
WE HAVE AGREED THAT THE
ALLEGATIONS OF EXCESSIVE OR
UNNECESSARY FORCE WILL GO AHEAD
AND TO BE PROCESSED BY AIMS.
THE INSTITUTION WILL HOLD THEIR
USE OF FORCE COMMITTEES UNTIL
THEY GET THAT BACK- BUT THE
OFFICE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS
SITTING OUT ON THOSE
COMMITTEES. SO I REALIZE THE
NUMBERS SEEM. AND I WANT TO
MAKE TWO FOUR FOUR ONE OTHER
POINT THE NUMBERS MISTER WESLEY
IS REFERRING TO- AS FAR AS THE
TWO THOUSAND DOWN TO FIVE
HUNDRED ARE NOT THE SAME TWO
THOUSAND THAT I'M REFERRING TO
THAT WERE FORMERLY BEST ENGAGED
OR MAKE SURE THAT. HIS ACTION
BECAUSE WE HOW OF- AT ANY TIME
STAFF CAN HAVE A VARIETY OF
MISCONDUCT WHETHER IT'S INMATE
RELATED OR OFF DUTY MISCONDUCT.
THAT IS REFERRED TO THE OFFICE
OF THE TROUBLE. THOSE CASES ARE
INVESTIGATED THE OFFICER THE
SPECTER GENERAL SENSE- AT THE
CENTRAL INTAKE PROCESS ON DAY
ONE. WHEN THAT CASE IS BEING
EVALUATED TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION WHETHER IT'S
GOING TO GO FOR FORMAL
INVESTIGATION OVER THIS COULD
BE SENT BACK TO THE INSTITUTE.
FOR A DIRECT. ACTION MEANING
THERE'S ENOUGH INFORMATION AND
I'LL USE AN EXAMPLE IF THE- REX
LAW OFFICER IS ARRESTED FOR-
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE. WE
HAVE A POLICE REPORT WE HAVE
ALL THE INFORMATION WE NEED WE
DON'T NECESSARILY NEED TO DO AN
INVESTIGATION. BUT WE HAVE TO
TAKE THIS ACTION. SO IS THOSE
KIND OF NEW WANTS SAYS- BUT IF
AN INVESTIGATION IS NEEDED.
WHEN IT GOES FOR FULL
INVESTIGATION IN THAT PROCESS-
I. G. GETS TO PICK WHICH CASES
THEY WANT TO DO DEPEND UPON THE
SEVERITY OF THE ALLEGATIONS.
AND PROCEED THROUGH THE THROUGH
THE ENTIRE PROCESS- FROM THE
INVESTIGATION. TO THE FINAL
DETERMINATION OF THE PENALTY AT
THE LOCAL INSTITUTION AS WELL
AS FOLLOWS IT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE STATE PERSONNEL
BOARD PROCESS. IF YOU ASK
MEMBER FEELS THAT. WE'RE
TALKING TO DIFFERENT THINGS-
AND SO THAT WAS CLEAR I HAVE
ONE MORE QUESTION AND THEN I'LL
OPEN IT UP TO MY COLLEAGUES- IN
THE NEW PROCESS THAT YOU ARE
SUGGESTING AND RECOMMENDING.
ARE THE WARD IS. GOING TO BE A
PART OF THAT PROCESS- DISCRETE
FOR. VERY WILL NOT BE PART OF
THAT NO WE TAKE THOSE. THE
GRIEVANCE COORDINATOR
VANSITTART WILL COLLECT THEIR
GRIEVANCES FROM THEIR
INDIVIDUAL FACILITIES
INDIVIDUAL YARDS AT THE
INSTITUTION. AND THEY WILL
PACKAGE THEM UP AND SEND THEM
TO A FIRST BILL WORKING OUT
WITH US AND BE LIKE TRONIC AND-
OR WHETHER IT'S GONNA BE A-
MAIL SENT I. STAFFER STILL
LOOKING AT THAT PIECE OF IT BUT
THOSE WILLING WILL NOT GO
THROUGH A LOCALIZED REMAIN- IT
WILL JUST BE. I SHOULDN'T SAY
IT WILL GO THROUGH ALL THAT
ADVERSITY GREENS CARD IT'LL
EVALUATE MAKE SURE. O. OKAY
IT'S A STAFF COMPLAIN VERSES I
THINK IT A LUNCH YES. I'M A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT KIND OF
PLAY OR MY LUNCH WAS. HOLDER
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE- YOU
STILL HAVE GRIEVANCES THAT ARE
NOT STAFF COMPLAIN SO HE'LL
MAKE THAT INITIAL DETERMINATION
AND THEN SPEND THAT. THOSE WILL
BE. OUT FOR SCREENING AND THE
DETERMINATION OF WHAT'S
PROCESS- WHERE WHERE IT NEEDS
TO GO IS THERE ENOUGH FOR AN
INVESTIGATION CURRENTLY DO WE
NEED AIMS TO DO AN EVALUATION
PROVIDE THAT THE INSTITUTIONS
WITH MORE INFORMATION SO I CAN
MAKE A DETERMINATION. ON-
WHAT'S THE BEST COURSE OF
ACTION AND JUST TO BE CLEAR THE
COORDINATOR THE GRIEVANCE
COORDINATOR THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT'S ONE AT EACH
FACILITY. OR IS THAT WHAT IT IS
WE HAVE ONE EACH INSTITUTION
YES MA'AM OKAY IS THAT CORRECT
OKAY. SENATORS OF CENTER NEWMAN-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SURGERY
ALSO THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US TODAY- I WANTED TO AYE I'M
STRUCK BY YOUR REFERENCE TO THE
FAIRLY LARGE NUMBER PER OR PER
SHARE OF THE CASES THAT WERE
REFERRED FOR FORMAL
INVESTIGATION YOU MENTION
FIFTEEN HUNDRED CASES OF TWO
THOUSAND. WHICH I THINK BASED
ON THE REST OF. THE TESTIMONY
TODAY IS PROBABLY A MUCH
SMALLER NUMBERS THAN IT SHOULD
BE. YES MY QUESTION FOR YOU AT
LEAST TO START IS IF YOU WERE
TO MOVE. THE SCREENING TO A
CENTRALIZED PROCESS THAT AS YOU
MENTIONED. ONE OF THE RESOURCE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THAT AND DO
YOU HAVE OR THEIR CURRENT STAFF
TO DO THAT IF NOT. IS THERE A
COST THAT YOU COULD ACCESS TO
THAT AND IS IT ALREADY BUDGETED.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
AND- WE WILL HAVE TO DETERMINE
EXACTLY WHAT RIGHT NOW WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE SOME INTERNAL
RESOURCES OR REDIRECT THEM. TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS INITIALLY WE
ALSO HAVE THE R. J. D. REQUEST
WHICH WAS ALREADY LOOKING AT
SOME OF THESE SAME PROCESSES-
SO IF THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCE NEEDS. WE WILL HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE PROCESS. TO OBTAIN.
I THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT
WOULD BE RIGHT THERE I MEAN
THAT SEEMS THAT'S QUICK MATTERS
THAT'S WELL OVER A HUNDRED-
LEGITIMATE COMPLAINTS THAT
MIGHT RESULT IN ADVERSE ACTION
PER MONTH- SO YOU'RE LOOKING
AT. A SUBSTANTIAL STAFF TIME TO
DO THAT- AND I'M ASSUMING YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT. ALREADY ON
HAND. YOU KNOW WE DO NOT SIR.
RIGHT BUT I'M NOT PREPARED TO
BE ABLE TO. GIVE A PRECISE
NUMBER WE DO HAVE THE TIME AND
MOTION STUDY GOING ON RIGHT NOW
SHE TO FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S
OTHER EFFICIENCIES WEEKEND-
WHAT'S ONE THING ABOUT KOBE-
WE'VE GOT TO PUT A POSITIVE
SPIN ON WE HAVE LEARNED THAT
THE USE OF TECHNOLOGY IS.
INSTRUMENTAL IN ASSISTING US
WITH VARIOUS- PROCESSES FOR
EXAMPLE INTERVIEW- THE SENATE
STAFF HAVING TO DRIVE THREE
FOUR HOURS TO AN INSTITUTION
SOME OF OUR VERY REMOTE
LOCATIONS. HELLO CHUCK A WALA
CAL PANTRY HANNAH KELLY CAN
BAY. WE CAN ACTUALLY NOW GET ON
THE SUIT. AND SO THAT REALLY
HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL. THE CARD
FINE WE'RE LOOKING FOR. AS WELL
AS EXPANDING- THAT THE VOLUME
OF WORKS MARK. IT SEEMS THAT
WE'VE MET ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE
WHO WILL WHO LIKES JIM TIME TO
MOLD A- PRECIADO AND MY OTHER
QUESTION IS. HOW WE FOR ABOUT.
I MADE TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THAT
THIS NUMBER IS CLEARLY LOW-
GIVEN SOME OF THE SYSTEMIC
ISSUES WE TALK ABOUT. HOW
SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT THAT THAT
THAT VERY HIGH RATIO. OF CASES
THAT DO RESULT IN ADVERSE
ACTION AGAINST STAFF. OKAY SO I
AND AGAIN I THINK WE'RE WE'RE
CONFLATING ISSUES SO LET'S FIND.
NO NO IT'S OKAY AIMS PROCESS IS
AN INITIAL ALLEGATIONS AND- HE
TOOK MY SHOES OFF SIR
CONFISCATED MY SHOES WELL IS
THAT STAFF MISCONDUCT OR IS. OR
IS IT THE INMATE HAD CONTRABAND
OR SOMETHING I MEAN THIS FRIDAY
OF I'M JUST STARTING OUT WITH A
DECENT EXAMPLE FOR YOU THERE'S
SO MANY- VERSES REALLY SERIOUS-
I MEAN ALL OR ALL OR SERIOUS TO
ME WE HAVE TO TREAT EVERYBODY
WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT I WANT
THIS DEPARTMENT TO GET. NOTHING
BACK I FEEL VERY VERY STRONGLY
ABOUT THAT TOO MUCH FOR IT IS
HOW I HAVE- CONDUCTED MYSELF MY
ENTIRE CAREER. BUT THE NUMBERS
THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT AS FAR
AS FORMAL ADVERSE ACTION THOSE
ARE FULL INVESTIGATIONS OR
DIRECT ACTIONS BASED ON. YOU
KNOW WE HOW HARD EVIDENCE-
VERSUS AN ALLEGATION OF OFFICER
JONES. YOU KNOW I TALKED TO ME
IN A DISPARAGING WAY IN THE
HOUSING UNITS THAT'S A LITTLE
BIT MORE BIG WE HAVE TO DO
INTERVIEWS. WE HAVE TO TRY AND
FIND WITNESSES IS THAT WITNESS
THAT MISCONDUCT VERSES. THERE'S
JUST SOMETHING THAT HAS YOU
KNOW HARD HARD EVIDENCE. SO HOW
AM I MOVE MY IT BUT HOW HOW WAS
IT SORT OF DAY LOGGED AND
TRACKED. THAT SHOW THAT I
PRESUME WE OVER TIME YOU HAVE A
YOU KNOW A BASS LINE AND YOU
COULD LOOK AT PROCESSOR
BEHAVIOR IMPROVEMENTS OVER TIME.
YES SO- OUR FORMAL
INVESTIGATION PROCESS DOES HAVE
A CENTRAL DATABASE. AND THAT'S
THAT'S BEEN WELL ESTABLISHED
FOR A LONG TIME OUR TEAMS
PROCESS JUST THE ALLEGATION
CHOIR REYES DID NOT HOW. LONG
SHOULD ALL DATABASE- AND SO
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING
TO GET THAT DEVELOPED- BUT THE
MORE FORMAL ACTIONS ALREADY
ALREADY HAVE THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ADVERSE ACTION I MEAN YOU CAN.
HAVE AS YOU KNOW FROM A LETTER
OF FORMAL REPRIMAND ALL THE WAY
TO DISMISSAL PERCENTAGE OF
TIME. I MEAN I'M SORRY
PERCENTAGE OF LOST WAGES YOU
LIKE 5% FOR TWELVE MONTHS OR
SUSPENSION DEPEND UPON THE
LEVEL OF MISCONDUCT SO IT YOU
KNOW DEFINITELY DEFINITELY VERY
I WILL SAY I FEEL VERY
CONFIDENT THAT OUR SYSTEM IS
VERY ROCKBASS. OFFSET INSPECTOR
GENERAL MIRS THAT PROCESS THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BRING- IF
THEY DISAGREE WITH THE LOCAL
HIRING AUTHORITY THEY CAN BRING
IT UP FOR EXECUTIVE REVIEW IF
IT GOES THROUGH THE ORCHARDS
DIRECT- THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR ALL
THE WAY UP TO THE SECRETARY- IF
NEED BE- IF THERE'S A
DISAGREEMENT BETWEEN THE AND-
THE HIRING AUTHORITY AND OFTEN
SPECTACLE WOULD BRING IT ALL
THE WAY UP. THAT EFFECT I THINK
I DID ONE EXECUTIVE RADIO MY
ENTIRE TIMES UNDERSECRETARY SO-
YOU KNOW IT'S A PROCESS THAT I
THINK WORKS. ARE AIMS PROCESSED
MEAT HAS A LOT OF WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. BUT WE DID
COME A LONG WAY WE HAVE. A LONG
WAY TO GO TO GET IT RIGHT. BUT
YOU KNOW IT'S AND I'D LIKE TO
PER MAYBE YOU KNOW- I DON TO
YOU TO HIGHLIGHTS WHAT I CHANGE
ARE IN SOME. AND THEIR KIND OF
X. BLAME THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE L. AND SIMPLE A RELATIVELY
SIMPLE ALLEGATION VERSUS
SOMETHING THAT IS MORE FORMAL
JOINT I CAN. THINK WOULD BE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND I
WOULD I WILL ALSO ASK IF
POSSIBLE IF YOU COULD INCLUDE
SOME OF THE THINKING YOU
MENTION ABOUT HOW TO CAPTURE
DATA- AND TO MR WESLEY'S POINT
HOW TO USE THAT DATA- FOR
QUALITATIVE PURPOSES OVER TIME.
SHOULD THANK YOU MEASURE THANK
YOU- I WAS GOING TO REFER TO.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL. COULD
YOU PLEASE MISTER WESLEY-
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE ISSUE I
THINK ESPECIALLY WITH THE
NUMBERS. HERE THAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE CASES. YEAH I
WANTED TO- KIND OF CLARIFY- THE
NUMBERS- S. SECRETARIAL SINCE
CORRECT THERE'S BEEN A
CONFLATION OF NUMBER. OF THE
TWO THOUSAND AND-
INVESTIGATIONS THAT SHE
REFERENCES. ARE ARE ALLEGATIONS
THAT CAME UP THROUGH THE STAFF
PROCESS SO SUPERVISORS AND
STAFF AT THE INSTITUTIONS-
FILED WITH THE WARDENS-
COMPLAINTS OF MISCONDUCT AND
THOSE WENT TO THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS. TO TO OPEN AS
IT AS MISCONDUCT INVESTIGATION
SO THOSE ALLEGATIONS OF
MISCONDUCT CAME UP THROUGH A
SEPARATE CHANNEL THEN THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT UNDER AIMS. UNDER AIMS
THE ALLEGATIONS COME UP THROUGH
THE END MAKE COMPLAINTS.
THROUGH COMPLAINTS MADE BY
INCARCERATED PERSONS SO- THE
TWO THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE THAT I TALKED ABOUT
ALL OF THOSE CAME FROM-
INCARCERATED PERSONS AND THERE
WAS A THERE WAS A VERY LOW
REFERRAL RATE OF THOSE CASES.
SO THERE APPEARS TO BE A
DIFFERENCE. BETWEEN WHETHER IT
GETS REFERRED BY STAFF OR
WHETHER IT GETS REFERRED BY- AN
INCARCERATED PERSON SO I THINK
THAT WAS THE DISCONNECT- THE-
THE ACTUAL- FINDINGS UNDER THE-
OF THE INTERNAL AFFAIRS PROCESS
THE GETS ELEVATED THROUGH
STAFF. IS ABOUT 54% OF THOSE
CASES- MISCONDUCT- THE
ALLEGATIONS ARE SUSTAINED- THEY
DON'T ALL RESULT IN ADVERSE
ACTION THEY RESULT IN A VARIETY
FROM TRAINING TO- TO
TERMINATION. BUT IT'S. PLAY
PROCESS. THERE ACTUALLY WAS NO
OF SUSTAINED FINDINGS OF THE-
THE WARDENS OUT OF THE TWO
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE COMPLAINTS THAT CAME UP
THROUGH THE INCARCERATED
PROCESS. REFERRED ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE OF THOSE
AND OF THOSE NONE RESULTED IN-
IN ANY DISCIPLINE OR OR- FORMAL
ACTION- SO I JUST WANTED TO
KIND OF CLARIFY- THE DIFFERENCE
IN AND WHAT WE WERE TALKING. I
GUESS I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT BUT IT'S PROBABLY STILL
ALSO TRUE THAT A FAIRLY LARGE
SHARE OF INMATE COMPLAINTS LEAD
OR ARE CREDIBLE- AND DESERVING
OF EXAMINATION LEAD TOWARD SOME
SORT OF ADVERSE ACTION. SHOW IT
AGAIN THAT'S WHY I THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT OVER TIME TO SEE
IF. YOU CAN USE THAT DATA TO
ASSESS WHETHER THINGS ARE
IMPROVING. I THINK IT'S A GREAT.
YES WE CERTAINLY. AGREE THAT
THE DATA SYSTEMS HAVE TO BE-
HAVE TO HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
RECORD WHAT IS HISTORICALLY
HAPPENING BECAUSE- QUITE
FRANKLY- UNDER THE STATE SYSTEM
THE ADVERSE ACTION IS REALLY.
THE WHOLE PROCESS IS- WITH THEM
WHICH I THOUGHT IN MIND THATYOU'RE GOING TO IMPROVE THE
EMPLOYEES DISTRICT ARE-
BEHAVIOR AND SO- IF SOMEBODY IS
DISRESPECTFUL TO AN INMATE- THE
FIRST TIME THAT MAY RESULT IN
NOTHING MORE THAN COUNSELING
BUT IF IT HAPPENS THE FIFTH
TIME THAT MAY RESULT IN- IN
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AND-
THERE'S NO STE DATA SYSTEM.
THAT CAN CAPTURE THAT RIGHT NOW.
RIGHT INTO BY INFERENCE SHOULD
SOMEBODY IS NOT IF THE
COMPLAINT IS AND DOESN'T WORK-
AND THAT SECOND THIRD FOURTH
FIFTH INCIDENT- IS NOT CAPTURED
YOU'LL GET NO IMPROVEMENT RIGHT
IN THE SUIT. THAT'S CORRECT
YEAH THE PROJECT THAT THEY
THANK YOU AFTER. SENATE
QUARTERS IN. THE TICKET MANAGER-
MISTER WESLEY APPRECIATE- ALL
OF YOUR EFFORTS ON THIS. BEEN
LISTENING TO YOUR PRESENTATION
INITIAL PRESENTATION. I
ACTUALLY FELT THAT IT WAS
RATHER TROUBLING ALL THE WAY
THROUGH AND THEN I WAS ALMOST
TAKEN ABACK WITH YOUR YOUR LAST
SENTENCE OR TWO WHICH WAS- I
WANT TO PARAPHRASE IT'LL BE
FACETIOUS BUT- WE'RE GONNA GET
TOGETHER- YOU IN THE SECRETARY
AN- INTERNAL WORKINGS OUT-
EARLIER THE SECRETARY OFFERED
THAT TO GIVE US A DOCUMENT THAT
WOULD EXPLAIN- SOME OF THE
PROCESS QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT UP BY THE COMMITTEE
PRIOR TO MY SPEAKING. MISTER
WESLEY AS A RESULT OF THESE
MEETINGS THAT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A THE SECRETARY WOULD BE
WILLING TO PROVIDE US WITH. A
CHART. ON THAT INDICATES. WHERE
YOU TO HAVE COME TO AGREEMENT.
A WERE YOU HAVEN'T COME TO
AGREEMENT. IN AND WHERE YOU
THINK ADDITIONAL ACTION IS
pOF THE DATE AS OF LAST WEEK WE
REALLY HAD NO DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT ON- ON OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND- THE
DEPARTMENT- THANKS FOR THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN. THAT
WAS REALLY THE END OF IT AND I
WAS- PROBABLY MORE THAN A YEAR
AGO I WAS A PRESENT FOR A
BRIEFING THE DEPARTMENT GAVE.
UP ON THEIR REGULATIONS PROCESS
WE RAISED SOME CNCERNS ABOUT
THAT AND ABOUT THE REGULATIONS
THAT WERE PROMULGATED. AND THEN
THE DEPARTMENT WENT FORWARD
WITH- WITH- APPROVING THOSE
RECORD RECOMMENDATION OR THOSE
REGULATIONS RATHER AT THAT- SO
ALTHOUGH. UNDER OUR PROCESS WE
CAN MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS WE
SIMPLY- AS AS AN OVERSIGHT
AGENCY THEN REPORT WHETHER THE
DEPARTMENT- TOOK OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE NOT AND I'M
AND PART OF THIS REPORT IS TO
TELL YOU THAT FOR THE MOST PART
THEY DID NOT. EIGHT EIGHT I GET
THAT AND I JUST I'M NOT USED TO
HAVING. IN A IN A REVIEW OR
AUDIT LIKE FUNCTION THE
SOMEBODY. TWENTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN GOVERNMENT. IS
UNDER LIKE THIS WITHOUT A
DOCUMENT THAT SHOWS COMING INTO
THIS STAGE WHERE THERE'S
AGREEMENT GOING FORWARD AND
WHEN WHERE THERE'S NOT I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE SAYING IN THE
PAST. THERE'S BEEN SOME
AGREEMENT- IT IN SUCH A PROCESS
ISSUE AND THERE'S TIME TO DO
THAT OR NOT CONCLUDED ANYTHING
HERE TODAY AND I JUST FEEL LIKE
A DOCUMENT LIKE THAT THAT COMES
TO US WOULD BE INVITING- IN
TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S- NO COMMITMENT GOING
FORWARD TO RESOLVE. THE
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES HERE. I'M
ONLY GOING TO REALLY ASK BUT
YOU KNOW WE'LL HAVE ONE MORE
FROM THE LINE OF QUESTIONING
THIS VERY SPECIFIC TO THE
INFORMATION YOU PROVIDED US.
BUT HONESTLY I THINK BASED ON
WHAT I'VE HEARD TODAY I COULD
PROBABLY ASK A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE QUESTIONS AND NOT BE DONE
BECAUSE- OF THAT SO. DISJOINTED
THIS FEELS RIGHT NOW
COLLECTIVELY AFFECT. THE MENIAL
IG'S REPORT I MEAN THE RESPONSE
TO THE REPORT IN BASICALLY-
BASICALLY THE SEER TEN GENTLE
BUT SERIOUS ISSUES THAT- THE
BASICALLY ARISE IN MY MIND AS I
AS I READ AND LISTEN TO REPORT-
THAT COULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCES IN TERMS OF-
LITIGATION. IN PORTABILITY THE
STATE'S TREASURY LET ME GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE WHERE I'M
THINKING THAT MIGHT BE THE CASE
YOU INDICATED MISTER WESLEY
THE- EXCLUSIONS TO THE AIMS
PROCESS INCLUDE- SEVERAL FRAMES
A THROUGH F. BUT OFFICE STAFF
MISCONDUCT IN CONNECTION WITH
THE AMERICAN DISABILITIES ACT.
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION
PROCESS. AND I KNOW YOU'RE
AWARE THAT- THERE'S BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT- TREND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN TERMS OF A PLAINTIFF
LITIGATION ASSERTING. A REFORM
IS NECESSARY BUT WITH THE ADA
AND IN JAILS AND PRISONS. BUT
DOWN BELOW. AND AGAIN I
UNDERSTAND THAT WAS EXCLUDED
FROM THE AIMS PROCESS DOWN
BELOW- YOU INDICATE- IN AMMAN
PAGE SIX OF MY REPORTED DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S THE SAME AS
YOUR- NUMBER THE PAGE NUMBERS
BUT IN MY REPORT HERE. DOWN
BELOW THAT LIST OF A THROUGH F.
IT SAYS. IT SAYS FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND SEVENTY THREE
GRIEVANCES WERE RETAINED AT THE
PRESENT LEVEL. IN CHARACTERIZED
AS ROUTINE GRIEVANCES- INDICATE
ON A WHOLESALE BASIS SAID EDA
IS RETAINED AS I UNDERSTAND IT
AS A AS A CATEGORY BUT YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY THAT THE O. I. G.
ESTIMATES AT FORTY TWO HUNDRED
OF THESE MAY HAVE BEEN MISS
CHARACTERIZED AS A ROUTINE
GRIEVANCE. WHEN THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN CHARACTERIZED AS A
STAFF OF MISCONDUCT GRIEVANCE.
SO WHAT ARE THE CONSEQUENCES IF.
SOME OF THOSE ARE ARE ADA.
ISSUES IN TERMS OF THE
LIABILITY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE HAVE TO HAVE YOU.
AN OPINION ON THAT OR AS
COUNCIL. BUT WAITED ON THE. SO
THE- THE FOCUS OF OUR REPORT
WAS WHETHER STAFF MISCONDUCT-
WAS INVOLVED IN THOSE
ACTIVITIES SO- WHERE YOU HAVE
FOR EXAMPLE A GRIEVANCE THAT
THE PERSON WASN'T PROPERLY
ACCOMMODATED. YOU CAN TAKE TWO
FORMS ONE THAT- I NEEDED A
WHEELCHAIR AND THEY JUST GAVE
ME A WALKER- NO ALLEGATION THAT
STAFF DID SOMETHING WRONG JUST
THAT THE PERSON IS NOT
SATISFIED WITH THE- WITH THE
RESOLUTION OF THEIR REQUEST-
THAT WOULD BE A ROUTINE
GRIEVANCE- IT WOULD ASK THE
DEPARTMENT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS AGAIN AND- AND- TELL THE
PERSON WHETHER THEY HAVE
CHANGED THEIR MIND ABOUT WHERE
THEY GET A WHEELCHAIR. CONTRAST
THAT WITH- SOMEBODY WHO SAYS
THAT- AN OFFICER TOOK THEIR
CAME AWAY FROM THEM FOR NO
REASON. AND THAT THEY WERE
ENTITLED TO HAVE THAT CAME. OF
THAT WOULD BE THEN AN
ALLEGATION OF STAFF MISCONDUCT.
AND UNDER THE DEPARTMENT'S
HANDLING OF THAT IT JUST STAYS
AS A ROUTINE GRIEVANCE UNDER
THE ADA PROCESS. WHAT WE ARE
SAYING IS THAT THOSE THE
QUALITY OF THAT ACT. OF SHOULD
QUALIFY IT FOR INCLUSION IN THE
GAMES MISCONDUCT. INQUIRY TO
FIND OUT WHETHER THIS OFFICER-
DID IT. INTENTIONALLY REMOVED A
REQUIRED ASSISTIVE DEVICE FROM
UP FROM A PERSON WHO NEEDED IT.
SO THAT'S THE I THINK THAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE- THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IN THOSE NUMBER OF
CASES WHERE. IN IN IN THE
REPRESENTATIVE SAMPLE WE LOOKED
AT WE SAW THINGS THAT- CLEARLY
IN OUR MIND. LOOK AT THE
BEHAVIOR OF THE OFFICE OFFICER
AS OPPOSED TO WHETHER THE
PERSON- WAS TREATED ACCORDING
TO. THEIR OWN INTERNAL
PROCESSES AND SIMPLY DIDN'T
LIKE THE END RESULT. YOUR
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THAT
EXPLANATION OF IN BOTH EXAMPLES
THAT YOU GAVE DO YOU HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT- THE DEPARTMENT
IS REACHING CLOSURE. IN EITHER
CASE. WELL MISCONDUCT OR NOT A
IS IT ARE YOU CONFIDENT BASED
ON WHAT YOU'VE SEEN THROUGH THE
SAME PROCESS THAT THOSE CLAIMS.
UNDER STAFF MISCONDUCT IN
CONNECTION WITH THE AMERICAN
DISABILITIES ACT- COOPER. ARE
BEING CLOSED OUT A REACHING
CLOSURE. BY THE SYSTEM. CON
MISCONDUCT OR NOT. WELL THEY'RE
BEING CLOSED OUT BY THE SYSTEM-
THE ISSUE IS WHETHER THEY ARE
UNDER THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITY ACT UP PROCESS WHICH
WE DON'T MONITOR AND WE HAVE NO
VISIBILITY ON OR WHETHER IT
GOES THROUGH A MISCONDUCT-
EVALUATION AT AN- UNDER WHICH
WE DO MONITOR. GREAT IN THE END
THE MONTH MY CONCERN IS THE
AUDIT TRAIL AROUND. AROUND
THOSE THAT THAT'S ONE OF MY
CONCERNS IT'S- HI THERE I'M
TRYING TO RAISE TODAY
SPECIFICALLY WITHOUT GETTING
INTO THE HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR
OTHER QUESTIONS IS HOW DO WE
HOW DO WE GET TO CLOSURE ON
THESE EIGHTY EIGHT CLAIMS ARE
WE- LEAVING AN AUDIT TRAIL-
ESPECIALLY IF THERE'S
UNRESOLVED EDA CLAIMS. THAT
COULD LEAD TO LITIGATION. IN A
NIGHT IF I DO HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION WHICH IS. MAYBE A
COMET RELATIVE TO THE
SECRETARY'S REQUEST FOR
CAMERAS. DOES IT MAKE SENSE. TO
PUT CAMERAS ON THE SITUATION-
NOT KNOWING WHETHER OR NOT
WE'RESUPER REACHING CLOSURE IN
ON THESE ISSUES. FROM A STATE
LIABILITY STILL POINT. WITH
REGARD TO THE ADA PROCESS THE
PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEYS ARE VERY
MUCH INVOLVED IN- IN THE
PRISONS WELL LOOKING AT THE
VERY THINGS THAT YOU'RE THAT
YOU'RE INDICATING SO I KNOW
THAT- THAT THESE ATTORNEYS GO
IN AND DO WHAT THEY CALL
ARMSTRONG TOURS AND THEY LOOK
AT WHATEVER DOCUMENTATION THE
DEPARTMENT HAS- THE DEPARTMENT
IS SUPPOSED TO HAVE A- A
PROCESS BY WHICH DAY- RECORD
ALL OF THESE. EIGHTY EIGHT
ALLEGATIONS AND- AND THEN THESE
ADVOCATES LOOK AT THOSE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PROPERLY
ADDRESSED THEM OR NOT AGAIN
THAT'S OUTSIDE THE PURVIEW OF
OUR- MONITORING- BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS THAT THAT
IS THE SOURCE OF A LOT OF THE-
LITIGATION THAT'S GOING ON WITH
THE WITH THE ADVOCATES THAT-
FROM WHAT I'VE READ IN IN THE
ARMSTRONG PLEADINGS. OF THOSE
ISSUES ARE ROUTINELY RAISED IN
THE ARMSTRONG REPORTS- SO OFTEN
BUT BUT TO ANSWER DIRECTLY YOUR
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION TO HAVE ANY
CONFIDENCE IN HOW THE PROCESS.
OF IN ARMSTRONG GENERALLY IS
ADDRESSING SOME OF THESE
ISSUES. WELL HOW IT WAS IS THIS
IS MY IS MY STAFF'S
INTERPRETATION OR IS THIS YOUR
STATEMENT OR RENDITION OF YOUR
STATEMENT THE FORTY TWO
HUNDRED. OF THE FORTY THOUSAND
SEVENTY THREE GRIEVANCES MAY
HAVE BEEN MISS CHARACTERIZED AS
A ROUTINE GRIEVANCE. ARE THOSE
YOUR NUMBERS YES YES THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE- THOSE ARE NUMBERS
BASED ON OUR REVIEW OF SOURCE
DOCUMENTS WHERE- THE GRIEVANCE-
CLEARLY SAID IN HIS- IN HIS
GRIEVANCE THAT OFFICER SO AND
SO WAS FOR EXAMPLE DISHONEST
WHEN HE DID WHAT I WHAT. WHAT
I'M ACCUSING HIM OF DOING- AND-
WITHOUT COMMENTING ON THE TRUTH
YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T GET TO THE
TRUTH UNTIL YOU UNTIL YOU
INVESTIGATE BUT- IN OUR MIND OF
THOSE THINGS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CATEGORIZED AS STAFF MISCONDUCT
CLAIMS BUT BECAUSE THEY DEALT
WITH ADA. OF WARDENS ROUTINELY
RE CATEGORIZE THOSE TO ROUTINE
APPEALS A ROUTINE GRIEVANCES
AND ASSIGN THEM THROUGH THE-
THE ADA PROCESS THROUGH AN ATA
WARD. INTO THAT IS THE REASON
THAT YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHETHER
OR NOT. THERE THERE'S A PROBLEM
THERE BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT. IN A
POSITION. TO SEE THOSE COME
THROUGH THE AIMS PROCESS EVEN
THOUGH YOU'RE SAYING THEY WERE
LIKELY MIS CHARACTERIZING
SHOULD COME THROUGH THE AIMS
PROCESS IS THAT CORRECT. THAT'S
CORRECT AND- IF IT GOES THROUGH
A CENTRALIZED AIMS PROCESS.
THEN I CAN HAVE PEOPLE THERE TO
MONITOR THAT PROCESS AND FERRET
OUT THOSE KINDS OF ISSUES- THE
WAY IT CURRENTLY- IS
STRUCTURED. OTHERS THIRTY FIVE
DIFFERENT PRISONS THERE'S
THIRTY FIVE DIFFERENT- ACTORS
IN THIS AND WE ARE NOT- WE'RE
NOT INVOLVED AT THE- LEVEL WHEN
AWARDING MAKES THAT DECISION
BECAUSE- WE- WE HAVE NO
RESOURCES TO GO TO THAT LEVEL.
AND REVIEW THOSE WE ARE LOOKING
AT WHAT COMES TO AIMS AND THEN
MAKING A DETERMINATION BASED ON
WHAT WE SEE THERE. I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I'M NOT TRYING TO
IMPUTE OR ASSIGNED TO YOU THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF GOING DEEPER
INTO THE ADA PROCESS I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT ANY PERCENTAGE
OF FORTY TWO HUNDRED- MIS
CHARACTERIZATIONS. IN TERMS OF
ROUTINE GRIEVANCES THAT MAY
HAVE BEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. YOU
KNOW MY SCENARIO YOU GIVE A
COUPLE EXAMPLES WOULD BE A AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS COMPLAINING
THAT HE OR SHE HASN'T RECEIVED
THEIR MATS WILL ASK FOR THEM
WAS NOT RECEIVED WAS DENIED.
AND SUBSEQUENT PLAINTIFF'S
COUNSEL COMES THROUGH AND SAYS.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT- WE SHOULD
BE TRYING TO I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU AGREE WITH THAT MY OPINION
IS WE SHOULD BE TRYING TO.
CORRECT THAT IN THE IND OF
BEHAVIOR IN ADVANCE THROUGH
TRAINING- OR DISAPPOINT BUT
JUST DISAPPOINT. SO THAT THAT'S
THE POINT I'M TRYING TO GET OUT
HERE AND THE CONCERN THAT I
HAVE- FIT YOU MAY OR MAY NOT
AGREE WITH ENOUGH I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH YOU- UNFORTUNATELY
THAT CAN'T HAPPEN UNTIL THE
GRIEVANCE GETS ASSIGNED TO THE
PROPER CATEGORY- BECAUSE IF IT
REMAINS AS A ROUTINE GRIEVANCE.
THEN THERE WILL BE NO EMPHASIS
ON THE BEHAVIOR STAFF. REALLY
THANK YOU IS- JUST- JUST WANT
TO ASK- YOU KNOW THROUGH THE
CHAIR IF THERE WAS ANYONE NOT
THE- A GPS SOMETHING IS A
RESPONSIBILITY YOU CAN SPEAK TO
WHETHER OR NOT AN ISSUE LIKE
THAT- WHICH MIGHT. SUGGEST
HAVING HAVING LEGAL COUNSEL
LOOK AT IT IN TERMS OF
POTENTIAL LIABILITY FOR THE
STATE. TO CONTRIVE YOUR A
CONFIDENTIAL OF OPINION
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE
OPINION ON HOW MUCH EXPOSURE
THERE MAY BE IF THIS MIS
CHARACTERIZATION CONTINUE
NUMBER BY THE- I. G. IS
ANYWHERE NEAR CORRECT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE REFERRAL PROCESS
IS BEING NEW AROUND HERE TO TRY
TO GET- THE- COUNCIL TO. OPINE
ON THAT IS THAT IS THAT. A
SEPARATE REFERRAL THROUGH LEDGE
COUNCIL. WE COULD. OKAY SHE
DIED OF AIDS THE STAFF. AND
THAT'S THAT WE CAN THAT'S
RIGHT- DIVE INTO THAT'LL BIT
MORE IN THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO FOCUS ON A PARTICULAR
AREA THANKS VERY GOOD I DO
WANNA- BRING UP IN TERMS OF THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE I
THINK WITH SOMETHING ON ISSUE
THAT CENTER NEWMAN. RAISED IS-
WHEN AIMS WAS ESTABLISHED IT
WAS IN TWENTY NINETEEN- THEY
WERE FORTY SEVEN POSITIONS. OF
THAT CAME WITH IT AND IT WAS
WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT WAS
BASED ON. SOMETHING IF I HAVE
THIS RIGHT SOMETHING LIKE FOUR
HUNDRED OF COMPLAINTS. OF PER
MONTH- IT'S NOT THE- ANYWHERE
NEAR THAT SO I THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK IN TERMS OF RESOURCES. IS
IT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES OR IS
IT HOW THE CURRENT RESOURCES
ARE ARE BEING USED OR NOT USED
AND I THINK THAT WAS. THERE WAS
REFERENCE TO THAT BY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AS TO THE-
WHAT WHAT WHAT THE AVERAGE COST
OF THE CASE. WAS OF HIM BECAUSE
OF THE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES AND
STAFF TIME THAT WAS. AVAILABLE
I DON'T KNOW IF I GOT THAT
RIGHT MISTER WESLEY. THE YES
MADAM CHAIR THE- OF WHAT WE
FOUND WAS THAT- AIMS IN A IN
THE B. C. P. THAT WAS PRESENTED
AND I KNOW THE DEPARTMENT- MAY
HAVE SOME ISSUES WITH THE WORK-
WITH THE AMOUNT OF WORK- THAT
THEY CAN DO NOW- BUT THEY
PROMISED FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR- INCREASE PER MONTH- BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
THEY HAVE THEY'RE DOING ONE OR
TWO A MONTH- THERE IF THEY ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY- BELOW. WHAT THEY
PROMISED THEY WOULD DO I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE RIGHT NUMBER IS
AND- SECRETARY ALLISON HAS
INDICATED THEY'RE DOING- A WORK
STUDY TO SEE. WHAT THAT RIGHT
NUMBER IS- BUT- MY IMPRESSION
IS THAT. AT THE MOMENT THEY
COULD PROBABLY DO MORE AND
THEY'RE NOT DOING IT AND SO.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT THEY
COULD DO FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR A MONTH MAYBE THEY COULD-
BUT THEY'RE SIMPLY NOT WORKING
TO- TO THE- TO THE ABILITY THAT
I THINK THEY COULD. EVEN IF
IT'S LESS THAN THE FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR MONTH- SO THAT WAS
THAT WAS FAR OUR POINT. YEAH.
OKAY- THE- SORRY WE GOT WE GOT
INTO THIS OF WHAT THE ALEJO'S
OFFICE. RESPOND. CAITLIN
O'NEILL WITH THAT ARE YOU KNOW
SORRY YOU OUT OF ALL THIS.
CONVERSATION SHOULD RECALL THEN
YOU SOONER- THAT'S FINE. AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF ANALYZING THAT
PROPOSAL RELATED TO THIS ITEM
WHICH I KNOW IS ACTUALLY NEXT
UP ON THE AGENDA- IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE- AG'S RECENT
REPORT AS WELL AS THE NEW
INFORMATION THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS- PRESENTED TODAY AS FAR AS
CHANGES IT'S MAKING TO THE- TO
THE AIMS PROGRAM. SO TO THE
EXTENT WE DO HAVE AN ANALYSIS
SHARING RECOMMENDATIONS WHILST
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY COMMUNICATE
THAT TO STAFF- BUT I JUST
DIDN'T WANT TO PROVIDE A FEW
PIECES OF ADDITIONAL BACKGROUND
INFORMATION- AT THIS TIME THREE
PIECES SPECIFICALLY TO KIND OF
EXPAND ON. WHAT YOU HEARD AND
GENERALLY PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL ON HIS TRAIN CONTEXT
FOR THAT COMMITTEE. FIRST
REPORTS OF SERIOUS OFFICER
MISCONDUCT ARE NOT NEW AND HAVE
BEEN REPORTED AT SEVERAL
PRISONS BY MULTIPLE REPUTABLE
SOURCES. INCLUDING THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. EXPERTS AND
EVEN EASIER ON STAFF. FOR
EXAMPLE AFTER VISITING THE
RICHARD J. DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WHICH IS A FACILITY WHERE
THERE'S BEEN. A NUMEROUS VERY
STATIC CONCERNING ALLEGATION
MADE ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF- MISS
CONTACT CONTACT SPECIFICALLY AS
IT RELATES TO DISABLED INMATES.
CDC OURS I SENT A STRONG TEAM
TO THAT PRISON- TO INTERVIEW
INMATES. SURROUNDING THOSE OUT
AND CC CHIEF ON BUT OMBUDSMEN
WHO WROTE- TWO LEADING
LEADERSHIP FOLLOWING A VISIT
EXPRESSED GRAVE CONCERN ABOUT
WHAT SHE OBSERVED THERE ARE
HEARD THERE URGED IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE AND NOTED THAT THE
ALLEGATIONS WERE THE WORST
SHE'S HEARD IN HER CAREER. AND
THE SECOND POINT IS THAT
CONCERNS ABOUT C. SHARES
ABILITY TO HANDLE STAFF
MISCONDUCT ARE ALSO NOT NEW AND
HAVE ALSO BEEN RAISED BY
MULTIPLE REPUTABLE SOURCES IN
ADDITION TO THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL- FOR EXAMPLE. IN THE
REPORT BY THAT STRIKE TEAM IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN- THE REPORT
SAID QUOTE D. IN MADE
ALLEGATIONS TAKEN AS A WHOLE
SEEM TO DISCRIMINATE BERMAN
WITH NO RELIEF MECHANISM FOR
AND MADE TO FEEL MISTREATED BY
CUSTODY STAFF. MOREOVER ON A AN
EXPERT WITNESS IN THE ARMSTRONG
VERSUS NATION CASE- WHICH I'LL
TALK ABOUT IN A MOMENT- WHO HAD
REVIEWED THE USE OF FORCE TO
DISCIPLINE SYSTEMS IN JAILS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY STATED IN A
COURT DECLARATION THAT CDCR
SYSTEM IS. THE WORST HE'S SEEN
IN HIS CAREER. AND TO KIND OF
COMPOUND UPON CONCERNS AROUND
CAESARS ABILITY TO HANDLE IN
MALAGA DACIANS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT I WOULD JUST NOTE-
AS MISTER WESLEY ALLUDED TO
THAT- LEGISLATORS RAISE
CONCERNS OVER- CDCR
REGULATIONS- BY. THE DEPARTMENT
PROMULGATED REGULATIONS FOR THE
NEW AIMS PROCESS DESPITE THOSE
CONCERNS- AND- AND DESPITE
GIVING LEGISLATORS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE
REGULATIONS IN ADVANCE- THIRD
THE STATE IS- INVOLVED IN
ONGOING LITIGATION ON THESE
ISSUES SPECIFICALLY- IN
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY
PLAINTIFFS IN AN ONGOING CLASS
ACTION LAWSUIT. KNOWN AS
ARMSTRONG THE NEW SIM. WHICH
HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR QUITE A
NUMBER OF YEARS CONCERNING THE
DEPARTMENT'S TREATMENT OF
INMATES WITH DISABILITIES FILED
A MOTION ALLEGING THAT OFFICERS
AT RICHARD J. DONOVAN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY IN SAN
DIEGO WERE ASSAULTING ABUSING
AND RETALIATING AGAINST INMATES
WITH DISABILITIES DISABILITIES.
ARE THE PLAINTIFFS ALSO ARGUE
THAT THE PRISON SYSTEM FOR
RESPONDING TO THESE ALLEGATIONS
IS AN ADEQUATE. AND IN
SEPTEMBER THE COURT HEY IN THAT
CASE ORDERED CDCR TO DEVELOP- A
PLAN TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS
RJD AND REQUIRE THAT THE PLAN
INCLUDES CERTAIN ELEMENTS SUCH
AS BODY WORN CAMERAS WE'RE
GOING TO BE HEARING. ABOUT PLAN
IS THE IMPETUS FOR THAT BUDGET
PROPOSAL WILL HEREBY NINE TO-
AND THEN FINALLY IN JUNE
PLAINTIFFS IN THAT CASE FILED A
MOTION ALLEGING THAT THE
MISCONDUCT AND INADEQUATE
SYSTEMS FOR HANDLING IT- WIDE
SYSTEMIC AND REQUESTING
STATEWIDE RELIEF HOWEVER THE
COURT IS STILL CONSIDERING-
CONSIDERING THAT MOTION. THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL.
BINANCE THANK YOU. MISTER YOU.
THE ONLY THING SHE WOULD
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME OKAY. OKAY I DON'T KNOW
IF- SECRETARY IF YOU WANNA OF
FINAL WORD ON THIS BUT- IT
APPEARS FROM EVERY DIRECTION
ALL OF THESE ARE EXTREMELY
SERIOUS ISSUES. I UNDERSTAND
YOU KNOW AND SHARE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF. OF ALL
WHAT'S BEING- THE INFORMATION
THAT'S BEING GIVEN TO US BY
THE- INSPECTOR GENERAL- IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT. RATHER THAN
IT GETTING MORE SERIOUS TO THE
POINT OF MORE LITIGATION MORE
LIABILITY THAT'S ONE WAY OF
LOOKING AT IT'S ALSO LOOKING
THAT THE WELL BEING OF BOTH THE
OFFICERS AND THE INMATES- THERE
HAS TO BE SOMETHING. MUCH MORE
DRAMATICALLY DONE AND CHANGED
HERE TO ADDRESS ALL OF THESE
ISSUES THERE'S A LOT OF
SPECIFICS HERE THAT WE COULD BE
ASKING BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THERE'S GOTTA BE OF FUNDAMENTAL
CHANGE AND I DO AGREE THAT
THERE IS ENOUGH INFORMATION.
ABOUT THE HISTORY OF THE MOST
RECENT AND NOT JUST SOMETHING
WAY IN THE PAST BUT MOST
RECENT. THAT OF DOESN'T LEAD IN
ANY OTHER DIRECTION EXCEPT TO
SOME FUNDAMENTAL SYSTEMIC
CHANGE SO I REALLY- EXPECT THAT
THAT'S WHAT YOUR RESPONSE WILL
INCLUDE THAT THERE WILL BE SOME
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES. BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE OURSELVES
COMING BACK WITH MORE AND MORE.
OF ORDERS FROM THE COURTS AND
WE SEEM TO. OF LET THINGS MOVE
IN THAT DIRECTION AND THEN THE
COURTS HAVE TO INTERVENE THE
LAWSUITS AND WE FIND OURSELVES
UNDER COURT ORDERS TO DO THINK
SO. WHY DO WE HAVE TO END UP IN
THAT IN THAT SITUATION BRUCE'S
MAKING THE CHANGE OURSELVES-
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE TO
MAKE A CHANGE OR SELF CARRYING
IT OUT. OF CHANGES IN TRAINING
CHANGES AND HOW WE HANDLE THESE
ISSUES. EVERYTHING THAT'S
INVOLVED IN IT AND IF WE'RE
GONNA DO A PIECEMEAL HERE AND
THERE WE'RE GOING TO FIND
OURSELVES UNDER MORE COURT
ORDERS. AND THAT'S CERTAINLY
NOT THE ONLY REASON THAT SHOULD
CONCERN US BUT IT'S A BIG
REASON THAT SHOULD CONCERN US.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT TO OUR
STATE AND IT'S COSTLIER. AND
THE LIVES OF SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
IMPACTED BY THIS SO. OF IF YOU
WANT YOU COULD- HAVE A- FINAL
WORD HERE. SECRETARY OR WE
COULD MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ISSUE.
THANK YOUMA'AM I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY- I DO
FEEL TRAINING IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT I FEEL CAMERAS ARE
CRITICAL COMPONENTS. OF FOR A
STATE AND AS WELL AS OUR
REQUIRES AN INVESTIGATION
PROCESS IN ORDER FOR US TO BE A
DEPARTMENT OF INTEGRITY THEY
ALL GO HAND IN HAND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO. THE SUPPORT FOR ON
OUR CURRENT REQUESTED ANY
FUTURE REQUESTS. AS RELATES TO
THOSE ISSUES SO THAT WE CAN
ALLEVIATE ON. ANY KIND OF
MISCONDUCT WHETHER REAL OR
PERCEIVED AND SO I DO THINK
THAT THERE IS EVIDENCE AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE
EVIDENCE. OF OUR CAMERAS TO
RESOLVE MANY OF THESE ISSUES-
WE DO HAVE EVIDENCE PRE AND
POST- CAMERA IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE FEW INSTITUTIONS THAT WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED- LOOK FORWARD
TO THE SAME AND- R. J. DONOVAN.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY JUST KNOW THAT I
AS THE SECRETARY OF THIS
ORGANIZATION I AM COMMITTED. TO
MAKING THE NECESSARY CHANGES-
FOR THE BETTERMENT OF OUR
INCARCERATED POPULATION AS WELL
AS OUR STAFF. THANK YOU I'LL WE
MOVE ON NOW SENATORS. YEAH OKAY
WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE TO
THE ARMSTRONG COURT COMPLIANCE-
FROM THE CDC ARE MISTER SWANSON
OR SOMEONE ELSE GOING TO.
PRESENT YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
SURE ENATORS ON THEIR SWANSON
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
OF FISCAL SERVICES FOR CDCR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS REALLY
REHABILITATION REQUEST THIRTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND TWENTY TWO POINT EIGHT
POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DIFFERENT AMOUNTS IN FUTURE
YEARS AS SHOWN ON YOUR AGENDA.
IN ORDER TO COMPLY WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR BY THE UNITED
STATES DISTRICT COURT IN
ARMSTRONG VERSUS NEW SEVEN
THERE ARE FOUR COMPONENTS TO
THIS REQUEST WE ARE EXPERT
POSING TO EXPAND OUR CCAR'S
AUDIO VISUAL SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEM WHICH IS- BASICALLY
STANDING CAMERAS ACROSS THE
PRISON IT RICHARD J. DONOVAN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY AND
SPECIFIED YARDS CAL STATE
PRISON L. A. R. LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. THIS FOLLOWS SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION AT A NMBER OF
FACILITIES AS OUTLINED BY OUR
SECRETARY THE LAST ISSUE- THIS
PART OF THIS YEAR'S. NEW THIS
PROPOSAL ON MY CAR- EXISTING
STANDING CAMERAS AND OTHER. THE
SAUDIS WILL INCLUDE BODY WORN
CAMERAS FOR EACH CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER AND SERGEANT IDENTIFIED
RGD IS HAVING REGULAR
INTERACTION WITH INMATE
ARMSTRONG CLASS MEMBERS. AND
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THESE FIRST
TWO ITEMS JUST A FEW MINUTES.
OUR THIRD COMPONENT IS A
SUPERVISORY COMPONENTS
CONSISTING OF NINE CORRECTIONAL
SERGEANTS AND ONE CORRECTIONAL
JANET RGD THE STAFF WILL ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH NEWLY
ESTABLISHED GUIDELINES POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES. AND FINALLY
WE'RE PROPOSING TO EXPAND THE
ALLEGATION IN CORRIE MANAGED IN
SECTION WHICHHAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IN THE FIRST ISSUE. IN
ORDER TO REFORM THE STAFF
COMPLETE PROCESS OF RJD. THIS
POINT I'D LIKE TO REACH TO-
INTRODUCE ANY MILLER WHO'S
GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE RGD STAFF COMPLETE PROCESS.
AND AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS AMY MILLER AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
CORRECTIONAL POLICY RESEARCH
AND INTERNAL OVERSIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. YOUR STRONG
CORE COMPLIANCE REQUEST
INCLUDES RESOURCES OR A STAFF
COMPLAINTS SCREENING UNIT AND
EXPANSION FOR THE ALLEGATION
ENQUIRY MANAGEMENT SECTION
SPECIFIC FOR RICHARD J. DONOVAN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY. SIX
POINT EIGHT POSITIONS REQUESTED
AND CURRENT YEAR AND A TOTAL OF
TEN PERMANENT RESOURCES AND
BUDGET YEAR. THIS REQUEST WILL
ENSURE ALL ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
STAFF RECEIVED BY RJD CAN BE
SCREENED BY AN EXTERNAL STAFF
ALLEGATIONS SCREENING ANALYST
TO DETERMINE WHERE THE INQUIRY
OR INVESTIGATION SHALL BE
CONDUCTED ACCORDING TO POLICY.
AND WILL EXPAND THE CATEGORIES
IN WHICH IN AMES AND COREY IS
COMPLETE AND BEYOND WHAT WAS
ORIGINALLY PLANNED IN THE
ALLEGATION INGRAIN MANAGEMENT
UNIT 200-019-2000 TWENTY BUDGET
REQUEST SPECIFIC- TO RJD. IS
ADDITIONAL CATEGORIES WILL
INCLUDE ALL ALLEGATIONS
UNNECESSARY EXCESSIVE AND
UNREPORTED USE. OF FORCE
REGARDLESS OF INJURY. ALL
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT TOWARDS INMATES. ALL
ALLEGATIONS OF DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST PROTECTED CLASS MEMBERS
AND FINALLY ALL ALLEGATIONS OF
RETALIATION FOR USING THE
GRIEVANCE AND APPEALS PROCESS
TO SUBMIT AN ALLEGATION AGAINST
STAFF. THIS REQUEST MEETS THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE SEPTEMBER
EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND OUR TWENTY
TWENTY ARMSTRONG COURT ORDER
REQUIRING C. C. R. TO REFORM
THE STAFF COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATION AND DISCIPLINE
PROCESS ASKED RICHARD J.
DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL FACILITY.
AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT CDC ARE
COMPLETE UNBIASED COMPREHENSIVE
INVESTIGATIONS AND ALLEGATIONS
OF STAFF MISCONDUCT VIOLATIONS
OF THE RIGHTS OF ANY CLASS
MEMBER. AND INCLUDES ADAPTIVE
MECHANISMS FOR OVERSIGHT
OVERSTAFFED COMPLAINTS USE OF
FORCE REVIEWS AND RELATED STAFF
DISCIPLINARY PROCEEDINGS AT RJD
THAT INVOLVE ALLEGED VIOLATIONS
OF CLASS MEMBERS RIGHTS UNDER
ARMSTRONG REMEDIAL PLAN OR THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITY ACT.
I WOULD LIKE TO NOW INTRODUCE
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE DIVISION
OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR MARION SPEARMINT WHO'S
HERE TO PROVIDE YOU WITH AN
OVERVIEW OF THE CAMERA CLASS
INCLUDED IN THIS. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND-
SENATORS MY NAME IS MERRY
INSTRUMENT ON THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF WORK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION I'M
GONNA GO OVER A COUPLE THINGS
THE FIRST THING IS IN SEPTEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY UNITED STATES
DISTRICT COURT ORDERED CDCR IN
ARMSTRONG LITIGATION INSTALL
SURVEILLANCE CAMERAS IN AREAS
OF THE RICHARD J. DONOVAN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY. OR
INCARCERATE HAVE ACCESS. AND IT
WAS AREAS OF OUR RECREATION
YARDS HOUSING UNITS FINDING
HOLES PROGRAM AREAS GYMNASIUM'S
THAT'D BE DONE WITHIN NINETY
DAYS. THE CORK IN THAT ORDER
ALSO ORDERED US TO BEGIN USING
BODY WORN CAMERAS FOR ALL
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS AT
RICHARD J. DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY BUT HE- MAY HAVE
INTERACTION WITH PROTECTED
CLASS MEMBERS OF THE ARMSTRONG
LITIGATION IN SIXTY DAYS. THREE
ZERO ALSO ORDER IN THAT TO
RETAIN ALL FOOTAGE FOR MAX
MINIMUM OF NINETY DAYS AND THE
FOOTAGE OF USE OF FORCE AND
OTHER TRIGGERING EVENTS
INVOLVING ARMSTRONG REMEDIAL
PLAN CLASS MEMBERS AT THE
RICHARD J. DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY WOULD BE RETAINED
INDEFINITELY. AND THAT FOOTAGE
WHEN AVAILABLE BE REVIEWED AND
CONSIDERED AS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION. OF ANY INCIDENT
OUR DEPARTMENT ALSO WAS VERY
PROACTIVE. WE GOT THE ORDER AND
SO WE A LIKE TO REQUIRE
CORRECTIONAL SERGEANTS AT
RICHARD J. DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY WHERE BODY WORN
CAMERAS TO WEAR BODY WORN
CAMERAS AS A HAVE MAY HAVE
INTERACTION WITH PROTECTED
CLASS MEMBERS OF THE ARMED FROM
REMEDIAL. PLANS THERE. SO IN
JANUARY NINETEENTH WE WERE ABLE
TO PULL IT OFF OF THIS YEAR THE
USE OF BODY WORN CAMERAS WAS
IMPLEMENTED AT RJD THROUGH AN
INSTRUCTION MEMORANDUM. ISSUED
BY DIRECTOR GIPSON. AND PRIOR
TO THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE ALL
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS SERGEANTS
AND LIEUTENANTS WERE PROVIDED
IN SERVICE TRAINING ON BODY
WORN CAMERA POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES. THE PRIMARY
OBJECTIVE OF BODY WORN CAMERA
TECHNOLOGIES TO GIVE. OUR
DEPARTMENT THE ABILITY TO
CONDUCT AFTER THE FACT REVIEWS
OF STAFF USE OF FORCE
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. IN INVESTIGATIONS
AND HELP IDENTIFY NEW AREAS IN
THE ACTIVITY. ALL CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS SERGEANTS HAVING
INTERACTION AND IN THE COURSE
OF THEIR DUTIES WITH THAT
POPULATION OR HAVE THAT HAVE A
BUY ONE CAMERA ISSUE THAT THE
POSITION THAT THEY ARE WORKING
BACK GATE. AND THE BODY WORN
CAMERAS TO BE TURNED ON DURING
THE ENTIRE COURSE OF THEIR
SHIFT. A BREAKDOWN OF THE AUDIO
VIDEO SURVEILLANCE FIXED
CAMERAS AND BIOWARE CAMERAS IS
AS GOES WE'RE A STALLING
APPROXIMATELY NINE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIXED SURVEILLANCE
CAMERAS- THE MINIMUM SUPPORT
FACILITY REMAINER AREAS OF
INMATES. AFTER TRAVEL AND
CONGREGATION RJD AND WE'RE ALSO
IMPLEMENTING. OXALATE SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE BODY WORN
CAMERAS AT RJD. IN ADDITION TO
THAT THIS REQUEST AS MISTRUST
OUR SECRETARY SAID AND NOT.
JUST ONCE INSTEAD IT INVOLVES-
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND WE'RE
LOOKING TO INSTALL POSSIBLY TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE FIX
CAMERAS AT OUR FACILITIES B.
AND B. AT THAT INSTITUTION. BUT
AS WITH MANY EARLIER UP. AUDIO
VIDEO SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS IS
NOT REALLY NEW TO OUR
DEPARTMENT THEY'VE BEEN AROUND
FOR QUITE AWHILE HOWEVER WE
BEGUN PROCESS OF INSTALLING
THESE CAMERAS- THE NEW HIGHER
DEFINITION IN. AT HIGH DESERT
STATE PRISON ACT THAT THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
FACILITY AT CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISON SAN QUENTIN AND A
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
SACRAMENTO. AND THE BENEFITS OF
A STOLEN THESE FIXED CAMERAS
THAT ARE UP HìNH IN THE
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS IS TO
IDENTIFY SUSPECTS IN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS. SOMETIMES
THINGS ARE LOST OR MISPLACED OR
EVEN STOLEN. AND WE CAN USE
THOSE CAMERAS TO HELP US IN
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS AND BY
DOING THAT THOSE CAMERAS AT
EIGHT IT DOES WARN THAT THOSE
PRISONS- CHIU AND I HAVE A
LENGTHY SEARCHES LOCKDOWNS
WHICH AFFECT OFFENDER
PROGRAMMING BECAUSE THE CAMERA
WAS ABLE TO SHOW US EXACTLY
WHAT WAS MISPLACED LOST OR
SOMETHING WAS TAKEN OFF
BROWN'S. AT WE HAD CAMERAS WE
DO HAVE CAMERAS AT OUR FRONT
GATE ISSUES RIGHT OUT THE GATE.
THEY ALSO SAYS WHEN EIGHT-
NONEMPTY. INTRODUCES CONTRABAND
ON PRISON GROUNDS. WE HAVE OUR
MINIMUM SUPPORT FACILITIES
WHICH ARE OUTSIDE OUR SECURE
PERIMETER SO MANY TIMES PEOPLE
DRIVE CLOSE ON THE HOURS ALSO
THAT JACKSON TO THE PROPERTY
LINE NOT ON PRISON GROUNDS AND
THEY'LL THROW CONTRABAND OVER A
FENCE THE PROPERTY LINE FENCE
AND THEN IF WE'RE NOT CAREFUL A
MINIMUM SUPPORT FACILITY IN
MAKING GO OUT AND GRAB THAT SO
THOSE FIXED CAMERAS. HELP WITH
THAT ALSO. AND THEY ALSO HELP
DETER THE INTRODUCTION OF
CONTRABAND INTO A PRISON. AND
IDENTIFY EMPLOYEES YES I SAID
EMPLOYEES. VOLUNTEERS
CONTRACTORS ATTORNEYS VISITORS
AND INMATES DISCOVERY
INTRODUCING CONTRABAND INTO THE
PRISON THEY'RE VERY VERY
HELPFUL. AND A PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DATA TO REVIEW IN
CONJUNCTION WITH ALLEGATIONS
MADE. AGAINST STATE STAFF OR
OTHER INMATES. AND IT ALSO
FACILITATES OUR DEPARTMENT
DEBILITY TO IDENTIFY VICTIMS OF
VIOLENCE. AND TO IDENTIFY
PERPETRATORS OF VIOLENCE WITHIN
OUR PRISONS. BODY WORN CAMERAS
NOW NEW TECHNOLOGY AND
DETENTION CENTERS THE TENSION
LOCATIONS AROUND THE COUNTRY
AND IT'S NOT WIDELY USED BY
VERY MANY CORRECTIONAL AGENCIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. THE RJD
IMPLEMENTATION WILL GIVE UP OUR
DEPARTMENT OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS. AND IN A
CORRECTIONAL SETTING AND SEE IF
THEY REALLY DO WORK. EVEN
NOBODY OR CAMERAS ARE NEW TO
CDCR. AND CORRECTIONAL SETTING
IN GENERAL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WE READILY ACKNOWLEDGE OF BODY
WORN CAMERAS PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY AND RESOLVING
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF FORCE AND
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT. THEY ALSO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DATA TO
REVIEW IN CONJUNCTION WITH
INVESTIGATIONS OF AN INCIDENT.
AND LASTLY IF A STAFF MEMBER
STAFF WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
IF BAY INTENSELY DEACTIVATE
THEIR CAMERAS AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WHEN A PERSON COMES ON
SHIFT THEIR CAMERAS TO BE
ACTIVATED AND TURNING ON INTO
THE END OF THEIR SHIFT. SO IF
SOMEONE WAS A DE ACTIVATE THEIR
CAMERA. INTENSELY DURING AN
INCIDENT AND THAT WOULD BE
REFERRED TO THE HIRING
AUTHORITY THE WARDEN- IN THAT
WOULD PROBABLY BE REFERRED TO
THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
AND- DISCIPLINARY ACTION BE
TAKEN ON THAT IT COULD BE AT
CORRECTIVE ACTION OR GET COULD
WIND UP BEING ADVERSE PERSONNEL
ACTIONS OUR SECOND TRIP
MENTION. IT COULD BE A LETTER
OF REPRIMAND A LOSS OF PAY A
DEMOTION OR DISMISSAL FROM THE
DEPARTMENT DEPENDING ON THE
SEVERITY OF THE CASE. ALSO ON A
LIGHTER NOTE IF SOMEONE WAS TO
BECAUSE THERE ARE TIMES WHEN I
CAMERA CAN BE DEACTIVATED AND
ONE EXAMPLE IS SOMEONE GOES AND
USE THE BATHROOM. SO THEY TURN
OUR CAMERA IF A PERSON WAS COME
OUT THE BATHROOM AND ANY
INCIDENTS TAKING PLACE YOU KNOW
WITHIN. CAN A FIFTEEN YARD IN
IN IN A PROGRAM OFFICE OR IN A
BUILDING AND THEY- REACT TO
STOP THE INCIDENT ANDTHEY
DON'T TRIGGER CAMARON. THEN ON
A SITUATION LIKE THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE SOMEONE TRAINING AND
REMIND THEM YOU KNOW KINDA KEEP
YOURS STAY FOCUSED REMEMBER TO
TURN YOUR CAMARON. YOU KNOW
EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE RESPONDING
TO AN INCIDENT JUST AS YOU EXIT
THE BATHROOM. SO THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE A BINARY CAMERAS I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THIS INFORMATION TO
YOU. AND I'M AVAILABLE IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEARMAN- I
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS- I THINK
YOU ALREADY ANSWERED THIS- OF
THE BODY WORN CAMERAS EXIST AT
OTHER PRISONS THEY DO IT EXIST
AT OTHER PRISONS- BUT THERE
THERE WILL BE NEW. IN OUR
PRISONS IN CALIFORNIA. THAT IS
CORRECT MA'AM SURE THEY EXIST
IN PRISON SO I KNOW THE GEORGIA
DEPARTMENT CORRECTIONS HASBEEN
THEIR BUSINESS BUT- RJD WILL BE
THE ONLY PRESENT IN OUR SYSTEM
HAS SOME RIGHT NOW. OKAY AND
YOUR PLANS DO YOU HAVE PLANS TO
EXPAND INTO OTHER. AT THIS TIME
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
OUR SECRETARY IN ADMINISTRATION
TO MAKE A DECISION ON INSIDE I
MANAGING ONCE WE LOOK AT THE
EFFECTIVENESS THESE CAMERAS
THEY'LL UP THEY'LL- MAKE A
DECISION ON THAT. AND THE
REASON WE HAVE A ONLY AT R. J.
D. IS BECAUSE OF THE COURT
ORDER. THAT IS CORRECT OKAY. OF
AND- WITH REGARDS TO THE VIDEO-
WE SHOULDN'T YOU KNOW FILM BY
THE BY THE CAMERA. HOW ARE YOU
STORING IT AND- HOW LONG WILL
YOU STORE THE VIDEO AND- DO YOU
REVIEW THE RIP VIDEO WHAT WHAT
DO YOU DO AND FOR HOW LONG. THE
VIDEO ALL AUDIO VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE AND BODY CAMERA
FOOTAGE IT R. J. D. WILL BE
RETAINED FOR NINETY DAYS ON THE
VIDEO MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. AND
THEN IF THERE IS A TRIGGERING
EVENT. OF MAYBE WE'LL SAY
ALLEGATIONS OF EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE IF THERE'S SOME TYPE OF
USE OF DEADLY FORCE- THEN THE
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES UNIT
STAFF WHAT EXPORT BACK FOOTAGE
TO A SECURE LOCAL SERVER AND
THEY WILL ALSO EXPORT THAT
FOOTAGE AND PUT IT ON A DVD FOR
EVIDENCE PURPOSES. AND AGAIN
ANY TO REITERATE ANY USE OF
FORCE OR TRIGGERING EVENT
INVOLVING- AGAIN MATE WHO'S A
CLASS MEMBER OF THE ARMS OR
MEDIA PLAN. THAT ACTUAL FOOTAGE
WILL BE RETAINED OR RETAINED
INDEFINITELY. OKAY THANK YOU
ARE A FEW OTHERS ON ANOTHER
ISSUE- WE HAVE- LA- PLEASE. THE
FOOD. L. L. WHERE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED IN THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S REPORT AS WELL AS THE
CHANGES THAT THE DEPARTMENT
INDICATES IT INTENDS TO MAKE AT
THIS SPRING SO TO THE EXTENT WE
DO HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS WE WILL
CERTAINLY GET THOSE TO STAFF AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. OKAY. OKAY
BEFORE WE GET TO OF FINANCE
PLEASE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
THE CENTER COURT AS HE THANK
YOU MA'AM SURE. FOR THE OLEO- I
UNDERSTAND. YOU'RE STILL OPEN
TO MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS ON ON
THIS ISSUE OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF CHOICE ABOUT
GETTING- CAMERAS INSTALLED NOR
NOR IS IT A BAD THING IT IN MY
OPINION INHERENTLY IT'S
SOMETHING THAT OTHER LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT I'VE I'VE SUPPORTED.
OF AS NECESSARY AND GOOD OVER
THE LONG TERM MY QUESTION IS
GIVEN SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT
YOU MADE- AND PERHAPS YOU YOU
HEARD SOME OF THE DISCUSSION OF
THE PRIOR ITEM- DO YOU HAVE
CONCERNS. IN TERMS OF- THE P.
OR CALL THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN-
GRIEVANCE PROCESSES GRIEVANCE
PROCESS SEEN- TRAINING ISSUES
IN AND GETTING THESE CAMERAS UP
AND RUNNING- IN THE ABSENCE OF
A LOT OF THAT WORK- HAVING BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED. THAT WERE BEING-
DISCIPLINARY REVIEW IN TRAINING.
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE ASKING IF WE
HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CAMERAS.
YES I'M REALLY ASKING YOU A
LITTLE BIT AND QUICKER QUESTION
PROBABLY GIVING YOUR YOUR
PARTICULAR STATION OF LIFE IS
GOOD- DO YOU AVE LIABILITY
CONCERNS I MEAN THIS THIS IS.
HELLO REPORT IS PIVOTING- OFF
OF THE ARMSTRONG LAWSUIT SO I
THINK IT'S SOMEWHAT FOR IT ASK
YOU KNOW FOR. A LEGAL OPINION
UNLESS YOU INTERNET BUT- BUT I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE HERE IN THAT
CAPACITY IN ANY CASE. I JUST
WANT TO KNOW IF WITH SERVICE
SEEN IN THE L. A. ALWAYS CAN
IS. AT ALL CONCERNED WITH- THE
LIABILITY THAT MAY ARISE ONCE
WE GET THESE CAMERAS UP GIVEN
UP SOME OF WHAT WE'VE HEARD IN
IN THE LAST TWO ITEMS IN TERMS
OF GAPS IN IN TRAINING THE
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS. IN RIGHT
I REALIZE THAT SO PERHAPS A
LITTLE BIT OF A LOADED QUESTION
YOU CAN ANSWER YOU DON'T HAVE
TO ANSWER IT I JUST WANT TO
KNOW IF YOU HAD. A THOUGHT ON.
YOU'RE CORRECT I'M NOT AN
ATTORNEY- AND- WE'RE STILL. AS
I SAID ANALYZING THE PROPOSAL I
WILL I CAN SAY THOUGH AT THIS
POINT THAT WE ARE THE STATE IS
BEING SUED ACTIVELY ON. ON THE-
PROCESSES FOR HANDLING IN MADE
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
AND HAS BEEN ORDERED- TO
IMPLEMENT A REMEDIAL PLAN. THAT
INVOLVES IMPLEMENTATION OF
CAMERAS- AND THERE'S THE
PLAINTIFFS AND NOT LAWSUIT
HAVE. ORDERED THE STATE- SORRY
EXCUSE ME HAVE SUBMITTED A
MOTION TO IN THE ARMSTRONG
COURT- ALLEGING THAT THIS
EVENING THESE. THIS MISCONDUCT
IS OCCURRING AT OTHER PRISONS
IN AS WELL AND THAT- SO IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT THE STATE COULD
BE IN A- ADDITION WORDS BEING
REQUIRED TO ADD CAMERAS AT
OTHER PRISONS- AS- I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE MAYBE POINTING TO IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A CHICKEN AND EGG
PROBLEM BETWEEN- WE NEED.
CAMERAS TO ADDRESS- LITIGATION
THAT'S HAPPENING BUT MAYBE THAT
COULD PROMPT ADDITIONAL
LITIGATION I DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER FOR YOU ON THAT- BUT I'M
HAPPY TO- TO FOLLOW UP WITH
YOUR STAFF AND SEE IF WE CAN BE
OF GREATER ASSISTANCE. I THINK
WE GOT ASSURANCES ON THE PER
ITEM THAT WILL WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH
LEGAL COUNSEL- YOU KNOW TO GET
TO THAT. QUESTION- FOR ANSWERS
TO THE QUESTION- I APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR REPORT I APPRECIATE
ALL REPORTS DANGER IN ATTEMPT
TO RESPOND TO THAT- MY CONCERN
IN A IN A I'VE BEEN
CHARACTERIZED AS A LIABILITY
FOR THE STATE OF THE TREASURY
ISSUE BUT I WANT TO HARKEN BACK
TO SOMETHING THAT. ARCHER SAID
ON THE PER ITEM I'M DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT PUTTING
EMPLOYEES IN THE POSITION OF
BOTH HAVING BODY WORN CAMERAS
THE STATIONARY CAMERAS
OBSERVING THEIR ACTIVITIES WHEN
THEY HAVE NOT YET- BEEN
PROPERLY TRAINED PERHAPS IN
SOME AREAS LIKE ABA OF
RESPONSE- CRISIS INTERVENTION-
HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH CERTAIN
KINDS OF SITUATIONS IN TERMS OF
A- FROM AN INMATE. ACTING OR
BEHAVING IN A CERTAIN WAY-
MAYBE WE'RE GOOD TO GO THERE-
MAYBE WE'RE NOT BUT IT JUST
SEEMS BASED ON THE TWO ITEMS
THAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY THAT WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW. IF IT PEOPLE
BE MEDICALLY TRAINED AND I
THINK TO YOUR POINT OF MANAGED
CARE EARLIER- THIS. I THINK
ARMSTRONG WAS BOOK WAS BOUGHT
BROUGHT FOR HER AS IS THE SUIT
PRIMARILY ON BEHALF OF INMATES-
BUT IF WE ALSO SHOULD HAVE THE
SAME HUMANISTIC CONCERN FOR.
THE GOOD EMPLOYEES THAT WERE
PUTTING- INTO A INTO A
SITUATION PERHAPS WHERE THEY
WERE THEY'RE NOT READY. TO HAVE
THEIR ACTIONS- OBSERVED DOES
THAT MEAN WE CAN DO WILL. YOU
KNOW REJECT THE IDEA OF CAMERAS
NO BUT IT COULD IT MIGHT MEAN
THAT WE CAN ACCELERATE
TRAINING- AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
REALLY GETTING AT HERE SO I
JUST WANNA SHARE THOSE.
COMMENTS WITH. MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
PARTICULARLY. YES DOES ANYBODY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT WANT TO.
RESPOND TO THAT THE TRAINING.
YEAH I THINK- I WOULD JUST
POINT OUT TWO THINGS AS
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR SPEARMAN
POINTED OUT WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED
CAMERAS AND OTHER PRISONS AND
THESE WERE PRISONS WHERE THERE
WERE THE ISSUES THAT CAME UP-
AND IT HAS BEEN WHAT WE WOULD
CONSIDER RESPECTFUL SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION. OF OUR SHARE
SOME STATISTICS ON THAT THE
SECOND IS- THE LAST TIME I
THINK WE MET WITH SO WE MET
WITH SO YOUR COMMITTEE WE
TALKED ABOUT A- TRAINING-
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE THAT GETS-INTO SORT OF SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS AND DEALING WITH REAL
LIFE SITUATIONS WE ARE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
TRAINING FOR CADETS- THAT IS-
THAT WILL PROVIDE THEM THE
TOOLS NECESSARY TO PROVIDED TO
BE SUCCESSFUL IN THIS VERY
STRESSFUL ENVIRONMENT. THAT'S
ALL I HAVE BEEN THINKING- I
HAVE A COUPLE OF MORE
QUESTIONS- THE MOTION FILED IN
THE ARMSTRONG CASE. MENTIONED
OF THESE SIMILAR ALLEGATIONS
DISTURBING ALLEGATIONS THAT
OTHER INSTITUTIONS. BECAUSE THE
DEPARTMENT INTEND TO EXPAND USE
OF THE CHANGES. PLANNED AT RG-
R. J. D. TO ALL PRISONS. I AT
THIS POINT WE'RE UNDER A AS YOU
KNOW WERE UNDER ACTIVE- AN
ACTIVE LAWSUIT AND SO AND I'M
UNFORTUNATE I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY
WE DON'T HAVE AN ATTORNEY WITH
US- AT THIS POINT WE'VE AGREED
TO THE CHANGES RGD WE ALSO
AGREED TO THE CHANGES- AT L. A.
C. BASED ON THE FACT THAT THERE
WERE. A TWO BUT THERE WERE A
COUPLE YARDS WITH WE HAD A
LARGE DEGREE OF ARMSTRONG-
PLAINTIFFS SO I'M THOSE ARE
THE- INSTITUTIONS WE'VE AGREED
TO SO FAR WE ARE COMING INTO
THIS WITH AN OPEN MIND THERE
ALTHOUGH- ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
SPEARMINT MENTIONED THAT. SOME
OF BODY WORN CAMERAS ARE USED
TO THE CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY IT ISN'T
VERY PREVALENT SO WE'RE COMING
INTO THIS. UNDER A COURT ORDER
OF COURSE BUT THE TO CUT BY CUT
TO ME IS THAT WERE ALSO COMING
INTO AND- TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
THIS THE BEST WE CAN- TO BE AN
EXAMPLE FOR. OTHER INSTITUTIONS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. I HOPE IT'S
AN EXAMPLE OUR OWN INSTITUTIONS
AS WELL. IN THE IN THE STATE.
OKAY THANK. I THINK THAT'S IT
FOR MY QUESTIONS. ANYMORE NO
MORE QUESTIONS OKAY OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO HOLD OPEN
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE HAD ON THE HARD WORK
THAT EVERYBODY'S DOING THANK
YOU. I WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
THREE NOW. ISSUE THREE IS THE
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION. WITHIN THE. THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY- HOW THE HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY WHO'S GOING TO PRESENT.
THAT'S ME MADAM CHAIR I'M- I AM
THAT STEPHANIE WELCH AND THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES- AND
SO I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY-
I'M GOING TO BE PROVIDING AN
OVERVIEW AND COVERING A FEW
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN ASKED.
THE PROPOSAL ESTABLISHES THE
OPPOSITE YOU THINK COMMUNITY
RESTORATION WHICH- LOOKING
FORWARD I'M GOING TO REFER TO
AS THE L. Y. C. R. WE'RE
REQUESTING RESOURCES THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION IN BUDGET
YEAR AND THREE POINT ONE
MILLION I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
NINETEEN STAFF AND CONTRACTS
FOR SPECIALTY SERVICES SUCH AS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
EVALUATION EFFORTS. SB EIGHT TO
THREE ESTABLISHES THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
WITHIN THE HHS WHICH- FROM THIS
POINT FORWARD I'M GONNA REFER
TO AS AGENCY AFFECTED JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION OF
JUSTICE INVOLVED YOUTH BEING
SERVED IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH
DECADES OF REFORM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO OUR JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. ESTABLISHING IN
THE OFFICE OF USING COMMUTER
RESTORATION AGENCY BETTER
ALIGNS WITH RESEARCH AND BEST
PRACTICES THAT FOCUS ON
REHABILITATION AND SUPPORT THE
DELIVERY OF TRAUMA INFORMED AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
SERVICES TO YOUTH AND YOUNG
ADULTS IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. RESEARCH SUPPORTS THE
BEING CLOSE TO HOME REDUCES
RECIDIVISM THE- I SEE ARE WILL
HELP SUPPORT THE LONG TERM AND
SUSTAINED SUCCESS OF
TRANSITIONING. REALIGN USED TO
COUNTY BASED CUSTODY PROGRAMS
AND SUPERVISION. I WAS IN THE
OFFICE OF YOU THINK MAYBE
RESTORATION AT AGENCY WILL
FACILITATE LEVERAGING THE
EXPERTISE OF OUR VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS. LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES EPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND OFFICES LIKE THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
WHICH CAN SUPPORT THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
IN ITS EFFORTS TO IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES. WE ENVISION
SIGNIFICANT INTERACTION BETWEEN
THE OFFICE OF MUSIC COMMUNITY
RESTORATION WITH THESE
DEPARTMENTS TO SUPPORT STRONG
EFFECTIVE CONNECTIONS TO LOCAL
IMPLEMENTERS THE WILL BE
SERVING NEEDS YOU. IN ADDITION
TO OUR ARE PARTNERS IN
PROBATION LIKE OUR HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL
WELFARE DEPARTMENT'S. THE NEW
OFFICE. AS OUTLINED IN STATUTE
WILL DO THE FOLLOWING. IDENTIFY
AND DISSEMINATE BEST PRACTICES
TO HELP INFORM REHABILITATIVE
AND RESTORATIVE YOU PRACTICES
INCLUDING EDUCATION. DIVERSION
REENTRY BUT THEY JUST AND
VICTIM SERVICES FOR ALL JUST
JUSTICE INVOLVED YOUTH. OFFER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
IMPLEMENTERS ADVISING ON HOW TO
ACHIEVE OUTCOMES AND SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENT FOR USE ACROSS THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. ONCE DATA
BECOMES AVAILABLE FROM THE DOJ
WE WILL DEVELOP A REPORT ON THE
FALCONS IN THE ENTIRE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND THEREFORE
AND ONGOING THE REPORT ANNUALLY
ON THE WORK OF THE OFFICE. WE
WILL ALSO REVIEW COUNTY PLANS
RELATED TO THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT BLOCK GRANT. AND WE
WILL PROVIDE AND DELIVER ARMS
PERSONS ROLES AND INCLUDING
RECEDING ASSESSING RESOLVING
AND REFERRING COMPLAINTS- ALSO
CONSISTENT WITH ANY
CONFIDENTIALITY RULES WE WILL
REPORT ANNUALLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON ISSUES THAT COME
UP THROUGH THIS OFFICE. TO
FURTHER SUPPORT THE TRANSITION
OF JUSTICE INVOLVED USED TO
LOCAL SUPERVISION AND
REHABILITATION SB EIGHT TO
THREE DIRECTS THE CHILD WELFARE
COUNCIL TO ESTABLISH A
COMMITTEE TO ADVISE AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE OFFICE
OF YOUTH AND THE RESTORATION.
OF RELATED TO THE POLICIES
PROGRAMMES APPROACHES- IT
SHOULD BE DONE. TO IMPROVE USE
OUTCOMES REDUCE YOUTH DETENTION
AND REDUCE RECIDIVISM OR REAL
LINES YOU. THE CWC SOME OF OUR
COUNCIL ESTABLISHED THIS
COMMITTEE BACK IN DECEMBER OF
LAST YEAR AND WE HAVE SINCE
THEN BEGAN TO MEET. THE WHAT IS
THE R. WILL PROVIDE STAFFING TO
THIS COMMITTEE- IN ORDER TO
ELICIT AND EXAMINE AND
OPERATIONALIZE THEIR EXPERTISE
AND THEN THE COMMITTEE DOES
SUNSET ARE AT THE END I'M SORRY
AT THE END OF FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE- THE STAFF
HAS ASKED ME A FEW QUESTIONS
AND I THINK- UNLESS YOU WOULD
LIKE ME TO PAUSE HERE TO TAKE
QUESTIONS I WILL JUST. LAUNCH
INTO MY RESPONSES TO THOSE
QUESTIONS. OKAY I HAD. OKAY-
PLEASE WATER THREE YEAR
PROPOSED ORGANIZATIONAL CHART
SO IN YOUR AGENDA YOU HAVE
EIGHT- DOCUMENT DOCUMENT THAT
SHOWS OUR ORGANIZATIONAL CHART-
AS AN OFFICE BUT THEN SEES THAT
WITHIN AGENCY- LEADERSHIP
ULTIMATELY IS RESPONSIBLE TO
THE UNDERSECRETARY WHO IS
ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE TO THE
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY- THE OFFICE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WILL OVERSEE
A STAFF OF EIGHTEEN IN ADDITION
TO CONTRACT FUNDS THAT WILL BE
USED TO PROCURE ADDITIONAL
SERVICES. THE EXECUTIVE OFFICE
INCLUDES FIVE FULL TIME STAFF
PEOPLE INCLUDING THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WHICH IS A
CLASSIFICATION GAME CAREER
EXECUTIVE ASSIGNMENT LEVELS
SEE- A STAFF ATTORNEY AND THREE
ANALYST AND IT STAFF. WE HAVE
THAT IN THE CHART YOU'LL SEE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATIVE TEAM AS
WELL AS OUR IN HOUSE COUNSEL
ALSO LIAISON WITH OUR OUR
LARGER AGENCY. ADMINISTRATIVE
TEAM SO THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO ADDITIONAL EXPERTISE IN
HUMAN RESOURCES AND COMPLIANCE
FOR OUR IN HOUSE COUNSEL- THAT
INDIVIDUAL WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO
LIAISON WITH OUR CHIEF COUNSEL.
FOR CONSULTATION ON MORE
COMPLEX ISSUES. ALSO I'D LIKE
TO ADD- CONSIDERING I'M A
DEPUTY SECRETARY OF PART OF
THE- THE ROLE OF THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WILL ALSO TO BE A PART
OF OUR EXECUTIVE TEAM AT CHS
AND SO. THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
ALSO HAVE REGULAR AND
COLLABORATIVE INTERACTION. WITH
OTHER DEPUTIES AND ASSISTANTS
SECRETARIES LIKE MYSELF AND
ALSO OUR TWELVE DEPARTMENT
DIRECTORS THEIR DEPUTIES AS
WELL AS OTHER OFFICE DIRECTORS
SUCH AS THE SURGEON GENERAL-
NEXT THE POLICY RESEARCH
OPERATIONS UNIT CONSIST OF
SEVEN FULL TIME STAFF- THIS
UNIT WILL BE- IDENTIFYING AND
DISSEMINATING BEST PRACTICES
ASSESSING THE IMPACT F LOCAL
PROGRAMS AND DEVELOPING POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS. I RESEARCH
DATA SPECIALIST WILL LEAD
EFFORTS TO COMPLETE ANNUAL
REPORTS- AND ALSO INTERPRET
DATA AND PROVIDE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE AND EXPERTISE ON
RESEARCH AND EVALUATION FOR THE
OFFICE. UNDER THE GUIDANCE OF
SENIOR MANAGEMENT REMAINING
STAFF WILL EXECUTE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE OFFICE
PERCENT IN COLLABORATION WITH
COUNCIL AS WELL AS OUR COUNTY
LIAISONS NOW THE COUNTY
COORDINATION UNIT WHERE COUNTY
LIAISONS RESIDE. ALSO INCLUDES
SEVEN FULL TIME STAFF- THIS
UNIT WILL BE REVIEWING THE
COUNTY PLANS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM THE STAFF ALSO ACTS AS
PRIMARY POINT OF CONTACT TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR THE COMPLETION OF THESE
PLANS. AND CORRESPONDENCE WITH
OUR LOCAL IMPLEMENTATION
PARTNERS AS SUPERVISING MANAGER
WILL WORK WITH THREE SPECIALIST
AND TO ANALYSTS AND
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT TO
REVIEW COLLECT AND ASSESS
TRENDS AS WELL AS IDENTIFY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NEEDS
BASED ON THE PLAN RUBIO. AND
THE UNIT WILL BE ALSO
RESPONSIBLE IN COLLABORATION
FACT THAT OUR POLICY RESEARCH
AN OPERATIONS UNIT TO ASSIST
WITH ANY RESOLUTIONS THAT NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED THAT COME UP
THROUGH THE ARMS PERSON
FUNCTION- INCLUDING PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO ADDRESS
PATTERNS. AND TO IMPROVE
SERVICES- ENVISION THAT. FUNDS
BEING USED TO IN NEST SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE- ON TRAINING
OR EVOLVING SCIENCE OR THE
EVOLVING SCIENCE AND ADDRESSING
OF ADOLESCENT DEVELOPMENT- THE
ISSUES AROUND COMPLEX TRAUMA.
AND ANY KIND OF SPECIALTY
EVALUATION THAT WE MAY NEED TO
HAVE DONE. LASTLY WELL I AM
STAFF MAY BE DONE IN TWO UNITS
I HOPE IT WAS CLEAR OF ANY KIND
OF WALKING THROUGH THIS A
LITTLE BIT OF DETAIL THAT THE
STAFF IS EXPECTED TO WORK AS A
TEAM WITHIN THIS OFFICE AND
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- WE BELIEVE
THAT HAVING THE OFFICE
ORGANIZED UNITS. IS AN
EFFICIENT WAY TO PROVIDE STAFF
SUPERVISION AND TO DIVIDE UP
THE LABOR. NEXT QUESTION HOW
DID THE ADMINISTRATION
DETERMINE THE STAFFING LEVEL
GIVEN THE RISKS GIVEN THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT THIS
OFFICE STATUS- I'D BE HAPPY TO
SHARE WITH YOU THE PROCESS THAT
WE WENT THROUGH. WE ASSESSED
WHAT THE DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES WERE THAT WERE
PROVIDED TO THE OFFICE BASED ON
THE STATUTE. TIME OPENINGS FOR
THOSE ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS OF
THE AUTHORITY THAT THE STATUTE
GRANTED- I THINK ALSO IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF OTHER INITIATIVES IN
EXPERTISE WITHIN. HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES THAT WE THINK WE
CAN CALL UPON AND COLLABORATE
WITH- AS IT RELATES TO SOME OF
THE LARGER RESPONSIBILITIES
AROUND POLICY DEVELOPMENT
EXCEPT DRIVE. IN THE AREA OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE. SO IN TERMS
OF DO TO REVIEW AND JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT PLANS THE
STATUTE OUTLINES SEVEN
DESCRIPTIVE AREAS THAT THE
COUNTY MUST REPORT ON. THE
STATUTE NOTES THAT OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO REVIEW AND
ENSURE THAT THE APPROPRIATE
COMPONENTS ARE INCLUDED- WE DO
BELIEVE THAT INITIALLY THIS
PROCESS- PLAN REVIEW. AND
WORKING WITH THE COUNTIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYTHING IS
COMPLETE COULD POTENTIALLY BE
MORE LABORIOUS FOR OUR STAFF-
BUT WE DON'T SEE THAT BEING AN
ONGOING. ISSUE THIS STATUTE
OUTLINES THAT WHILE THE PLANTS
MUST BE UPDATED- OR MUST BE
SUBMITTED ANNUALLY THEY REALLY
ONLY HAVE TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY
UPDATED EVERY THREE YEARS.
WHICH THIS ALLOWS US TO KIND OF
STAGGER OTHER PROJECTS THAT
NEED TO BE DONE RECOGNIZING
THAT EVERY THIRD YEAR- OUR
STAFF WILL BE BUSY. WORKING ON
PLANTS- THE- I SEE ARE ALSO.
HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO FOCUS
ON IMPROVING THE OVERALL
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM BY
DEVELOPING BEST PRACTICES AND
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS. SO
BASED ON OUR ASSESSMENT
INCLUDING. SOME OF THE
INITIATIVES UNDER WAY WITH OUR
OTHER DEPARTMENTS- WE BELIEVE
THAT OUR RESEARCH- OUR RESEARCH
UNIT AS WELL AS THE COUNTY
COORDINATION UNIT IS WELL STAFF
TO ACCOMPLISH THIS. SOME OF THE
OTHER INITIATIVES GOING ON IN
OUR DEPARTMENT. THAT WE SEE
COLLABORATION WITH CERTAINLY
WOULD BE WITH OUR DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THE WORK
THEY'RE DOING ON THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE REFORM AS WELL AS
SYSTEM OF CARE REFORMS. AS WELL
AS THE WORK THAT'S GOING ON
WITH THE SURGEON GENERAL WITH
ASUS- AND IMPLEMENTING TRAUMA
INFORMED PRACTICES- THE- I SEE
ARE ON PERSON. RESPONSIBLE WILL.
ON PORTION OF THE JUSTICE. THAT
WAS RE ACCOUNTING. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN AND TWO
TWENTY. THIS INCLUDES ALL YOU
WITH THE SEVEN OF SEVEN B.
OFFENSE. WHICH I WOULD JUST
STATE FOR THIS- WHO MAY NOT BE
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT THAT IS
THERE'S A FAIRLY SERIOUS.
CRIMES AND DEAD. AND THEN YOU
FOR CERTAIN SEX OFFENSES AS
WELL AS YOU THROUGH STEP HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER NEEDS WHO
MAY HAVE BEEN SENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND AND STEP.
THE O. Y. C. R. WILL FOCUS
SERVICES ON THESE YOU BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE MOST LIKELY TO BE
PLACED IN JUVENILE JUSTICE
FACILITIES. AND ARE OFTEN TIMES
THE MOST IN NEED OF INTENSIVE
TREATMENT AND PROGRAMMING.
BASED ON ALL THE ABOVE I
CRITERIA AS THE ADMINISTRATION
ANTICIPATES THAT THE-
PERSONABLE WILL WORK WITH- THE
NUMBER OF USED TO AT LEAST THE
AND NUMBER OF USERS. WHO ARE
RELYING TO TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN AND TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
WE ESTIMATE THAT NUMBER TO BE
ROUGHLY AROUND. AT ONE HUNDRED.
NINETEEN HUNDRED. I THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY- THESE
ARE USED TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGH NEEDS THE
HIGH RISK OF- GRADUATE TO THE
ADULT CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND ALSO HAVE SIGNIFICANT-
NEEDS AND SO WE THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO FOCUS ON-
THIS PARTICULAR POPULATION. I
THINK THE LAST THING I WOULD
STAY IN THIS AREA- IS THAT THIS
OFFICE IS NEW AND I THINK IT
WOULD BE REMISS TO SAY THAT WE
SAT DOWN AND MATHIS OUT AND
THOUGHT THAT THIS IS THE WAY
THAT IT SHOULD OPERATE
INDEFINITELY- WE BELIEVE IN
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT WE NEED TO
BE COMMITTED TO THAT AND
RECOGNIZE THAT. WITH TIME THERE
COULD BE CHANGES AND WE MAY
NEED TO RESTRUCTURE AND ADAPT
TO BE EFFECTIVE- NEXT QUESTION
WHAT ARE THE TECHNICAL HUMAN
SERVICES AND JUVENILE JUSTICE
BACKGROUNDS EXPECTED OF THE
STAFF. THE OFFICE WILL HAVE A
TOTAL OF SEVEN- SORRY NINETEEN
STAFF- AND WILL HAVE KNOWLEDGE
IN IT IN THESE AREAS JUVENILE
JUSTICE HUMAN SERVICES HEALTH
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. STAFF
SKILL SETS RANGE FROM LEGAL
EXPERTISE THE DATA EXPERTISE TO
PROGRAM AND POLICY EXPERTISE-
IN STATE SERVICE THE
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT WE
SELECTED WE BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN. WORK WITH IN DEVELOPING
DUTY STATEMENTS DURING
RECRUITMENT- AND VARIOUS JOB
DESCRIPTIONS TO INCLUDE THESE.
AREAS OF EXPERTISE. WE WILL
ALSO MOST CERTAINLY CONSULT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT. THAT THE
CURRENT DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND OTHER EXPERTS
INCLUDING THE MEMBERS OF R. O.
Y. C. R. COMMITTEE OF THE CHILD
WELFARE COUNCIL. TO GET THEIR
THOUGHTS ON WHAT KINDS OF
SKILLS- AND BACKGROUND WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING FOR WHEN
DEVELOPING DUTY STATEMENTS AND
JOB DESCRIPTIONS. I DON'T AGAIN
I THINK IT I WOULD ALSO THINK
IT'S IT IS ALSO VERY IMPORTANT
TO KNOW THAT ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY THE OFFICE IS. AND IS A
VALUABLE FOR IT TO BE AN AGENCY
pTECHNICAL EXPERTISE OF THE
STAFF AND LEADERSHIP AND OUR
OTHER DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING OUR
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT THREE HAVE
THE- DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS. ETCETERA IN
THIS PROPOSED A CAREER.
ASSIGNMENT DESIGNATION X. ME-
IS PROPOSED THE EXACT DIRECTOR.
INSTEAD OF THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTED POSITION SUBJECT TO
SENATE CONFIRMATION WHY IS A
CAREER EXECUTIVE ASSIGNMENT
POSITION PROPOSED FOR THIS
POSITION AND I THEIR ACTIVITIES
A TO SEE A DEAL. THAT APPOINTED
APPOINTED POSITION CANNOT. THE-
WHITE C. R. AS IN MY BEFORE
REPORT TO THE UNDER SECRETARY
WHO IN TURN REPORTS TO THE
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. THE UNDERSECRETARY
AND THE SECRETARY ARE CONFIRM
POSITIONS MOREOVER THE HEAD OF
A Y. C. R. WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
ACT WITHOUT APPROVAL OF THE
UNDERSECRETARY AND THE
SECRETARY. IN STATE
CLASSIFICATION A. C. A. LEVEL
SEAT POSITION IS DESCRIBED AS
SOMEONE WITH EXTENSIVE
MANAGERIAL AND PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPERIENCE WHICH
HAS INCLUDED WHICH HAS INCLUDED
SUBSTANTIAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR
A COMBINATION OF MANAGEMENT
FUNCTIONS. SUCH AS PROGRAM
PLANNING POLICY FORMULATION
ORGANIZATIONAL OF COORDINATION
AND CONTROL AND FISCAL AND
PERSONNEL MANAGEMENT WE FEEL
THAT IS C. A. C. POSITION WILL
PROVIDE THAT LEVEL OF SKILL.
EXPERTISE LEADERSHIP AND
MANAGEMENT THAT'S NEEDED FOR
THIS OFFICE TO BE. SUCCESSFUL
SO GIVEN THESE AT THESE POINTS-
ITS FEET MINISTRATIONS POSITION
THAT THIS SHOULD. NOT BE A
COMFORTABLE POSITION. DO YOU IN
TO STAFFING TO MEET THE REST.
IN FUTURE YEARS SB EIGHT TWO
THREE. FOR EXAMPLE SB EIGHT TO
THREE MINUTES ALL JUVENILE
JUSTICE GRANT ADMINISTRATION
FUNCTIONS FROM THE BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
TO THE OCR. IN JANUARY. TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. WE DO NOT- WE HAVE
LOOKED INTO THIS THIS WAS PART
OF OUR ASSESSMENT. THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT GRANT PLANS
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE WILL NOT
REQUIRE A SIGNIFICANT- ANNUAL-
STAFFING AND STAFF TIME- BY THE
TIME WE HAVE REACHED TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE AND WE BELIEVE THAT
AT SOME OF THIS STAFF IN
PARTICULAR. CAN ABSORB THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES. AND CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON THE DECISION TO
PLACE THE ARMS BUT- ARMS BY
THIS MAN'S GIVE ME IT'S AN
AWKWARD. WORDING ALMOST PERSONS
POSITIONS WITHIN A UNIT AS
OPPOSED TO A SEPARATE UNIT- AS
I MENTIONED BEFORE THE CONCEPT
OF UNITS IS REALLY TO
FACILITATE EFFECTIVE STAFF
SUPERVISION. THIS OFFICE WILL
FUNCTION AS A TEAM- AND
EVERYBODY REPORTS TO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ULTIMATELY
THROUGH MANAGEMENT THE L. Y. C.
R. ARMS FOR SOME
RESPONSIBILITIES INCLUDE
RECEIPT AB RECEDING REVEALING
AND REFERRING COMPLAINTS FROM
YOUTH AND FAMILY STAFF AND
OTHERS. ABOUT HARMFUL
CONDITIONS AND PRACTICES
VIOLATIONS OF THE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS GOVERNING
FACILITIES AND CIRCUMSTANCES
PRESENTING AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION THE- ICR HAS
DETERMINED THAT IT CAN HELP
RESOLVE THESE COMPLAINTS. A WE
MADE A DETERMINED THAT WE MIGHT
BE ABLE. TO RESOLVE THESE
COMPLAINTS THE COLLABORATION.
AND TECHNICALS. WITH THE STILL
EIGHT MINUTES AND STAFF.
CERTAINLY THESE ROLES ALSO
PROVIDE INCREDIBLE INSIGHT AS
TO WHAT KIND OF TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
RESEARCH THE OFFICE SHOULD BE
DOING THE OFFICE WILL ALSO
PUBLISH AND PROVIDE REGULAR
REPORTS THE LEGISLATURE AS I
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY. AND OF
COURSE IF THERE ARE COMPLAINTS
WE WILL TAKE SEVERAL WE WILL-
REFER THEM TO THE APPROPRIATE
BODY TO REFUSE TO SEEK
RESOLUTION. ALL THE OFFICES
NINETEEN POSITIONS WELL WE HAD
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SOLELY
DEDICATED TO THIS FUNCTION AS
WELL AS HAVING ACCESS TO IN
HOUSE COUNSEL. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WE SEE
SEVERAL OF THE STAFF- BEING
PARTIALLY DEDICATED TO DOING
WORK THAT COMES OUT OF WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED. THROUGH WHAT WE-
ARE RESPONSIBLE IS BEING
EXECUTED. IN THE ARMS OF ARMS
PERSONS FOR ALL. FOR EXAMPLE
THE COUNTY LAZINESS WILL ENGAGE
WITH WITH LOCAL IMPLEMENTERS IF
WE ARE HEARING THINGS. THAT
ROLE THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
IT LAST QUESTION- IF THE
STAFFING IS SPLIT UP INTO
REGIONS WITH THIS MAKE IT
HARDER TO DISSEMINATE BEST
PRACTICES PLEASE EXPLAIN- WITH
THE TEAM THIS SIZE WE ACTUALLY
SEE A LOT OF ENERGY AND
INNOVATION THAT CAN COME FROM
STAFF BECOMING EXPERTS IN OUR
REGION OR WITH THE PARTICULAR.
COMPLEX COUNTIES OR COUNTIES
THAT HAVE SOME SIMILARITIES
LIKE ALL BEING IN MORE RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND I'M BRINGING
THAT EXPERTISE IN CROSS
FERTILIZING IT OF ACROSS
REGIONS- AND IN IN MY
EXPERIENCE- AND EFFECTIVE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CAN
SUCCESSFULLY CREATE THIS KIND
OF ENVIRONMENT WHERE STAFF FOR
SHARING WITH AND LEARNING. AND
USING IT TO IMPROVE STRATEGIES
AND PRODUCTS- AND OUTCOMES SO-
WITH THAT BEING SAID I WILL.
HEY QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- PRECIADO-
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU PUT INTO
INTO THOSE- QUESTIONS I GUESS I
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE WHO
YOU WILL BE- SERVING AND YOU
MENTIONED- THAT YOUR FOCUS IS
GOING TO BE ON THE YOUTH THAT-
EITHER THE ISSUES FOR WHICH-
YOU KNOW THAT. THEY COMMITTED
OR OF THEY HAVE A GREATER NEED-
THEY BASICALLY YOUR- MORE MORE
LIKELY OR MORE RISK- TO GO INTO
ADULT OF INCARCERATION AND YOU
SAID IT WAS ABOUT NINETEEN
HUNDRED FIFTY USE- THE SYSTEM
BEFORE THE- WASN'T SERVING. A.
B. M. I'VE GOT THIS WRONG BUT
LIKE SEVENTY FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND YOU WERE REFERRED TO
PROBATION AND THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND MAKE UP THE JUVENILE
PROBATION POPULATION CLOSER-
QUITE HUGE NUMBERS WHAT HAPPENS
TO THE NEEDS OF THE REST OF THE
JUVENILES. ARE YOU. YES VERY
VERY GOOD QUESTION- FIRST TO
CLARIFY I THINK WE CAN FOR- IS
GOING TO BE THE NINETEEN SIXTY
BASED ON OUR OUR ESTIMATES OF
THOSE TWO PARTICULAR YEARS TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY- AND THAT I FOR OUR
ARMS PERSONS- WILL OF
RESPONSIBILITY I THINK IN TERMS
OF POLICY DEVELOPMENTS AND
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF YOUTH TO ENGAGE AND
INTERACT WITH JUSTICE SYSTEM-
THESE ARE USE THAT ARE ANYTHING
FROM STATUS OFFENSES. TO
MISDEMEANORS I WOULD SAY THAT
YOU KNOW THAT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF USERS WHO ARE. ENGAGED IN
THAT. YOU CAN OPERATIONS- AND
OUR POLICY MOST SIR SHOULD I
SPEAK TO. REACHING THOSE KIDS
EFFECTIVELY WITH SERVICES- AND
INTERVENTIONS SO THAT THEY THEY
DON'T- FIVE. I WAS A GRADUATE
TO THE ADULT SYSTEM BUT THEY
ALSO JUST- ARE ARE SERVED AND
SUPPORTED TO BE SUCCESSFUL-
ADULTS AND- SO I DO SO I DO
THINK THAT- SOME OF THE
IMPORTANT GOALS OF ESTABLISHING
THIS. OFFICE MOST CERTAINLY
ESTABLISHING IT WITHIN HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AND AS I
MENTIONED THE DEPUTY AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH I KNOW THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT IN MY ROLE TO BE
VERY INVOLVED IN THIS OFFICE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING IN BEHAVIOR HEALTH
POLICY IS REACHING AND
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF THESE
KIDS BEFORE THEY FALL DEEPER
INTO THAT. YOU'RE NOT JUSTICE
SYSTEM SO IT IT IS A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSING I HOPE THAT I
CLARIFIED THAT. SOME OF THE
ROLES OF THE- AROUND POLISH
IDENTIFYING DISSEMINATING BEST
PRACTICES WE'RE REALLY GOING TO
LEVERAGE A LOT OF THE WORK THAT
OUR OTHER. DEPARTMENTS AND
OFFICES ARE DOING LIKE I
MENTIONED. YOU KNOW THE SURGEON
GENERAL HAS BEEN SUCH A
TREMENDOUS ADVOCATE FOR TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE. AND SCREENING
FOR TRAUMA IT'S REALLY KIND OF
BRINGING TOGETHER LEADING
TOGETHER THOSE VARIOUS
DIFFERENT INITIATIVES IN
ADDITION TO A CLEAR FOCUS ON
JUVENILE JUSTICE IMPROVEMENTS.
WITH THE OFFICE WHERE- I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AN IMPACT
OVERALL. I'M A BETTER OF. OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE SERVICES
WHEREAS- THE ARMS PERSONS ROLE
IN OF COURSE- WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IN THE PLANS
BECAUSE THAT'S VERY. CLEAR AND
SPECIFICALLY. OUTLINED IN THE-
STATUTE IS REALLY SPECIFIC TO-
A POPULATION THAT HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER NEEDS AND
FRANKLY HAS. HAS COMMITTED MORE
SERIOUS CRIMES. OKAY THIS THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE HAVE ANY
COMMENT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SYDNEY TENET PARTMINER FINANCE
NOTICE ON COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU UNDER ALEJO. MOREOVER
THE L. A. L. WE ARE NOT RAISE
CONCERNS OF THIS PROPOSAL
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE OKAY
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES MANY
QUESTIONS SENATE QUARTERS IN
EUROPE FOR PROOF PRECIADO THE A
VERY THOROUGH PRESENTATION-
UNITED I THINK IT'S- ON
DEFINITELY ON THE ONE HAND
COMMENDABLE TO. REALLY TRY TO
LEVERAGE I THINK IS A WORD
USED- YOU KNOW SYNERGY AND
OPPORTUNITIES- CROSS SYSTEMS IF
YOU ACROSS UNITS THE ONE AREA
THOUGH I'M STILL A LITTLE BIT
OF TROUBLE WITH IN TERMS OF. IT
STOPPING EXPECTATIONS. IS ON
THIS ARMS PERSON AROUND
SPOKESMAN ROLE IF I'M READING
THE CHART RIGHT THERE'S TWO OF
THOSE AND IF I HEARD THE-
EFFECT PRESENTATION CORRECTLY.
IS JUST SOUTH OF TWO THOUSAND.
YOUTH POTENTIALLY THAT. COULD
COULD- NEED TO BE MONITORED BY.
BY THIS GROUP IT I'M JUST
CONCERNED AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S ENOUGH- MAYBE I'M SHELL
SHOCKED TODAY BECAUSE OF.
COMPLAINT DRIVEN PROCESS IS NOT
LIVING UP TO WHAT PEOPLE
THOUGHT AND I JUST WANT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT- WE DON'T.
INADVERTENTLY WORKER JUST
THROUGH. AMBITION HERE TO TRY
TO GET A LOT DONE WITH TWO
PEOPLE THAT WE DON'T END UP IN
A POSITION WHERE. WE END UP
LATER ON GETTING A REPORT FROM
SOMEBODY SAYING WE HAD A LOT OF
COMPLAINTS THAT DIDN'T GET
RESOLVED OR- OR WITH A LOT OF
PLANES COMPLAINTS WERE PEOPLE.
NEVER REALLY GOT. WORD AS TO
WHERE THEY SHOULD GO. FROM
COULD YOU COULD YOU RESPOND TO
THAT PLEASE AND AGAIN I'M- AT
ONE OF CREATED A DEFENSIVENESS
HERE. IN TERMS OF SOMEBODY
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING VERY
LEAN- IN THE SYSTEM BECAUSE I
THINK THIS GENERALLY GOOD I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT.
SHORTCHANGING SHORTCHANGING YOU
AS WELL THANK YOU. YES SO AS I
MENTIONED- TO STAFF ARE SOLELY
DEDICATED TO THAT PURPOSE BUT
THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT OTHER
STAFF ARE NOT GOING TO BE
WORKING ON THIS OF COURSE WE
HAVE AN ATTORNEY- THE STAFF
ATTORNEY AT LEVEL THREE WHICH
IS IT IS A FAIRLY. HIGH LEVEL
POSITION- WHO ALSO I COULD SEE
MOST CERTAINLY PLAYED A
CRITICAL ROLE IN REALLY
DETERMINING WHAT TO DO WITH THE
COMPLAINTS- AND THAT FOR THAT
PARTICULAR STAFF PERSON WILL
LSO HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
AGENCIES CHIEF COUNSEL- YOU
KNOW MANY OF THESE COMPLAINTS
WERE GOING TO NEED TO REFER TO
OTHER PARTNERS AND ORDER HAD
GEORGE JOINT JURISDICTIONAL
ISSUES- WE HAVE WONDERFUL
LESSONS THAT WE WANT TO LEARN
FROM OUR OFFICE OF FOSTER CARE
THE OFFICE OF THE FOSTER CARE
HOMES BUT SPENT- AS YOU KNOW
FOR THESE YOU THERE'S A LOT OF
YOUTH WHO INVOLVED IN THOSE
SYSTEMS. AND SO WANT TO LOOK
INTO THAT AND DETERMINE HOW WE
CAN- WORK MORE COLLABORATIVELY
WITH THEM AS WELL AND I THINK
THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS
THAT WE REALLY SEE THIS ROLE-
AS A WAY TO LEARN ABOUT HOW TO
MAKE THINGS BETTER AND- AND
THAT'S WHY THE COUNTY LIAISONS-
WILL PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE AND
ALSO I THINK PEOPLE WILL
CERTAINLY- HAVE A PRETTY ACTIVE
ROLE IN RESPONDING TO THINGS
THAT WE LEARNED FROM FROM WHAT
COMES THROUGH THE OFFICE
PERSONS RESPONSIBILITIES
BECAUSE- WE WANT TO USE A
FRANKLY A CARROT TO CREATE
CHANGE AND STUFF SO THAT MEANS
WE NEED TO TAKE WHAT WE LEARNED
WHAT WE HEAR. AND OF COURSE IF
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT SERIOUS
YOUNG PEOPLE HORRIBLE WE'RE
GOING TO ACTION- BUT IF IT
MEANS IF WHAT WE'RE HEARING IS
THE PROGRAMS NEED TO PRINT
IMPROVE OR THEIR KIDS ENDING UP
IN THE SYSTEM SHOULD HAVE
GOTTEN SERVICES EARLIER THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
INGEST OF ADDRESS WITH OTHER
STAFF TO BETTER POLICIES BETTER
TRAINING YOU KNOW THEY CAN
CONTACT ME AND WE'RE NOT DOING
ENOUGH. FOR BEHAVIOR HEALTH
WHAT HAVE NOT AND SO I KNOW
IT'S- IT LOOKS PAPER BECAUSE
IT'S GOT THE TWO LITTLE. WITH
THEIR NAY ON IT BUT IT'S REALLY
THE WHOLE. WILL HAVE A ROLE TO
PLAY. MMHM IT THANK YOU THAT.
IN A- AGAIN I COMMEND YOU FOR.
YOU'RE TRYING TO CREATE AS
MUCH- NO EFFICIENCY IS POSSIBLE
I GUESS THAT'S THE RIGHT WORD-
BUT YOU KNOW IN YOUR- IN YOUR
QUEST TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
POSITIONS ARE THERE ARE TWO- I
DON'T SEE TROUBLE SHE WOULD
MAKE THE SYSTEM BETTER. AT
ALMOST RATHER SEE THE
INVESTMENT- IN IN MORE OF A
SURVEY AND- I WANT TO SEE
MENTORSHIP BECAUSE THAT'S A
STRETCH BUT IT'S A ROLE AS
OPPOSED TO A COMPLAINT DRIVEN
ROLE IN IT I GUESS IN MY MIND
SIGH- HAVING. YOU THOUGHT THERE
WHO WERE NOT INCLINED TO CHECK
IN WHO WITHOUT SOMEBODY
CHECKING IN WITH THEM HAVING
AGAIN SOME OF THIS IS MY
EXPERIENCE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
AN ENEMY SAY I APPRECIATE YOUR
RELIANCE ON A GOOD COUNTIES THE
COUNTIES THAT ARE DOING A GOOD
EFFORT BUT- THEY ALSO DON'T.
REALLY HAVE MUCH IN THE WAY OF
LEASE CURRENTLY OF SUPERVISION
OUTSIDE OF INCARCERATION- AT A
COUNTY LEVEL. OF OR ANY KIND OF
MENTORSHIP IT'S GETTING BETTER
I WOULD SAY EVEN IN A BIG
COUNTY LIKE SANTA CLARA WHERE I
COME FROM- THERE'S INCREASE
EFFORTS TO. I TO CREATE THOSE
KIND OF EXTERNAL SUPPORT
SYSTEMS- BUT THEY REALLY DON'T
FULLY EXIST IN. BLACK FACT THAT
THEY DON'T EXIST TENDS TO LEAD
TO- WITH SOME YOUTH- YOU'RE THE
KIND OF RECIDIVISM THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO AVOID SO- WHAT'S YOUR
LET ME ASK YOU- WHAT YOUR
FALLBACK POSITION IF TO ISN'T
ENOUGH IN. YOU KNOW IMPROVING
THE SYSTEM REALLY MEANS THAT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE. OF MORE MORE
HANDS ON MORE EYES- MORE. A
MORE COMMUNICATION WITH THESE
YOU. SO I THINK WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS THAT THE OFFICE ALSO HAS
A RESPONSIBILITY TO LOOK AT
DATA- AND TO USE THAT DATA TO
DRIVE POLICY WE ALSO COME BACK
HERE AND SHARE THAT DATA WITH
WITH ALL OF YOU WITH THE
LEGISLATURE SO DON'T KNOW IF I
WOULD CALL IT SO MUCH OF THE
BALL BACK- BENCH- OBVIOUSLY AN
OPENNESS TO LEARNING WHAT WE
NEED TO DO AND TO USE DATA. TO
DRIVE THAT SO- AS I THINK THAT
THAT IS ANOTHER THING THAT
WE'RE REALLY GOING TO HAVE TO
LOOK AT AND THIS IS YOU KNOW
AND THIS IS AN EXCITING AND
IMPORTANT CHANGE BUT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PAYING
ATTENTION TO WHAT WE'RE
LEARNING AND DAD. YOU KNOW
AGAIN HAVE A COMMITMENT TO
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT. LAST
QUESTION IN THIS REGARD IS. IF
YOU WERE. BUDGETARY AUGMENTED
SPECIFICALLY IN THE AREA WOULD
YOU INCLINATION TO BE TO PUSH
BACK ON THAT IT IS HAVING THE
TWO SO COR AND TWO AND NO MORE.
THAT IS SO CORE TO YOUR YOUR
MODEL HERE THAT- YOU'RE NOT
EVEN INTERESTED IN ADDITIONAL
FISCAL SUPPORT IN THAT AREA. I
CAN'T REALLY ANSWER THAT
QUESTION- WHAT I CAN SAY AGAIN
IS I DON'T REALLY BELIEVE THAT
THE OFFICE IS DEDICATING TO
PEOPLE TO THE SERVICE I THINK
IT'S DEDICATING- MUCH OF THE
WORK IT'S JUST NOT IT'S JUST
NOT THE SOLE FOCUS OF THEIR
WORK- AND SO I EAT YOU KNOW
AGAIN. I REALLY THINK THAT THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION
AS WE REALLY THOUGHT ABOUT THIS
AND WE HINK THIS IS A GOOD AS
STRUCTURE AND AS WE THINK THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH EVERYTHING THE
STATUTE HAS DIRECTED US TO
ACCOMPLISH MORE WITH. WHAT WE
PROPOSED DEAL. OKAY WELL THAT'S
ALL I CAN DO IS ASKING INQUIRE
AND- YOU KNOW STOP THEIR
MANAGER WITH THE- FIFTY EIGHT
AGAIN I MIGHT CONCERN IS TO BE.
A WHO WAS TAKEN IN A HELPFUL
AND CONSTRUCTIVE CONTEXT HERE
IS. THIS SEEMS TO BE A GOOD
THING FOR MY AGAIN FROM MY
EXPERIENCE- IN. THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM PARTICULARLY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. I THINK COUNTIES
WILL EMBRACE IT BY AND LARGE-
GREAT JUST- HE TO CS
SHORTCHANGE THE MODEL EARLY ON
AND I HOPE YOU'LL CONTINUE TO
CONSIDER THAT. THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU. THE WOMAN
THE COURT CHRISTIAN FOR THE
CARE THIS IS ALLISON WHO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WANTED
TO JUST OFFER ONE THING I'VE TO
SENATOR CORTESE'S COMMENTS- I
WANTED TO. AS UNDERSCORE THAT
SB EIGHTY THREE WHEN THAT
JUVENILE REALIGNMENT I THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
ULTIMATELY- IS EFFECTUATED THE
JUVENILE REALIGNMENT WENT
THROUGH THE PROCESS LAST YEAR
CRIME THE BILL ACTUALLY
INCLUDES APPROPRIATIONS TO
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
THE USE THAT WOULD BE REALIGNED
UNDER THE BILL. AND IF YOU JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE IS
THAT A GOAL OF PROVIDING
RESOURCES TO COUNTIES TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE. THAT ROBUST
LEVEL OF SERVICES TO THE TO THE
USE THAT WOULD BE REALIGNED.
I'M TO THEM STARTING ON JULY
FIRST. YOU I HOPE. I PRESHEAF
THAT CLARIFICATION IN THE KELLY
WOULD YOU SAY- I WOULD SAY
YOU'RE PUTTING A LOT OF FAITH
AND CONFIDENCE IN THE HR.
DEPARTMENTS AND HIRING
PROCESSES AT THE COUNTY TO GET
THOSE FOLKS IN PLACE- IN TIME.
IT IN AGAIN I DON'T KNOW. WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE FROM THE
STATE'S PERSPECTIVE HOW FAST
YOU CAN YOU KNOW ON BOARD
PEOPLE AND GET THEM- AGAIN
HANDS ON EYES ON THE SITUATION
BUT- I'M PROUD OF MY IT MIGHT
COME HOME COUNTY BUT- YOUR- HE
PROBABLY TO GET POSITIONS
FILLED CURRENTLY EVEN PRE
COATED IS A TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN
MONTH PROCESS- IT IN A WITH.
BUT THE MONEY'S GREAT AND
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN THEY CAN DO
BETTER AND YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
OUT THERE AND THEY'RE ALL GOING
TO HAVE TO LIVE UP TO. YOU KNOW
TO A PRETTY. PRETTY QUICK. FAST
PACED- ENVIRONMENT HERE. AS
THIS GOES FORWARD I GUESS. BUT
I APPRECIATE THE CLARIFICATION
THANK YOU YEAH. THANK YOU- I DO
HAVE CONCERNS ALSO ABOUT THE-
THE STAFFING LEVELS- ESPECIALLY
AS I THINK THAT THEY ARE SET
OUT IN SB EIGHT TO THREE- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT- YOU'RE
MAKING DECISIONS OR PROPOSALS
BASED ON A MUCH SMALLER NUMBER
OF YOUTH TO BE SERVED OTHER
THAN WHAT I THINK IS LAID OUT
IN SB EIGHT TO THREE SO I WOULD
REALLY URGE AND COME BACK TO
THE ISSUE OF HAVING- THE
STAFFING THAT'S GOING TO BE
NEEDED- TO MAKE THIS WORK. AND
ALSO DO WE WANT TO MAKE IT WORK
RIGHT- WE CAN ALWAYS BUT WE
DON'T NEED THAT MANY WE CAN
ALWAYS ADDRESS THAT BUT- MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE START OUT
WITH LESS THAN WHAT'S NEEDED-
AND- SO I'D LIKE TO JUST PUT
THAT OUT TO. A TO THE
DEPARTMENT- AND- JUST ONE LAST
I KNOW YOU MENTIONED THIS AND
IF YOU HAVE A SHORT ANSWER TO
THIS IS- THE POSITION THE
EXECUTIVE POSITION- WHY AGAIN
WOULD YOU. OPPOSE A SENATE
CONFIRMED POSITION. THIS
INDIVIDUAL WILL BE RECORDING-
UP REPORTING DIRECTLY TO THE
UNDER SCRETARY WHO REPORTS TO
THE SECRETARY BOTH OF THOSE ARE
CONFIRM POSITIONS- ALSO THERE
ARE NO DECISIONS OF THAT PERSON
WILL BE MAKING OUT WITHOUT THE
APPROVAL AND- COORDINATION WITH
ART ARE CONFIRM SECRETARY AND
UNDERSECRETARY SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION JUST NOT SEE A
NEED TO. CONFIRM THIS POSITION.
OKAY I THINK WE MAKE
CONFIRMATIONS AND A LOT OF
POSITIONS THAT. DON'T HAVE THE
DECISION MAKING WE DO THAT ALL
THE TIME WITH A- DIFFERENT
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS. AND
POSITIONS SO- I WANT TO KEEP
THAT ON THE ON THE TABLE AS
WELL- I THINK THAT'S IT NO MORE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOU WORK THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
THAT YOU WERE HERE. BUT WE MOVE
ON NOW TO ISSUE FOR. OUR COUNTY
PROBATION. AND- WHO WILL BE
MAKING THE PRESENTATION GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I JUST
NAY I MEAN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND I'M GOING TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF DEBT
FREE REQUESTED SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT- FIRST PROPOSING A
MODIFIED YOUR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THE STATUTORY FORMULA.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS PERFORMANCE ACTORS
TWO THOUSAND NINE. WHICH
PROVIDES FUNDS TO COUNTIES TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS ON FELONY
SUPERVISION WERE SENT TO STATE
PRISON. I BECAUSE OF SEVERAL
FACTORS PRIMARILY IF OF THE
NINETEENTH AND THEN MAKING IT
IMPACTS. YOU THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS COMMUNITY STATE
PRISONS WE ARE PROPOSING TO
AMEND THE FORMULA. TO PROVIDE A
SET AMOUNT OF A HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION GENERAL
FUND. WHICH IS A TEN POINT
THREE MILLION INCREASE OVER THE
PRIOR YEAR FOR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. OBVIOUSLY NOT IS
DERIVED FROM THE HIGHEST SB SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT AND IN EACH
COUNTY OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS. I WE NOTE THAT THIS IS
INTENDED TO BE A TEMPORARY
MEASURE. I IN ADDITION TO THE
PANDEMIC OTHER FACTORS SUCH AS
AB NINETEEN FIFTY WHICH REDUCED
THE DURATION OF MOST PROBATION
TERMS. ALSO AFFECTING EXISTING
FORMULA. THESE FACTORS WILL
REQUIRE FUTURE MODIFICATION OF
THE CURRENT FORMULA MAINTAIN SB
SIX SEVEN EIGHT FOUR ONE
INCENTIVIZING THE WORK OF
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT. IN
MINIMIZING. CALIFORNIA'S PRISON
POPULATION. THE SECOND REQUEST
IS FOR. FIFTY NINE GENERAL BY A
ONE TIME TO SPUR COUNTY FOR.
DEPARTMENTS IN. IT RE. AS THEY
TAKE ON INCREASED WORKLOAD AND
RESPONSIBILITIES I WE BELIEVE
A. COUNTY PROBATION AGENCIES
CAN BE PARAGONS OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM EFFORTS. EIGHTY
NINETEEN FIFTY AND SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE TREELINE JUVENILE
OFFENDERS THE COUNTIES OF THEIR
COMMITMENT BEGINNING JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- IF THEY'RE
PROVIDED THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES TO DO SO. THESE FUNDS
ARE INTENDED TO PROVIDE START
UP FUNDING A. COUNTY SAID THAT
PROBATION AGENCIES COMPLEXITY
BASED PLANT SPEND. IN THE
MANNER MOST APPROPRIATE FOR THE
POPULATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE
COUNTIES MAY USE THESE FUNDS TO
FRONT LOAD TREATMENT AND OTHER
SERVICES. ARE MODIFIED JUVENILE
FACILITIES THREE UNIQUE
ENVIRONMENTS. PLAN AND DEVELOP
REGIONAL APPROACH IS FOR
SERVING YOU. AND TRAIN AND HIRE
ADDITIONAL STAFF FOSTER
REHABILITATION AND. BEAST CASE
THAT SIZE AND- FIND THE BUDGET
TWELVE POINT NINE ONE MILLION
GENERAL ONE TIME PROVIDED.
SUPPORT COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT ON EXPEDITED
RELEASES THERE POST RELEASE
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION
POPULATIONS RELEASED FROM STATE
PRISON. BEGINNING IN JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ICC ARE
IMPLEMENTED A POLICY TO REACH
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS.
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WITH A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS ORDER LAST
DISORDER WE'RE NOT SERVING OUR
STANDS FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR
VIOLENT CRIME. WERE NOT
REQUIRED TO REGISTER AS SEX
OFFENDERS YOU DO NOT POSSESS
THEIR RISK ASSESSMENT SCORE
THAT INDICATES A HIGH RISK FOR
VIOLENCE. EARLY RELEASE REDUCE
PRISON POPULATIONS AS A
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC. I'M
C. C. R. HAS ALSO EXPEDITED THE
RELEASE OF OTHER INMATES
INCLUDING THOSE CONSIDERED
MEDICALLY HIGH RISK. ABSENCE
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE OR
TWENTY TWENTY EXCUSE ME AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROVIDED
NINETEEN POINT ONE MILLION.
YOUR EXECUTIVE ORDER
AUGMENTATIONS AT THE DISASTER
RESPONSE AGENCY OPERATIONS
ACCOUNT. FOR THE NUMBER OF
EARLY DAYS COUNTIES RECEIVE
THESE INDIVIDUALS ON THEIR
CASELOAD. OF THE TWELVE POINT
ONE MILLION REQUESTED IS A
PROJECTED AMOUNT YOU CAN YOU
THESE EXPEDITED RELIEF EFFORTS.
THREE THE FIRST SIX MONTHS OF
THE BUDGET YEAR UNTIL DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
IF THE RELEASES ARE TERMINATED
BEFORE ASKING ENDATE. COSTS ARE
LOWER DUE TO OTHER FACTORS I WE
INTEND TO RIVER ANY ACCESS
FUNDING TO THE GENERAL FUND. I
WITH THAT I AM MORE THAN HAPPY
TO TAKE. ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
HELLO. THANK YOU MARIO THE AND
OFF ALL THE ADDRESSING OF THESE
SEPARATELY OF THE FIRST ISSUED
ON THE SB SIX SEVENTY CRIMES
MODIFICATIONS- WE NOTE ALL
ALONG WITH WHAT THE LETTER SAID
THESE POLICY CHANGES WILL BE
HAPPY WE CAN ALSO CHANGES WILL
BE IMPACTING THE SB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT AWARDS WITHOUT SOME SORT
OF MODIFICATION. AND GIVEN THIS
WE THINK THAT IT JUST WENT TO
THE S. B. SIX SEVEN EIGHT GRANT
FORMULA IS APPROPRIATE IN THE
NEAR TERM BECAUSE HE'S IMPACTS
WOULD BE DUE TO REASONS.
OUTSIDE THE CONTROL THE
COUNTIES. I IN THE LONG TERM.
WE THINK THAT IT IS FOR. WAS IT
IN MAY PERMIT. THAT JUST MEANS
WOULD UNDERMINE INTENT OF SB
SIX SEVEN EIGHT. IS BECAUSE IT
REMOVES INCENTIVE STRUCTURE
THAT WAS CREATED BY SB SIX
TO CONTINUE TO REDUCE THE RATE
AT WHICH PEOPLE. ARE REVOKED
BACK TO PRISON AS A RESULT OF
FAILURE IN THE PROBATION
SUPERVISION. EVEN IF WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THE
AUGMENTATION ON A ONE TIME
BASIS AND RECOMMEND
MINISTRATION TO PROVIDE A LONG
TERM PLAN FOR SB SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT. PACIFIC WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT MULTICHANNEL
LEGISLATION DIRECTING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PRIVATE
LONG TERM PLAN FOR JUSTICE SB.
SIX SEVEN EIGHT BY JANUARY
TENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
GOING ON TO THE NEXT PROPOSAL
ON THAT ONE TIME. AERATION
GRANT AFFECTING MILLION
DOLLARS. IT APPEARS TO BE
PROBLEMS ON THE IDEA THAT
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT'S
LACK SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE
WHICH THE REALIGNMENT OF THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
DJJ. ANYTHING NINETEEN FIFTY
WHICH IS A REDUCTION IN
PROBATION TERMS. HOWEVER THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
DEMONSTRATED THIS IS THAT THE
CASE. FOR EXAMPLE A LARGE
PORTION THE MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSAL SEEMS TO BE INTENDED
TO BE AT A SUPPLEMENT TO THE
FUNDING PROVIDED TO SB. EIGHT
TWENTY THREE BASED ON CONTACT
USE OF DJJ. HOWEVER THE MANAGER
DOES NOT DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE
ARE ANY INSUFFICIENT SEES IN
THE LEVEL OF FUNDING OR THE
ALLOCATION AND- THAT WAS
INCLUDED. AS PART OF THIS NEW
TWENTY THREE. IN ADDITION AB
NINETEEN. TRACKING D. FOR BASS
DEPARTMENT WORKLOAD BY REDUCE
THE AMOUNT PEOPLE ON. AS A
RESULT AB NINETY FIFTH SHOULD
ACTUALLY FREE UP PATIENCE WE-
MOREOVER THE RULES A LOT AND
YOU. AFTER THE TO ENSURE
FUNDING FOR THESE PURPOSES. THE
MINISTRY STATED THAT IT DOES
NOT TAKE ACCOUNTABILITY ON THE
USE OF THIS FUNDING IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED PASS
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE SIX SEVEN
EIGHT. HOWEVER SB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT REQUIRES OF THE FUNDING
PROVIDED FOR THE PROGRAM GO
TOWARD EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
AND ALSO REQUIRE THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT'S REPORT ON THE USE
OF THIS FUNDING. EVERFI THE
LIKELY THAT THESE
ACCOUNTABILITY BACK IT SEEMS
LIKELY THAT EITHER CATHOLIC
MECHANISMS CONTRIBUTED TO SB
SIX SEVEN EIGHT SUCCESS. AND I
SUGGEST I'M GONNA BY THE
MINISTRATIONS IN THE SUCCESS OF
SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT PROGRAM I'VE
BEEN JUSTIFICATION FOR MEETING.
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THIS PROPOSAL.
INITIATION ALSO INDICATE IT
SEEMS. THE REPORTED AS SIX
SEVEN EIGHT B. H. ONE THREE
WOULD PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
TRANSPARENCY ON HOW THE
PROPOSED FUNDING ISSUES. OUR
THE PROPOSED MONEY WILL NOT BE
SUBJECT TO THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDED IN SB SIX
SEVEN EIGHT OR SB TWENTY THREE.
AND THE MINISTRATIONSMADE IT
CLEAR THAT THE FUNDING SEPARATE
FROM THESE PROGRAMS MOREOVER
THE REASON APARTMENT COULD USE
THAT MONEY FOR OTHER PURPOSES
EACH FIT. I DID IT ON THAT THE
REPORT. FOR THESE PROBLEMS WITH
ANY BEARING ON THE- OF THE OF
THE PRO. ON IS A LOT OF JUST.
FOR BY THE MINISTRY FOR THIS
PROPOSAL AND A LOT OF ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISM WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL. GOING ON THE LAST
PROPOSAL ON THE TWELVE POINT
ONE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR PSEC TO SUPPORT
CONFIRMATION WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THE RELEASE OF.
PRISON INMATES TO PRC HAS TO
THE GOVERNMENT TEAM HAD DONE
IT. WE FIND THAT THERE'S
UNCERTAINTY OVER THE NON SUCH
RELEASES THAT WOULD HER GOING
BUDGET YOUR IS BECAUSE EACH
YEAR AS WE MADE SIGNIFICANT
ADVANCES IN. KOBE NINETEEN
MEDICATION EFFORTS INCLUDING
BEGIN AGAIN. MISTER MAXINE'S TO
INMATES. ONLY OVER THREE OF
BRITS INMATES HAD AND OR
RECEIVED BACK TO AT THIS. WHICH
HE DOESN'T. MAY NOT BE AN TO
CAN TO BE A ALL THE- WERE TORN.
TO REDUCE THE- DOES AND SEE TO
MINIMIZE THE CO NINETY. IN
ADDITION WE KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES FOR
CDC ARE INCLUDES POPULATION HAS
AN INTERESTING THE COCONUT TEAM
RELATED ALTHOUGH HE SHOULD STOP
BEFORE JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WHICH IS THAT SUGGESTS
THAT THEY WOULD NOT BE A NEED
FOR THE FUNDING FOR THESE ONLY
RELEASES TO BE ROUTED THROUGH
THE SEC TWO COUNTS. EITHER THAT
OR IN HIS YARD IT USED TO BE
ADJUSTED DOWNWARD TO REFLECT
LOW POPULATION I WOULD ARGUE.
THAT CONTINUED OR AT LEAST.
EVEN IF YOU RECOGNIZE HOLD
ACTION THE PROPOSED UNTIL THE
EVERY DAY. TIME WEEKS BECAUSE
CLARITY ON A LACK. OF COVENANT
THESE HERE CSK. INTO TWO
TWENTIES TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
HAVE BEEN QUESTION TO HAVE.
THANK YOU MR KRISHNA. OF OKAY.
MADAM THIS IS JUST NAY TO WITH
THEM SO I NEED THAT WOULD LIKE
YOUR HANDS ON. IF I IT HARD AND-
SORRY ABOUT THAT GO AHEAD
MINISTRATION IS TO THAT
PERFORMANCE INSTEAD COMPLY OF A
SIX SEVENTY EIGHT WE DO HOWEVER
WANT TO KNOW TO CONCERNED
INCLUSION OF BUDGET TRAILER
LANGUAGE TO COMMIT TO A
SPECIFIC PLAN OR EVEN A
TIMELINE OF A PLAN I'M
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC IN CERTAIN
UNCERTAINTIES WITH PROBATION
I'M COULD NEGATIVELY AFFECT AND
NECESSARY REVISIONS TO THE
FORMULA BY IMPOSING INFLEXIBLE
TIME ONE- THAT SAID WE'RE
CONTINUALLY- HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE THE L. A. O.
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AND
DEVELOPING A NEW FORMULA THAT.
PRESERVES THOSE INCENTIVES IN-
AS FAR AS THE L. A. RECOMMEND
AND CRITICISMS ON B. FIFTY
MILLION- IF THERE IS NO
SPECIFIC NEED I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT RECENT SURVEY-
OF INFORMATION THEY CAME
THROUGH THAT PART OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS REQUEST
FOR INFORMATION. ABOUT THE ONE
NINE POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME GRANT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATED WITH SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE I SEVERAL COUNTIES IN
THAT- REQUESTS FOR INFORMATION
INDICATED THAT. THERE WAS
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING STE PARTICULAR ANY
WALKING- INFRASTRUCTURE
MODIFICATIONS TO REALIGN YOU.
ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
NOTED THAT THEY NEEDED
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO FIND ADEQUATE FACILITIES
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS. I'M
MARIN COUNTY NOTED THAT THEIR
FACILITIES WERE OLDER AND THEY
NEEDED ME THEY NEEDED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. I TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THAT
FACILITIES- AND I THINK MOST
BLUNTLY KINGS COUNTY EXPRESSED
THAT THE NINE POINT SIX MILLION
WAS WOEFULLY INADEQUATE. TO
COMPARE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES TO
TAKE ON THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
JUVENILE. REALIGNMENT- AND WE
THINK THERE IS STEVEN NEED FOR
ANY DAY FIFTY NINE- TO HELP
PROBATION DEPARTMENT DEAL WITH
WORK BUT IT THE STATE EIGHT
THREE- SB AS DAY. THEY NOTE
STATE EIGHTEEN FIFTY IS GO TO
REDUCE PROBATION- TERM LIMITS
AND PRESUMABLY REDUCE
CASELOADS. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE WANTED TO KNOW WHAT
ABOUT THAT IS THAT IT'S LIKELY
TO END IMPACT- INDIVIDUALS ON
LONGER PROBATION TERMS WERE
LESS LIKELY TO OUR FANS-
INSISTENT RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
THEY HAVE MOST LIKELY
RECIDIVISM IS BERLINA
PROBATIONERS TERM INCIDENT
THESE FUNDS ARE ARE MORE AND
MORE INTENSE FRONT LOADING
SERVICES RATHER THAN FINDING A
DRESS IN THE BACK AND THE
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT COME EARLIER
OFF THOSE PROBATION TERMS. AS
BASIC KIND OF FACE TO FACE
THOSE IN AN INDOOR THE STATE ON
PROBATION TERMS SO WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR COUNTIES
NOW IT POPULATIONS CAN BE SIR-
RIGHT WHEN THEY BEGIN THEIR
PROBATION TERM SO THAT BY THE
TIME THEY'RE OFF THOSE
SHORTENEDSENTENCES THE RATE
SET UP FOR SUCCESS- AS FAR AS
THE LACK OF THE PLANNER
METHODOLOGY WE'VE- WORKED OUT
OF A CASE THAT BASED ON THAT
PASSED FIVE YEARS OF COUNTY
LEVEL DATA FOR THEIR- ORDER.
PORTANTINO PROBATION
POPULATIONS AND THE NUMBER OF
JUVENILE COMMITMENTS- WELL MORE
THAN HAPPY TO SHARE WITH
MEMBERS OF THE STAFF BEARING
ANYBODY ELSE WHO'S INTERESTED
KIND OF ALLOCATION WE'VE
ESTABLISHED- AND IT KIND OF IS
A CONSIDERATION OF HISTORICAL
WORKLOADS. BUT AGAIN WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT FUNDS SHOULD BE USED
FLEXIBLY BY COUNTY PROBATION-
AGENCIES INDIVIDUALLY AS THEY
HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS. FOR THEIR
INDIVIDUAL POPULATION. LASTLY
THE A. O. THAT THERE IS A LACK
OF- YOU JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT
IT MAY. SUPPORTS ENTRANCE. I'M
WEEK LOOKS TO WERE WITH OTHER.
ON AGAIN TO MATCH TO PROMOTE
MUSIC. I DO WANT HIGHLIGHT
COUNTIES ALREADY SUBMITTING.
AMOUNTS OF DATA TO BE A
EXISTING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. I'M SPECIFICALLY
IF YOU AB IS INCLUDED AS PART
OF S. B. EIGHT TWENTY THREE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WILL BE
WORKING ON REPLACEMENT OF A
JUVENILE COURT PROBATION
STATISTICAL TO THE SYSTEM-
POINT JCPS S. ODD BECAUSE
OFFICE IF YOU CAN COMMITTEE
RESTORATION IS. ALSO TASKED
WITH PROVIDING REPORTS ON YOUTH
OUTCOMES IN THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM. AND THE EXISTING
FRAMEWORK OF SB SIX SYDNEY
ALREADY REQUIRES COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS TO
REPORT. INFORMATION ON THE USE
OF. EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
INFORMATION OR OUTCOMES WITH
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ANNUALLY-
IN THOSE FINDINGS AND REPORTS
ARE PUBLISHED ANNUALLY- AND
PROVIDED TO THE LEGISLATURE.
ASK WHEN IT COMES BE POINT
MILLION FUND. AND GIVE ME A-
DOESN'T KNOW THAT THERE WERE
DIFFERENCES WHEN WE WERE DOING
OUR POPULATION ESTIMATES- CCR
HAD PROVIDED EARLIER ASKED ME
IT SEEMED. DAY EXPEDITED
RELEASES WOULD AND JUNE THIRTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHERE'S- THE
ADMINISTRATION FINANCE.
ASSEMBLY KIND OF LATER DATE
WHEN WE WERE DOING OUR
EXPECTATIONS A LITTLE LATER ON
THAT DAY WAS EXPEDITED RELEASES
WILL CONTINUE THROUGH DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
SO AGAIN WE DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT IT LOOKED KIND OF.
DEFEATED DIFFERENCES IN POINT
KIND ESTIMATES AND THAT WERE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO REVISIT IN
THE MAY REVISION ON THE KIND OF
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
NEED. I'M WEARING A PANDEMIC
MIGHT BE AT THE TIME BUT WE
JUST THOUGHT IT PRUDENT TO
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL BUDGET
RESOURCES AND THE GENERAL FUND.
TO PAY FOR THIS- EXPEDITED.
RELEASES THEIR NEXT. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MUCH. I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR. RAND THE
REPORTING THERE ARE NO
PROVISIONS- OR ARE THERE
PROVISIONS FOR REPORTING- AFTER
THE COUNTIES USE THE FUNDING.
AND HOW WILL THE- ALLOCATIONS
BE DETERMINED TO THE COUNTIES.
ONE THING I EXCELLENT QUESTION
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE NO
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS PROPOSAL-
HOWEVER WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT-
WE ARE OPEN TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS PARTICULAR
TOPIC- WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ALLOCATIONS- AGAIN IT'S BASED
ON KIND OF IT AND HISTORICAL
WORKLOAD OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS SPLIT. BETWEEN COUNTY
HISTORICAL SUBMISSIONS IT
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
FOR THEIR JUVENILE OFFENDERS AS
WELL AS THE INDIVIDUAL COUNTY
PROBATION POPULATIONS THAT WERE
KIND OF ADDRESSING HISTORICAL
NEED- FOR THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH. BOTH ADULT
PROBATIONERS AND YOU'VE BEEN
OUT MAINTENANCE TO ADDRESS
PRIMARILY SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE
AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FIFTY ITS
POTENTIAL. FUTURE WORK WILL
IMPACT. THE L. DID YOU. HOW
WILL THE ALLOCATIONS BE
DETERMINED WE HAVE- SET UP AD
BY COUNTY ALLOCATION AND AGAIN
I CAN PROVIDE THAT IT OKAY
STAFF AS WELL. OKAY ON THOSE
ARE MY QUESTIONS THUNDER. NO
THANK OR DOESN'T KNOW. QUICK
QUESTION AND YES THEN IT IS I'M
I'M CURIOUS TO KNOW IN TERMS OF
RESPONSES BACK FROM COUNTIES
REGARDING OF FACILITIES NEEDS
WHICH I KNOW EXIST OF THAT SO.
A PRETTY PLAIN TO SEE OBVIOUS
SITUATION. WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S BEEN- ANY EMPHASIS ON
FACILITIES NEEDS FOR PURPOSES
OF- TREATING THE CDA POPULATION
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
ALL DAY LONG AND THEN MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES- IN A DIFFERENT
FACILITIES THAN- FOLKS WITHOUT
THOSE ISSUES INMATES WITHOUT
THOSE ISSUES THAT ARE BEING.
SENT ON TO THE COUNTIES. I'M
JUST ASKING IS WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S AN ONGOING DISCUSSION OR
NOT. I BELIEVE THAT IS AN
ONGOING DISCUSSION AGAIN.
EXCELLENT QUESTION SENATOR
CASEY WE DON'T HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR AT THIS POINT. THIS
IS A FIX ON EIGHTY EIGHT
FACILITY NEEDS HOWEVER COUNTIES
ARE WORKING WITH THAT NINE
POINT SIX BILLION ARE PROVIDED
THROUGH SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE
ON KIND OF FACILITY GRANT
PROGRAMS ON THOSE FUNDS WERE
ALSO INTENDED TO SUPPORT AND A
REGIONALIZATION. SO THAT SOME
COUNTIES WHO MIGHT NOT HAVE A
NEED FOR ADA COMPLIANT
FACILITIES- DEPENDING ON OUR
POPULATIONS WILL BE ABLE TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
OTHER- NEIGHBORING COUNTIES TO
KIND OF ESTABLISH FACILITIES
THAT SUPPORT MORE REGIONALIZED-
EFFORTS. FOR THOSE PURPOSES AND
OTHERS. YEAH I DO REMEMBER COLD.
ASPECT OF IT THE YOU- IT JUST I
GUESS- AGAIN PUT A PLACE HOLDER
OUT THERE SO TO SPEAK ON THE
POLICY SIDE THAT- YOU KNOW THE
BUCKET. THIS THERE ARE OF FOR
THOSE GRANTS FOR THAT PURPOSE
FOR FACILITIES PURPOSES IS. A
POTENTIALLY GONNA NEED TO BE
EXPANDED TO. TO DEAL WITH.
AGAIN WHAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT WE KNOW IS THERE AS WE
RETURNED. AS A RETURN FOLKS
BACK TO THE COUNTIES- IT IN WE
REFLECT ON. THE STATE'S OWN
CHALLENGES- THE ARMSTRONG AND
WHAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER- WITH THE SIGNIFICANT-
PDA POPULATION AND MUCH OF THAT
BEING OF MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
OR ILLNESS THAT THE COUNTY'S RT
QUIPPED EITHER TO. ADD YOU KNOW
WITH BEDS OR TO HOUSE OF. THEN
PERHAPS THE STATE IS AT THIS
TIME SO IT THINK IT'S JUST
SOMETHING THAT FROM A BUDGETARY
STANDPOINT NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO
BE LOOKED AT WHETHER THAT'S- ON
THE LEGISLATIVE SIDE- WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE I DON'T
KNOW BUT- I'M SURE THE
PRESENTERS WOULD AGREE THAT
ALTHOUGH IT. THIS BUCKET THAT'S
BEEN CREATED- IS A GOOD INITIAL
START FOR PURPOSE ELISE MEANS-
IT'S PROBABLY GONNA FOLDERS
SHORT. BUT THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THE REPORT. THE L.
A. O. ANY RESPONSE. YES ONE
FINAL BIT OF CLARIFICATION ON A
COUPLE OF THAT PROPOSALS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS SO ON THAT SB
SIX SEVEN EIGHT RECOMMENDATION
FOR THE BUDGET TRAILER
SITUATION HARD TIMES NOT WITH
THAT PLAN THAT. THERE WOULD BE
REQUIRED BY JANUARY TENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO LAY OUT A
NEW FORMULA FOR THE SB SIX
SEVEN EIGHT AMOUNTS BUT TO SET
UP A PLAN FOR ADJUSTING NOT
FORMALLY GOING FOR ABOUT A TO
KEEP. IT ALIVE. ON ON GOING
BASIS AS FOR. ONE BRAND. I
WONDER TO COME A FEW THINGS
FIRST ADDITION THAT AND I ONE-
SIX MILLION IN THE COMING
THAT'S FOR BY FOR THE REAL LINE.
THE NOT ALL BE IN AWE GRAND
THAT'S- YEAH DOLLARS FOR SIX
POINT FIVE AND IN TWENTY
TWENTY. AND TO EIGHTY MILLION.
IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE WITH PROCESS ESTABLISH
HERE CONTINUE TO ADJUST GOING.
IN ADDITION REGARDING THE
SERVER THAT FOUND APART OF MINE
IS MENTION. WATER STILL HE'S
DID EXPRESS OVER LOCAL PHONE
MANY OF COUNTY ROUGHLY HOW OF
THEM. EXPRESS WE'RE NOT
INTENDED TO APPLY FOR THAT
POINT SIX MILLION SO IT.
WITHOUT SOME KIND OF MADE WOULD
NEED TO FUNDING IT'S NOT CLEAR.
WHEN I START THAT- TOTAL NOW OF
FUNDING THAT'S BEFORE. IS
AMOUNT. OKAY THANK YOU. THAT IS
CORRECT- EIGHT EIGHT I WOULD
SUS IN IN SOME COUNTIES AND I'M
NOT SO THAT THE ENTIRE ANSWER
THEIR BUT THAT THAT IN SOME
COUNTIES THERE'S A MOVE AWAY
FROM INCARCERATION IN GENERAL
AND SO THE NOTION OF BUILDING
MORE FACILITIES ARE IMPROVED
MORE FACILITIES GOES CONTRA TO
THEIR FOUGHT CURRENT PHILOSOPHY
OR IDEOLOGY- ABOUT. A DIVERSION
AND IN IN USING OTHER PROGRAMS
OTHER THAN INCARCERATION BUT IT
DOESN'T ANSWER THE QUESTION
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH FACILITIES
WHICH WOULD BE ESSENTIALLY THE
FACILITIES PROHIBIT THAT THEY
WOULD NEED TO MAKE- RELEASE OF
FOLKS WHO DON'T NEED THAT HELP
WE DON'T NEED THE FACILITIES
FOR INCARCERATION BUT WE DO
NEED. FACILITIES FOR A MENTAL
HEALTH AND I JUST SUGGEST DALY-
MAYBE. THAT QUESTION. HI BEEN
ASKED HIM THAT WAY- IF YOU ARE
TAKING THIS TIME POINT SIX
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN IT- OR ANY
ONGOING MONEY FOR FACILITIES.
FOR CORPORATION PURPOSES WOULD
YOU BE INTERESTED. IN IN A
SIMILAR BUCKET OF MONEY FOR. OF
MENTAL HEALTH PLACEMENT OF.
THAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT REQUIRE THAT
IN IF THAT'S BEEN ASKED.
WONDERFUL IF IT HASN'T I'M JUST
SUGGESTING IT'S A QUESTION THAT
NEEDS TO BE ANSWERED. GREAT
FOLLOW UP ON THAT- IT'S I THINK
THAT'S IT FOR THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU ALL VERY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK. OKAY
MOVING ON TO ISSUE FIVE. AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WILL
HAVE A PRESENTATION THANK YOU
ALL FOR JOINING US OF WHO IS
GOING TO BE MAKING THE
PRESENTATION. I'M SURE RYAN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WELL MISTER RANDALL. THANK YOU-
JUST WANTED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR YEAH THAT'S FINE AND SHE
THE VISION OF OPERATIONS
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ON ONE
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THE
OPPORTUNITY YOU ARE PRESENT ARE
ISSUES TODAY. I'M INTERESTED IN.
AND WE WILL PROVIDE- AND THEN
LOOK YOU I HOW QUESTIONS. FOR
TO COME. WHY ON THE AYE- SO WE.
BECAUSE I OUR ONE GO ON WITH
THE ISSUE IF YOU NUMBER FIVE-
THERE ARE EIGHT. PC THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET OFFICE
USEFUL FIVE FIFTEEN POINT ONE
DOLLARS. AND INCLUDE SEVEN
POSITION IN VARIOUS PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE DEATH. THE
EIGHTEEN POINT ONE MILLION.
WITH THOSE PCP. I THANK MILLION
SIX SEVEN. RELATED APPLICATION
OF THE IF YOU HAVE- THE POLICE
CHIEF FORCE STUFF. OF THIS
REASON WE FIND SPEND MUCH OF
OUR TIME- AND THOSE RELATED THE
INFLUENCE OF YES SIX- FOR MORE
THAN TO COVER ANY OF THE BILLS.
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE THAT
THERE WAS A LETTER THAT HE
DECIDED YOU THE SERVICE THAT
YOU THE AUTHOR. BACK IN JANUARY
AND- JANUARY TWENTY SIXTH
CONTENT LEYVA OUR REGIONAL
ESTIMATES OF WHAT WE BELIEVE IS
NEEDED EMPLOYMENT AB FIFTY HAS
SIX- SUPPORTING ME THE
EXPECTATIONS AND THE
REQUIREMENTS. SPECIFIED. IN THE
BILL THAT WAS SIGNED. SO THIS
MILLION- WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE
LETTER OUTLINE HIS INITIAL
INVESTMENT I DON'T WANT TO BE
REALLY CLEAR- BUT IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY GET US THE POINT-
THAT WAS EXPECTED IN THE
LEGISLATION- THE MODEL IS BASED
THAT ARE ORIGINAL ESTIMATE IS
BASED ON FORTY CASES PER YEAR.
AND INSTEAD AND THAT'S WHAT OUR
ESTIMATE WOULD ADDRESS A FIVE
TWENTY SIX MILLION THEN WHEN
THE POLICE PRACTICES PROVISIONS
IMPLEMENTED IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES NEEDED FOR
THAT- SO WE HAVE- BOTH
AVAILABLE TODAY I HAVE JOHN
MARSH WITH THE DIVISION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WHO CAN ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT R. ONE PORTION
OF THE VISION AND I DON'T WORK
THERE WITH YOU NOW WE ALSO HAVE
LANCE PLAYERS HE FAR FROM HIM
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE
ACTIVITIES AND THE RESOURCES
NEEDED FOR THE CREDIT. AS A
MATTER. OF FACT YOU QUESTION.
OKAY DO WE HAVE. DELEO OR MR
I'M SORRY PUT THEIR HAND UP
FIRST. OKAY THE L. A. O. HAVE
ANY DALY WITH THE L. A. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU. OKAY
THE OTHER HAND MISTER WEBER.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WEBER-DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST ONE
COMMENT COUNT ON THE END OF
THAT COMPANIES RAN WEEKLY THE
FUNDING PROVIDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOWS DOJ TO
ESTABLISH THIS INVESTIGATIVE
TEAM THE PROGRAM COLLECT DATA
AND WORKLOADS MIRACLES IN THE
FUTURE IF I JUST RESOURCES ARE
NECESSARY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT AT THIS
TIME IS A BRAND NEW PROGRAM
THERE A LOT OF UNCERTAINTIES.
AS HE MENTIONED THE WE ESTIMATE
ABOUT FORTY CASES YEAR BUT WHO
KNOWS REALLY GONNA HAPPEN AND
ALSO A LOT OF THIS IS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT ISSUE THE DOJ HAS
SO WE COULD RAMP UP OR THE
BUDGET THE DIRECT FUNDING FROM
YEAR ONE TO YEAR TILL AND IF
THEY WERE COMMITTED TO WORK
WITH DEPARTMENT JUSTICE AS
THESE TEAMS ARE COMMITTED AND
WILL BE MODERATED JUST RESTORE
NEEDS ARE NEEDED. IT'S WORTH
NOTING THAT AT THIS BILL
REQUIRES PLEASE PRACTICE VISION
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO THE
PROJECT IS WHAT'S COME BACK IN
A COUPLE YEARS REQUEST FUNDING
FOR THAT TO THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS AND AT THAT TIME TO RE
EVALUATE THE PROGRESS. OF THESE
VESTED. THANK YOU MUCH. I HAVE
A- QUESTION. IF IT THE- SOMEONE
COULD. DESCRIBE A LITTLE BIT
MORE. HOW AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
CHANGES THE WAY THAT THE DOJ.
HANDLED THESE CASES HOW WILL
THE DOJ. A DEPLOY YOUR
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT THE BILL.
AND CHAIRMAN OF THE JOHN MARSH
FOR MARKETERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND HE CAN SPEAK TO
HOW THOSE RESOURCES WILL ROLL
OUT- OKAY. MISTER MARSH. I'M
SURE SO- DIFFICULTY WITH THIS
PROGRAM IS- THE PHARMACIST
CURRENTLY DOESN'T DO THIS TYPE
OF WORK- WE DON'T HAVE THE
INVESTIGATIVE INFRASTRUCTURE
SET UP TO DO THIS TYPE OF WORK-
WE WOULD HAVE TO HIRE NEW STAFF
AND WE HAVE A TRADING COMPONENT
IS ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR HOURS TO GET- HE'S
FLYING- TRAINING FOR THE AGENTS
TO DO THIS TYPE OF WORK AND A
PROBLEM- THAT WE'RE WE'RE
SEEING- WITH ONLY GIVEN US
PORTION OF THE FUNDING IS. I
THINK WE DON'T HAVE THE
INTERNET STRUCTURE ALREADY
WITHIN CAL B. O. THEN STARTING
IT YES PART OF IT IS- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AGENTS
BUT THERE'S SO MUCH A QUICK
MINUTE INFRASTRUCTURE WE JUST
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE TO DO THIS
TYPE OF WORK IN THIS WORK IS SO
IMPORTANT TO THE COMMUNITY IT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT THERE'S NO
ROOM FOR ERROR I MEAN THESE ARE
THE MOST COMPLEX SERIOUS CAES
THAT BUT LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN
HANDLE. AND WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT WERE SET UP TO SET UP FOR
SUCCESS AND SET UP TO HANDLE
THESE CASES APPROPRIATELY IT'S
NOT SOMETHING. THAT WE CAN-
LIMBANG TO AND STAR WITH HOW OF
THE FUNDING THAT WE NEED OR
HOUSE THE RESOURCES- THERE'S-
WE BUCK- HOLD. A LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE DIDN'T WITH- LAW
ENFORCEMENT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS A GRAVE
CONCERNS. ABOUT OUR ABILITY TO
DO WHAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THEM TO. TO HELP TRAIN US- WE
HAVE TO COLLABORATE. THE
RESOURCES THEY WERE ASKING FOR
ARE GOING TO COVER THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA NO OTHER
STATE DOES- INVESTIGATIONS FROM
BEGINNING TO END OF AN OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTING- YOU START
YOUR FRIENDS LIKE SERVICES TO
COLLECT EVIDENCE. AGENTS DOING
INVESTIGATIONS WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE ATTORNEYS PROSECUTING THE
CASES SO. THIS TYPE OF. WORK IS
LITERALLY START TO FINISH AND-
EVEN IN. THE COMING UP WITH THE
NUMBER OF CASES THAT WE ARE
ANTICIPATING HAVING EVEN
LOOKING AT THE BUDGET THE
LEGISLATION WE'RE GONNA HAVE
DIFFICULTIES FINDING WHAT CASES
ARE THAT WE'RE GONNA HANDLE ARE
NOT HANDLE- IF THE GUNS LOADED
OR UNLOADED- WE HANDLE A CASE
OR NOT HANDLE THE CASE- SO
WE'RE TRYING TO EVEN WORK
THROUGH- THE LEGISLATION WHICH
DOESN'T MATCH CALIFORNIA. PENAL
CODE LAWS SO OUR ESTIMATE OF
FORTY CASES IS A ROUGH ESTIMATE
WE GATHER THAT DATA FROM DATA
THAT WE'VE BEEN COLLECTING TO
MAYBE SEVENTY ONE- AND WE'VE
WE'VE GONE BACK TO TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN AND LOOK AT THE AMOUNT
OF OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS-
WHICH IS ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY
YEAR AND WE'VE DETERMINED
THROUGH THAT- ABOUT TWENTY OF
THOSE HUNDRED FORTY YEAR ON
ARMS. ANOTHER NINE A REPLICA
FIREARMS AND THEN ELEVEN WOULD
BE- NOT CLASSIFIED AS DEADLY
WEAPNS SO WE'RE WORKING WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT- THEY
IMPLEMENTED A STATEWIDE-
PROGRAM IS DIFFICULT WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE STATEWIDE AGENCY
BUT THE NUMBER OF PERSONNEL
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO-
DESIGNATE TOWARDS THIS PROGRAM
IS A MESS SO WE'VE DETERMINED
THAT ABOUT 60% OF THESE CASES
HAPPEN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
SO WE'RE GONNA SHIFT- SOME MORE
RESOURCES TOWARDS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AT THE HELP. HANDLE
THOSE TYPES THE CASE BUT WHICH
HAVE TO BE AVAILABLE RESPOND
ANYWHERE. IN THE STATE HELP NOT
SO MORE AND BORDER AND- WHAT
THE MOUNT PERSONNEL IT'S- GONNA
BE DIFFICULT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- SHAPE THE
THOUGHTFULNESS THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING INTO IT AHEAD OF TIME
SO TAT WE CAN BE AS SOME. AND
ONCE THE USE THE TERM
SUCCESSFUL BUT THAT WE COULD BE
AS THE DO THE WORK AS WELL AS
WE CAN SO. EIGHT THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SENATORS. OKAY. I
THINK THAT'S IT ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS BY ANYBODY. NO OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER RYAN AND-
EVERYBODY BUT WE'RE MOVING ON
TO ISSUE SIX OUR BUREAU
FORENSIC SERVICES. JERRY THIS
IS CHRIS RYAN OF THE FALCONS OF
JUSTICE AGAIN. AND- THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT'S BEEN AROUND FOR A
FEW YEARS IT IS WITH THE
NETWORK ISSUE. YOUR BROTHER
SERVICE PROPOSAL THE PROPOSAL
RELATED TO A BACK ROOM HERE
TODAY- IT WAS THIS MORNING ARE
YOU HEARING IMPAIRED FINANCE
THAT DESCRIBE THE FINE HE- HE
SHE THAT WOULD SENIOR PROSTATE
AND FRIENDLY EVER SINCE THE
LAST SERVICES. YEAH HE FIRED-
IS A FIND THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THAT PASSED YEARS.
HAVE WITHIN. AFTER I CAN SPEAK
TO VERY SMALL. WEAKENS EVERY.
ON BEHALF OF INDIAN AFFAIRS AS
IT RELATES TO THE PROPOSED- THE
SIX NATIONALLY AND THE LACK OF.
THE CRAP OUT OF PROPOSAL WELL
UNTIL AND- ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE OF LATE BECAUSE OF
THESE COUPLE LINES. OKAY ALL
RIGHT THE MISLI L. A. O. WHAT
THE L. A. L. WE HAVE FOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR YOU ON THIS
ITEM- FIRST WE ARE RECOMMENDING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
THE PROPOSED BACKFILL BUT ONLY
FOR TWO YEARS IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
SUFFICIENT REVENUES AND THE
FINGERPRINT FEES ACCOUNT- WHICH
IS AN ACCOUNT THAT WILL BE USED
TO BACK FILL A PORTION OF
DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING SHIFTED
OVER TO THE BUREAU OF FORENSIC
SERVICES- AND THIS IS BECAUSE
THE EVENUES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEPOSITED INTO THIS ACCOUNT-
HAS BEEN LOWER. AS OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
THE FINE COULD BECOME INSOLVENT
IN A COUPLE YEARS OF THE
REVENUES DON'T INCREASE AND SO
BY APPROVING IT ONLY FOR TWO
YEARS IT IT IT HELPS ENSURE
THAT THERE IS SUFFICIENT FUNDS
AND THAT SPECIAL FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. IT WOULD ALSO
PROVIDE THE BUREAU WITH
SUFFICIENT FUNDING WALL OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR NEW FUNDING
FRAMEWORK- ARE GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED. SOURCE SECOND
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THE LEGISLATURE
IMPLEMENTED NEW FUNDING
FRAMEWORK BY REQUIRING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PARTIALLY
SUPPORT THE BUREAU BEGINNING IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR GIVEN
THE SUBSTANTIAL BENEFIT THAT
CERTAIN LOCAL AGENCIES ARE
CURRENTLY RECEIVING FROM THE
BUREAU PROVIDING SERVICES AT NO
CHARGE TO AGENCIES LOCAL
AGENCIES IN ABOUT FORTY SIX
COUNTIES. AND THE REQUIRING
LOCAL AGENCIES CONTRIBUTE A
PORTION- FOR THE SERVICES THAT
THEY RECEIVE WILL ALSO PROVIDE
GREATER INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO
PRIORITIZE THE WORKLOAD THAT IS
BEING SUBMITTED TO DOJ IT WOULD
ALSO REDUCE THE NEED FOR
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. OUR THIRD
RECOMMENDATION IS HERE TO HELP
WITH THIS FUNDING FRAMEWORK WE
RECOMMEND THE EGISLATURE
REQUIRE DOJ DEVELOP AND REPORT
ON A PLAN NO LATER THAN OCTOBER
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR
CALCULATING EACH LOCAL AGENCIES
SHARE BASED ON THE SERVICES
IT'S USING. SO THIS PROVIDES
DOJ WITH THE FLEXIBILITY TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
DEVELOP THE SPECIFICS OF THE
NEW FUNDING FRAMEWORK SUCH AS
WHETHER YOU KNOW THE AGENCY
SHARE WILL DIFFER BASED ON THE
TYPE OF FORENSIC SERVICE THAT'S
BEING REQUESTED THE SPEED OF
THE SERVICE OR THE SIZE OF THE
AGENCY. OUR FOURTH AND FINAL
RECOMMENDATION IS IN LIGHT OF
THIS NEW FUNDING FRAMEWORK THAT
WE'RE RECOMMENDING WE DO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECTED THE PROPOSED NEW
FACILITY UNTIL IT IS
IMPLEMENTED. AND THE REASON FOR
THIS IS THE NEW FUNDING
FRAMEWORK WHICH INCENTIVIZE
LOCAL AGENCIES TO FIND THEIR
CAUGHT THEIR LAB SERVICES AND
OBTAIN THEM IN THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE WAY. POSSIBLE WHICH
COULD IMPACT THE WORK WITH
BEING SENT TO DOJ AND SAID TO
THE EXTENT THAT. THE WORKLOAD
IN THE ORGANIZATION OF THE
GIRLFRIEND'S EX SERVICES
CHANGES IT COULD CHANGE THE
NEED FOR THE PROPOSED FACILITY.
SO THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS FOR. OKAY NOBODY
ELSE NOBODY ELSE OKAY. I'M
SORRY. OF ONE. SORRY MR
WHATEVER YOU KEEP YOUR HANDS UP
AND I KEEP IGNORING YOU. K.
RESPONSE SEVENTY BE AGAINST YOU
EITHER DON'T FEEL. ABOUT THE
ACTUALLY THE BACKFILL SO AS WE
TRAVERSED NAME IS VERY SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE HAD EARLIER THIS
MORNING WITH RESTITUTION FINES
IN THAT THE UNITED STATES FUND.
I REFUSE BEEN GOING DOWN LAST
YEAR'S WE HAD TO DO GENERAL
FUND BACKS BILLS. ANALYSTS NOTE
THAT ADD THIS BACK ON SOME OF
THE REST YO CAN FIND IT WILL
BE ADJUSTED EACH YEAR TO THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS BASED ON
ACTUAL REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES. ONE OTHER NOTE-
ON THE RECOMMENDATION MANY
OTHERS HAVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PERSONALLY SUPPORTS AND THE
BFS. WE DO A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED BECAUSE THEY COULD
HAVE A NEGATIVE EFFECT ON
SMALLER COUNTIES TO HAVE A
DIFFICULT TIME PAINS STATE FOR
SERVICES. AND WE'RE A LITTLE
WORRIED THAT IT COULD
INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES TO
PRIORITIZE MISSION EVIDENCE
THEY CANCELED BECAUSE- YOUR- I
AGREE WITH YOU ON ON THAT LEVEL
LAST ONE- ESPECIALES KIND OF
SERVICES ARE SO IMPORTANT CAN I
ASK YOU OR ANYONE. OTHER THAN
THE COUNTY. WHAT OTHER ENTITY
COULD POSSIBLY BE TAPPED TO
PARTIALLY PAY FOR THE SERVICES
I THINK WE HAVE A OPINION ON
THE. MILLER MIGHT BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THAT I THINK WAS ALL
HAVING A HARD TIME FINDING THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FUTURE. IT IS A
LITTLE OLD SCHOOL. OKAY YEAH
YES GO AHEAD MR MILLER. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- WITH THE QUESTION
BEING OTHER THAN- THE COUNTY
BEING A SOURCE OF INCOME
THEY'RE ACTUALLY BUT A LOT OF
STUDIES- THROUGHOUT THE NATION
AND INTERNATIONALLY REGARDING
WHERE THESE BONDS CAN COME FROM
AND THOSE STUDIES HAVE INCLUDED
THINGS LIKE THE ONLY-
RECOMMENDED YOU FOR SERVICE A
COST SHARING. AND THOSE LONG
BEEN REJECTED BY VARIOUS STATE
TEXAS IDAHO JUST MENTION A
COUPLE- AND THE ONES THAT HAVE-
TRYING TO IMPLEMENT SOMETHING
LIKE THAT ACTUALLY FIND THAT
THEY HAVE A VERY LARGE
COLLECTION POOL SUCH AS
MISSISSIPPI WHERE THEY HAVE A
LOT OF MONEY THAT IS- NO. NO
LONGER BEING PAID TO THE STATE
EVEN THOUGH IT DOES SET OUT
THERE AS- SOMETHING THAT THEY
NEED TO COLLECT FROM THE COUNTY
AND IT IS- MISTER RYAN ALLUDED
TO. WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL
DIFFERENT AVENUES BUT RIGHT NOW
THIS IS THE SITUATION WE FIND
OURSELVES AND IS THAT THE
GENERAL FUND BACKFILL IS WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR BECAUSE THERE
IS THAT SAME CONCERN ABOUT
SMALLER COUNTIES AND SMALLER
POPULATIONS ABILITY TO PAY%
GETTING. EQUAL ACCESS TO THAT
JUST. MMHM THANK ANYONE GIVE ME
A IT OF WHAT THE ACTUAL
CONCRETE IMPACT WOULD BE- IN A
COMMUNITY. IF THEY COULD IF
THEY COULD NOT- IF THEY COULD
NOT OR WOULD NOT- PAY INTO- PAY
FOR THESE COSTS. I'M SURE VERY
MILLER AGAIN- THE I THINK WE
ACTUALLY HAVE EXAMPLES OF THIS
AND ONE OF THEM IS THAT WHEN WE
DID OUR RESEARCH FOR AN
ASSESSMENT THAT I PROVIDED TO
THE LEGISLATURE. HE ONE OF THE
AREAS THAT WE LOOKED AT WAS
ACTUALLY A POLICE DEPARTMENT
THAT DOES HAVE A FEE FOR
SERVICE. MODEL WITH THEIR LOCAL
AGENCIES AND WE FOUND THAT
THERE WERE MANY SEXUAL ASSAULT
EVIDENCE KITS THAT HAD NOT BEEN
TURNED IN OR ANALYZED BECAUSE
THE LOCAL AGENCY DIDN'T FEEL
LIKE THEY CAN AFFORD. THE
SERVICE AND SO WE DO SEE THAT.
AS A POSSIBILITY THAT THOSE
TYPES OF EVIDENCE COULD BE
EITHER NOT TURNED IN BASED ON
AN AGENCY MAKING FUNDING
DECISIONS. THAT DON'T
NECESSARILY SUPPORT BEST
EVIDENCE. OR THEY DECIDE THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO TAKETHE
TIME TO INVESTIGATE A CRIME
THAT COULD LEAD TO THE SOLVING
OF OTHER CRIMES IN A DATABASE
THAT ARE UP. BECAUSE THEY CHOSE
NOT STERN. MMHM OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF. C. I HEARD- LOOK
AT THE OTHER OPTIONS OKAY. THE
CAMPUS CONSOLIDATION. COULD
SOMEONE SPEAK TO THAT AND
EXPLAIN THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE
WITH THE TIME LINE WOULD BE
AND- AND THE IMPACT ON ON ON
RICHMOND. YEAH MILLER MEDICARE.
MR MILLER SAYS I'M SURE VERY
MILLER AGAIN. SO THE
CONSOLIDATION OF WE'RE LOOKING
AT IS ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT
IS THAT IS BEING WORKED ON
SENSE. ABOUT TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND TWO- THE RICHMOND
FACILITY WHEN DNA STARTED TO
BECOME. MORE AND MORE
INTEGRATED INTO GRANTS SIX. WAS
LOCATED IN BERKELEY AND THEY
WERE MOVED TO THE RICHMOND
FACILITY WHILE WE WERE PLANNING
A LARGE SCALE CAMPUS IN
SACRAMENTO TO HOUSE ALL OF THE
DNA AND LOCAL SACRAMENTO
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING B.
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL CRIME LAB
THE CALIFORNIA CRIMINALISTICS
INSTITUTE. THE CURRENT DNA DATA
BANK IN RICHMOND AS WELL AS ALL
OF THE IN A CASE WORKING CRIME
SCENE RESPONSE FUNCTIONS THAT
ARE IN THAT AREA. WE ALSO
CENTRALIZED TALKS APOLOGY WHICH
IS THE DRUG TOXICOLOGY UNIT IN
SACRAMENTO BADS PROVIDE SERVICE
FOR ALL OF THE COUNTIES THAT WE
SERVE. WE ALSO HAVE A
HEADQUARTERS UNIT- WHICH I'M A
PART OF IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
TOGETHER IN THIS CONSOLIDATED
FACILITY IN PARTNERSHIP. WITH
SOME OF OUR STATE PARTNERS
BEING UC'S AND THE ISSUES RIGHT
NOW WE'RE TALKING TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
BECAUSE ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE HAVE IS MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE A GOOD. CANDIDATES AND
INTERNS THAT WE CAN RUN THROUGH
THE PROGRAM SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
WORKING WITH THEIR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO. WORK IN
COLLABORATION TO GET THAT
ROLLING. AS FAR AS THE AFFECT
ON RICH. B. RICHMOND STAFF-
MANY OF THEM DON'T ACTUALLY
LIVE IN THE RICHMOND AREA A LOT
OF THEM ARE DISPERSED
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA AND I
DO HAVE SOME THAT LIVE IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA THANK YOU MUTE
THE DAILY BASIS OUT OF RICHMOND
AS THE COST OF LIVING. SO THE
RICHMOND STAFF WILL BE
RELOCATED WITH CELERY AND WE'VE
DONE SOME- LOOKS INTO WHAT THAT
WOULD LOOK LIKE AND THEY BE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY KNOWING
FULL WELL THAT THIS IS A
SEVERAL YEARS DOWN THE ROAD TO
ADJUST TO HOW WE'RE GOING TO.
GO BACK TO SLEEP TOGETHER- IS
THERE ALREADY. AN AGREEMENT
WITH THE CSU SACRAMENTO. AS FAR
AS A SPECIFIC AGREEMENT RIGHT
NOW WE ARE PART OF THEIR MASTER
PLANNING PROCESS THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES- PUBLICLY HAS APPROVED
A SPECIAL LEAST AGO SITUATION
WITH DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES OR A PLOT OF LAND THAT
IS NEAR THE SACRAMENTO STATE
CAMPUS BUT THOSE ARE STILL IN
THE PRELIMINARY PLANNING BASIS.
AND DID YOU THINK ABOUT- DOING
THE- CONSOLIDATING THE
OPERATIONS WITHOUT CLOSING DOWN
THE RICHMOND. OF CAMPUS. YES WE
DID- MADAM CHAIR WE LOOKED AT
SEVERAL DIFFERENT OPTIONS AND
HOLDING A RICHMOND CAMPUS IS
ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR US
BECAUSE YEAR BY YEAR THE COSTS
RELATED TO THE LEAST ABOUT
PROPERTY. ARE ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ALSO LOOKED AT HIS THE
STATE BEING ONE OF THE LESS
COMPETITIVE SALARIES IN THE
STATE HAS A LOT OF COMPETITION
FORENSICS IN THE BAY AREA WERE-
LOCALS THAT ATE A LOT MORE FOR
THE FRENCH SCIENTISTS. THE COST
OF LIVING IS HIGHER AND SO IT
WAS CONTRARY TO OUR GOAL OF
ACTUALLY BRINGING ALL OF THOSE
THINGS TOGETHER INCLUDING THE
DNA FACILITIES IN THE DNA DATA
BANK INTO A MORE COST EFFECTIVE
AREA WHERE WE CAN HAVE A
GREATER COLLABORATION WITH OUR
STATE PARTNERS. AN OF FINALLY
WHAT IS THE TIMELINE THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION THAT I'M SURE
THE TIMELINE RIGHT NOW IS
ANYWHERE FROM FOUR TO FIVE
YEARS MOST LIKELY ON FIVE YEARS
AS LONG AS EVERY STEP ALONG THE
WAY IS APPROPRIATELY GROUP. I'M
SORRY FORTY FIVE YEARS MEANING
THAT'S WHEN IT'LL BE BUILT OR
MEANING. YOU WILL START. I'M
SORRY ABOUT A JOB THAT WOULD BE
A MOVE IN DATE. A MOVE IN DATE
OF. HELLO MR MEDRANO. GO AHEAD
I COULD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
JUDGES TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
TIMELINE SO WE ARE REQUESTING
FUNDING FOR PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA AND IF APPROVED AT THE
TIME WHEN WOULD BE THAT WE
WOULD BEGIN PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA ON JULY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- WITH ANTICIPATED
COMPLETION ON SEPARATE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AFTER IT IF WE
APPROVED FOR PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA WE WITH THAT ASK FOR
DESIGN BUILD MONEY AND THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO BUDGET AND
WITH BEGIN CONSTRUCTION AFTER
PERFORMANCE CRITERIA IS DONE
AFTER FEBRUARY TWENTY YET
DISSIPATE. LIKE VERY SAID
AROUND FIVE YEARS. AND WHAT DO
YOU AND- THE TOTAL COST. SO THE
TOTAL COST IS SO WE HAVE SIX
POINT FIVE FOR THE PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA AND THEN WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION OR- WITH
PUBLIC BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTION.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATORS ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS VERY NON- THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE-
YOUR WORK ON THIS. MOVIE NON TO
ISSUE SEVEN. HEALTH CARE RIGHTS
AND ACCESS WORKLOAD. THERE
CHRIS RYAN THE PHARMACIST SOLVE
YOU HAVE FREE PHOBIA AND THEN I
HAVE- RUNNING THE DEALERSHIP
TIMES ARE SUPERVISOR. HAS THE
SECOND. THIS FOR BOTH WILL NEED.
ANOTHER PHONE. AS WELL PRESENT
AS PART LAST BUDGET. DURING THE
NAY. LAST YEAR. IT WAS ONE OF
THE I THAT THE GENERAL FUND OF
THE SITE. OBSTACLES THAT WILL
REMOVED- AND THEN AND GENERAL
FUND THAT TIME- SO WE COME BACK
WITH THE RIVER. WITH AN ALTERED
FUNDING I- THE PUBLIC RIGHTS
DIVISION THEY HAVE ONES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO BE THIS WORK.
AND SO THIS PROPOSAL IS TO- YOU
COME BACK AND ASKING FOR THAT
AUTHORITY- AND DECISIONS ABOUT
TWO POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS I
TO GIVE YOU AN UPDATE ON THE
RESOURCE WE GOT LAST YEAR- WE
HAVE. BASICALLY HIRED ALL THE
POSITIONS EXCEPT ONE DAG AND I
THINK YOU SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST-
AND RUNNING I CAN GIVE YOU
UPDATES ON THE DETAIL WORK
WHETHER WE'RE DOING ESSENTIALLY
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD HELP ENACT
ANTI COMPETITIVE MARKET AND
ENSURING THAT THE HEALTHCARE
MARKET REMAINS AFFORDABLE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. WOULD THAT
WORK. THANK YOU. BUT I'M SORRY
MR COULD YOU COULD SEE- THE-
THE NEW FOR THE ADDITION PER.
YES MA'AM JERRY TO THE PART OF
A GROUP FROM YEAR THAT WAS NOT
APPROVED- IT WAS CONDITIONS
ABOUT TWO MILLION DOLLARS I WAS
THE GENERAL FUND REQUEST LAST
YEAR- AT THE TIME IT WAS
GENERAL FUND WAS IN CRISIS
MODE- SO WE CAN GET THE
PROPOSAL THROUGH WITH SOME
SPECIAL FUNDS. AND SO THIS YEAR
WE'RE COMING FORWARD ASKING FOR
THE ARTS THAT RELATE TO OUR
GENERAL FUND THAT WE'RE ASKING
TO USE A SPECIAL FUNDS.
TRANSITIONS IN THE WORKLOAD
THAT THEY WOULD DO IS RELATED
TO THE ANTI COMPETITIVE ASPECTS
OF THE HEALTHCARE MARKET- I RAN
I GOT COULD ANSWER MORE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT.
MATTERS IN THE FACE YOU-
REDEKER MISTER JOE. YEAH IF YOU
CAN JUST GIVE A THE- AN EXAMPLE
OF WHAT THE WHAT THE NEED IS.
YES MADAM CHAIR- AS MR RYAN
MENTIONED- ONE OF THE MANY
THINGS THAT THE SECTION DOES IS
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS A
PROPER COMPETITION WITHIN THE
MARKETPLACE. I THINK YOU SEE
THIS IN IN VARIOUS DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THE MARKET ONE OF
THE BIGGEST ISSUES AND THAT IS
OF THE GREATEST CONCERN IS OVER
CONSOLIDATION WITHIN HEALTHCARE
MARKET WHICH THEN DRIVES UP
COSTS. AND SO WE HAVE SEEN- WE
HAVE SEEN AND OVER THE LAST
YEAR ESPECIALLY AN UPTAKE IN
THE AMOUNT OF ONE CONSOLIDATION
WITHIN HEALTHCARE FACILITIES-
DUE IN PART I. TO HAVE THE
TRAIN IN GENERAL IN THE
MARKETPLACE AND ALSO- LIKELY AS
A RESULT OF THE CODED PANDEMIC-
AND THE CONCERN. WHEN THERE'S
AN UPTAKE IN CONSOLIDATION IS
THAT YOU END UP WITH- BEING
BILL HE NEXT MUCH LIKE SATTAR
I'M AS I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE
MADAM CHAIR OF BOMB WE- THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE WAS
RECENTLY IT'S A QUITE
SUCCESSFUL. IN BRINGING ON A
LAWSUIT AND THEN ULTIMATELY A
SETTLEMENT- AGAINST AT CENTER
FOR ITS ANTI COMPETITIVE
PRACTICES AND SO WITH INCREASED
RESOURCES WE BELIEVE THAT WE
WILL BE ABLE TO. CONTINUE TO
CONDUCT COMPETITIVE IMPACT
ANALYSIS FOR- THESE
TRANSACTIONS AS AS THEY HAVE
COME TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE FOR REVIEW- TO CONTINUE
TO OVERSEE AT THE CENTER
SETTLEMENT- WITH WERE REQUIRED
TO MONITOR AFTER EACH OF THE
NEXT TEN YEARS. AND TO
INVESTIGATE AND BRING SUITS
AGAINST OTHER LARGE SYSTEMS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEGUN TO
MIMIC I CENTERS ANTI
COMPETITIVE BEHAVIOR I'M IN IT.
WITH OUR CURRENT RESOURCES
UNFORTUNATELY HRA WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE ARM AT ALL IN
THAT THIRD BACK AND I THINK YOU
INCREASINGLY WE'RE EVEN SEEING
A LOT OF- THAT RESOURCE IS
BEING BEING TAKEN OUT BY. AT
TRANSACTION REVIEW WHICH WERE
REQUIRED TO DO UNDER THE
CORPORATIONS. ON THE OTHER AREA
OF ANTI COMPETITION WHERE WE
ARE I'M SEEING ADDITIONAL NEED
FOR RESOURCES AND WORK WITHIN
COMPETITION IS IN
PHARMACEUTICAL DRUG PRICING- IN
ORDER TO BRING. THAT CASE. IS
I'M- AGAIN STAFF PHARMACY COME
THAT ENGAGE. AND TRUMP- BE LIKE
PAPER TO GREEN- IN TO LOOK AT
IT AND READ IT WHILE. AND BY
FARMS BENEFIT MANAGERS THAT ARE
ARE RESULTING IN. HIGHER DRUG
PRICES- WE DO NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ON THESE CASES BEGAN
AS AN INVESTIGATION WITH ONE OR
TWO DADS BUT THEN AS THEY- YOU
KNOW APPROACH TRIAL YOU NEED AN
ENTIRE TEAM- SO WE THINK WITH
CURRENT RESOURCES WE WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO ENGAGE IN AN
ADDITIONAL PHARMACEUTICAL DRUG
PRICING. MATTERS FORM
INSTIGATING PBMS FOR INSTANCE.
WONDERFUL OKAY THANK YOU ALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SHADE ALL
YOUR WORK. MOVING ON TO ISSUE
EIGHT CONTINUATION OF CURES TO
HELP DESK RESOURCES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE MISTER
RENDER YES THIS IS RYAN YEAH
AND I THINK HE MAY HAVE- FROM-
I HELP MY PRORAM IS ON BUT I
THINK THEY MAY HAVE GOTTEN BACK
AND GOOD DIFFICULTY IS THAT
THIS IS A REIMBURSEMENT
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE PARTIES
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT YOU CAN
REPAIRS HI HAS RELATES YOU MUST
PROVIDING- HELP DESK- PHARMACY
DOCTORS WILL FIND A LOT OF.
THAT STUFF- AGAIN IT'S A
REIMBURSABLE GOING INTO OUR
LOCATION AND I THINK THIS ONE
FOR SOME TIME AND BELIEVES THAT
THESE RESOURCES WILL HELP PAY
FOR THOSE POSITIONS THAT STAFF
TO HELP OUT. WITH THAT AWFUL
TURNED THANK YOU FOR. FROM WITH
THE LA LIKE TO COMMENT. IDEALLY
WITH THE L. L. WE DON'T HAVE
CONCERNS ON THIS PROPOSAL OR
THE PRIOR ONE EITHER. WHO DID I
MISS YOU ON THAT SORRY. WELL
THAT WAS LIKE IT DANNY FOR ME
LAST THANK. OKAY OF MR WEBER I
SEE THE HAND. THANK YOU THANK
YOU I REMEMBER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO CONCERNS ON THIS ONE
OR THE ONE CRACK OKAY THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH ON
THIS- WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE NINE.
OR BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS. INCREASED TITLE TO
SPENDING AUTHORITY. WHO WISHES.
GOOD AFTERNOON- I'M KATIE
HOWARD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE B. S. E. C. CAN YOU HEAR ME
ALRIGHT YES RETIRED GOOD TO SEE
YOU GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN THANK
SENATOR- GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M KATIE HOWARD I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS AND I'M JOINED
TODAY BY MY COLLEAGUE RECORD OF
GOOD RIDGE WHO'S HERE TO ANSWER
ANY DETAILED QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE- JUST VERY QUICKLY THE
TITLE TO PROPOSAL ON THE AGENDA
AS IS NOTED- IS A FEDERAL GRANT
THAT FOCUSES ON JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IMPROVEMENT- AND
THE BSP SAID MINISTERS THIS
GRANT. IT'S A GOVERNOR
APPOINTED A COMMITTEE THAT-
CARRIES OUT THE WORK THE WORK
OF THE GRANT AND THAT COMMITTEE
THE STATE ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND
DELINQUENCY PREVENTION- HAS A
PROPOSAL FOR- ANY- OF CONTRACT
TO- GO OUT FOR BID FOR- IT'S A
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR INCREASE IN
FEDERAL SPENDING SORRY AND IT
REQUIRES THAT WOMEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE IS TO INCREASE OUR
FEDERALS- SPENDING AUTHORITY
ONLY THERE'S NO IMPACT ON THE
GENERAL FUND. SO THE INCREASE
SPENDING AUTHORITY WILL ALLOW
US TO DRAW DOWN ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR THIS
CONTRACT I GOT AHEAD OF MYSELF
BECAUSE THE CONTRACT IS A
REALLY WONDERFUL IDEA- THE-
STATE ADVISORY COMMITTEE HAS-
PROPOSAL THAT WILL FOCUS ON
RECENT REDUCING RACIAL AND
ETHNIC DISPARITIES IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM- IT'S
GOING TO BE AN ASSESSMENT OF
COUNTY INTERVENTIONS THAT
RESULT IN THE REDUCTION OF
DISPARITIES AND IN ADDITION THE
IDENTIFICATION OF CHALLENGES
AND BARRIERS THAT MAY EXIST
WITHIN THE COUNTY JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. SO WITH YOUR
APPROVAL TODAY WE WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO- ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
DOLLARS FOR THIS SPECIFIC
PURPOSE AND THAT'S WHAT THE BCP
IS ABOUT LIKE I SAID MY
COLLEAGUE RICARDO IS HERE. IF
YOU HAVE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
GOOD TWO ONE AS ANYTHING. BY
THIS TIME THANK YOU OKAY
WELCOME- AND THE ALEJO. MISS
O'NEILL EVEN ON YOUR THE L. A.
L. WE DIDN'T RAISE CONCERNS ON
THIS PROPOSAL OKAY. EASY PEASY
ALRIGHT WE'RE A STAFF
RECOMMENDS- TO HOLD OPEN. AND
WHERE NOW SAID IT. OH MY
GOODNESS. IRWIN JONES FROM
BEGINNING TO LIKE THIS ROOM
HERE. OKAY NEGATIVE FIVE. THIS.
OKAY BORN THANK YOU EVERYBODY
HERE WE GO- WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR ITEMS RELATED TO
PART TO BE OF THE AGENDA AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN SIX ZERO NINE DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS THAT CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS
REINSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M ASKING THAT
EACH MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
PROVIDING COMIC KEEP THEIR
REMARKS TO WITHIN ONE MINUTE.
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM SEEN NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEN NONE. OF WE WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK
YOU HELLO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO PROVIDE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO AND OUR FIRST PUBLIC
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR. YES
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHIANG COMMITTEE MEMBER WANTED
ME GELBART YEAH AND I REPRESENT
THE ENTIRE ACTIVISM COALITION
AND I AM SPEAKING ON ISSUE
THREE THE OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION AS A
YOUNG PERSON COMMITTED A SEVEN
OH SEVEN B. OFFENSE AND WITH
THANK YEARS THANK YOU CAN
PETITIONS IN CALIFORNIA I
RECOGNIZE THE NEED OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY NOW MORE
THAN EVER. CALIFORNIANS
BOARDING CLOSING DOWN ARE YOU
PREGNANT IT'S CRITICAL CRITICAL
THAT OUR STATE SUPPORT THE-
LIKE YOU ARE WHICH IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING THE
TRAINING OF ALL YOU IN TO GET
IT DONE IN A HIGHER STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO NOW REMAIN UNDER
COUNTY CARE ACCORDING TO THE
MOST RECENT DATA AVAILABLE.
SIXTY THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
OF PARTICULAR KNOWLEDGE AND
ANNUALLY THE O. LIKE HE I NEED
MORE STAFFING FUND IS ABILITY
TO OVERSEE THE TREATMENT OF ALL
YOU NEED YOU CAN ADJUST THEM TO
ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY OVER ALL
CAN LEVEL INVESTMENT NOW FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY. CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING BOARD HAD FIVE TIMES THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY PROPOSED FOR
THE- LIKE THE OCT THE PROPOSAL
ONLY HAD THREE PEOPLE TO BUILD
ON THE NEW JERSEY AND FOR
EXAMPLE TECH THE TAX THIRTEEN
FULL TIME EMPLOYEE FOR SOMEONE
NUMBER OF FERTILITY. THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THE CONSIDERATION AND I HOPE
YOU HAVE A GREAT DAY. HE SAID.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN. NEXT
MODERATE NEXT PUBLIC. AND NEXT
PUBLIC COMMENT COME FROM LINES
NINE WE'VE AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
SUPER RAIL FROM THE PACIFIC
JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER AND I
AM ON THE CHAU WELFARE COUNCIL
STRUCK. FOR THE- WHY C. R. AND
I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO THAT
ITEM NUMBER THREE. THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR- I SEE ARE THE
GOOD START BUT IT NEEDS TO BE
AUGMENTED TO ASSURE ADEQUATE
STAFF TO FULFILL ITS MISSION
HIGHLY SKILLED STAFF. AND
GUIDELINES FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF ITS STATUTORY MISSION
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY TO THE-OMBUDSMAN BUDGET THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO STATE LEVEL
COMPLAINT PROCESS FOR YOU
EXPERIENCING MISTREATMENT IN
JUVENILE FACILITIES AND THE
PROPOSAL TO LIMIT THE PROCESS
ONLY TO USE. INVOLVED IN
CERTAIN KINDS OF OFFENSES MAKES
ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE. THERE WERE
SIXTEEN THOUSAND YOU FIFTEEN
TONIGHT TWENTY NINETEEN OF THE
STAFFING LEVEL IS CLEARLY
INADEQUATE EARLIER TODAY WE
HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE I
REQUEST RECALLS MORE POSITIONS
TO HANDLE MISCONDUCT COMPLAINTS
IN JUST ONE PRISON. NOW AT THE
VERY BEGINNING OF LAUNCHING
THIS LONG NEEDED AGENCY THIS IS
THE TIME TO FRONT LOAD IT TO
MAKE SURE IT SUCCEEDS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NEXT. AND OUR NEXT
PUBLIC COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
FORTY FOUR IF GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MORE WHEN A FATHER MY
NAME IS A VERY BEYOND REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY JUSTICE I'M
ALSO GIVING COMMON ON ISSUE
THREE TOP THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION. THE
TOPIC NEED MORE STAFFING IN
FORTY TWO A BILL IS TO OVERSEE
THE TRIMMING OF ALL OF OUR
YOUTH IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS SADDENED ME. TO KNOW
THAT ARE CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING BOARD HAS FIVE TIMES THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY PROPOSED FOR
THIS CRITICAL OFFICE. ALTHOUGH
HORSES ARE IMPORTANT VALUES OUR
CHILDREN ARE MORE SACRED. THE
CREATION OF ALL OF ALL Y. C. R.
AS MONUMENTAL. THE COSBY EIGHTY
THREE NORTH TO INSTILL IS
POSSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING AND
PROMOTING BEST PRACTICE FOR THE
CARE AND CUSTODY OF YOUTH
IMPACTED BY THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
I URGE YOU TO ALLOCATE THE
PROPER DO FUNDING TO ENSURE
THEY INTENDED THE LAW. AND
THERE'S BE A TO THREE BEING MET
IN FULL. ALSO IF I MAY
REGARDING THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
PROBATION- I STRONGLY ADVOCATE
AGAINST APPROVING SUCH AS ALL
COUNTY A PROBATION DEPARTMENTS
ARE RECEIVING A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES. BECAUSE OF
SB EIGHTY THREE RATHER FORESEEN
FURTHER RESOURCING PROBATIONERS
ADMINISTRATION AND THIS
IMPORTANT COMMITTEE TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INVEST IN
INTERVENTION PREVENTION AND
DIVERSION BE A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES WERE BETTER EQUIPPED
THAN HELPING OUR CHILDREN AND
KEEPING OUR CHILDREN AWAY FROM
THE U. QUESTION SYSTEM. WHICH
UNTIL ABOUT THE THIRD TIME.
GOOD I SAYS THAT'S OFTEN. NEX
INTERNET PUBLIC COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JOSH
DUGGAR REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
AND COUNTY WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE PROBATION
RELATED FUNNY I DIDN'T TODAY
THE DIFFICULT TO FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED FOR COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT TO PREPARE
FOR EXACTLY IMPLEMENT DJJ
REALIGNMENT AND AB NINETEEN
FIFTY. THESE RESOURCES ARE
CRITICAL FOR COUNTY TO PREPARE
TO PRODUCE SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES
WITH THE ULNERABLE BJJ
POPULATION THAT INCLUDES SOME
OF THE MOST ACUTE CASES IN THE
STATE. ADDITIONALLY THE TWELVE
POINT ONE MILLION FOR EARLY
RELEASES TO PR YES IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION OF THE
STATE'S PRIOR COMMITMENT TO
FUNDING THE IMPACT TO THE PRC
ESCALATION RESULTING FROM NEW
STATE POLICY DECISIONS. THESE
RESOURCES ARE ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT IN THIS PANDEMIC
ENVIRONMENT AS WE ALL SHARE A
HEIGHTENED INTEREST IN SHARING
OFFENDERS ARE NOT RELEASED
HOMELESSNESS AS A RESULT OF
TRYING TO REDUCE THE PRISON
POPULATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES TODAY. THANK
YOU FOR CALLING NEXT. ALL RIGHT
NOW PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOMINIQUE NOW
BEEN DIRECTOR OF YOUTH JUSTICE
POLICY THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROVIDE
COMMENT ON ISSUE THREE THE
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION. BUDGET PROPOSAL
SUBMITTED BY HHS IS CONCERNING
THE BASED ON MISINTERPRETATIONS
OF BOTH THE INTENT AND WRITTEN
A LOT REGARDING A WIFE ER THAT
HAS LED TO GROWTH UNDER
ESTIMATES ABOUT THE STAFFING
AND RESOURCES NEEDED. ALONG
WITH MANY OTHER PARTNERS I JUST
MET A LETTER DETAILING SEVERAL
CONCERNS WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
ABOUT PROPOSAL CONCERNED THAT
DO A LOT OF THE CONCERNED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MADE EARLIER
WELL FOCUS ON ONE MAJOR POINT
TODAY AT THE FORMAL CIVIL
RIGHTS ATTORNEY WHO
INVESTIGATED THE PRESENT
CONDITION AND AN ADVOCATE NOW
ALL TOO FAMILIAR WITH THE
PEOPLE CONDITIONS AND
INADEQUATE PROGRAMMING INSIDE
THE FACILITIES. I CANNOT
OVERSTATE HOW WHOLLY
INSUFFICIENT TO STAFF MEMBERS
EVEN IF THEY ARE SUPPORTED BY
OTHER STAFF MEMBER THE ONE
ATTORNEY IT IS. TWO PEOPLE WITH
INSUFFICIENT FOR NINETEEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY USED THE
NUMBER USED BY HHS WELL THERE
ARE MANY PROBLEMS THAT HAVE THE
NUMBER WITH YOU RIGHT THAT I
SIMPLY ITERATE ONE OF THE
NUMBERS SHARED BY THE CHAIR IN
TWENTY NINETEEN ALONE SIXTEEN
THOUSAND YOU PARTICULARLY
DETAILED. FAR MORE THAN THE
NUMBER GIVEN BY HHS DID YOU
KNOW THAT CALM IS IMPORTANT
TECHNIPFMC PAUL KIND OF PLEA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR CALLING NEXT AND- MODERATED
COULD YOU TELL ME HOW MANY-
PRESENTERS. SURE WE RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE- SEVEN MORE P. WAIT TO
GET PUBLIC COMP OKAY NEXT. OUR
NEXT- COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME WITH
SOME OF OUR MEETING I REPRESENT
RESILIENCE ORANGE COUNTY AND
I'M GIVING COMMENT ON ISSUE
NUMBER THREE. THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION. CURRENTLY THE
OFFICE OF YOU CAN COMMUNITY
BRITAIN RESTORATION BUDGET AND
STAFFING PROPOSAL INCLUDES
RESOURCES. FOR NINETEEN FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES AND THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
GROUP ONE ONE MILLION AND THEN
ONGOING GENERAL FUND. WITHOUT
MISSION OPERATE THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
THIS IS NOT ENOUGH. THE OFFICE
OF COMMUNITY YOU CAN
RESTORATION NEEDS MORE STAFF
AND FUNDING TO FULFILL ITS DUTY
TO OVERSEE THEIR TREATMENT OF
ALL YOUTH IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THE INTENTION
ALL WHY C. R. IT'S TO PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED ACCOUNTABILITY OVER
THE COUNTER COUNTY LEVEL
INVESTMENT IN A CONTINUUM
APPROACHES IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE. IT
IS UNBELIEVABLE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD
HAS FIVE TIMES THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY PROPOSED. FOR ALL WHITE
THE ARM. COURT THREE. THE
HORSERACING BOARD IT FIFTEEN
WHEREAS INCOME. TO THE OFFICE
OF- COMMUNITY BURSARY HAVE
THREE MALES BIT DEMONSTRATE THE
LACK OF REGARDING. THAT IT'S
GIVEN. OUT SUCH AN IMPORTANT
OFFICE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT. CONNECT COMMENT
COMES FROM THE LINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND PLEASE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE
THANK YOU. INDEED THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THIS IS ELIZABETH
ESPINOZA I AM CALLING ABOUT
ISSUE FOR AN ISSUE SIX I WILL
BE BRIEF ON THE ISSUE FOR THESE
ARE THE COUNTY PROBATION
PROPOSALS I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS A RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN BROAD SUPPORT THE
CONTINUED AND CRITICAL
INVESTMENT IN PROBATION ACROSS
THE THREE CATEGORIES THAT WERE
DISCUSSED TODAY AND COMMITTEE-
COUNTY IS WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE STATE ON PROBATION
LEADERS HAVE BEEN COMMITTED
PARTNERS IN IMPLEMENTING FAR
REACHING. AND HISTORIC REFORMS
OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS AND
BOTH THE ADULT AND JUVENILE
SYSTEMS. SO IS THE BUDGET
BUDGET CONVERSATION CONTINUE WE
URGE OF THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
MADE FOR CONTINUITY AND SUPPORT
ACROSS A VITAL AND VERY
SERVICES DELIVERED BY PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS IN OUR SATE-
ESPECIALLY GIVEN CONSIDERABLE
NEW RESPONSIBILITIES THAT ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF BEING
IMPLEMENTED. AND THEN FINALLY
ON ISSUE SIX ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTIES- I WANTED TO
SHARE AS WELL OUR OPPOSITION TO
THE ALLEY A RECOMMENDATION TO
CHARGE LOCAL AGENCIES FEES FOR
THE USE OF STATE CRIME LAB. FOR
THE SAME REASONS THAT WERE
NOTED IN TODAY'S DISCUSSION
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
CONCEPT OF ANY MAGNITUDE WOULD
JEOPARDIZE THE POP THE
INCONSISTENCY OF FORENSIC
SERVICES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
FORCE COUNTIES TO MAKE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS ABOUT
CURTAILING. NECESSARY FORENSIC
WORK WHICH WOULD WORK IT IS THE
PURPOSES OF BOOK BOTH DEFENSE
AND PROSECUTORIAL EFFORTS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE CONVERSATION
AND THE OPPORTUNITY. TO PROVIDE
OUR INPUT THANK YOU. NAY OUR
NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM A LINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME'S EMILIANO LOPEZ I AM
FROM THE GROUP TRAINING
INSTITUTE AND THE ONLY
SUBMITTED A BUDGET REQUEST
OPPOSING THE SCALING PLAN THE
COULD SERVE. AS A CORNERSTONE
FOR STATE STRATEGY TO SHIFT
KAMALA JUSTICE SYSTEM FROM A
PUNITIVE MODEL TOWARD HEALING
AND RESTORATIVE JUSTICE MODEL.
THE WHEN YOUR COMPREHENSIVE
HEALING ACCOUNTABILITY PROGRAM
OUR MISSION IS TO TRANSFORM
VIOLENCE AND SUFFERING AND
HEALING AND LEARNING FROM CARTS
MAKE PEOPLE SURVIVORS OF
VIOLENCE AND CHILDREN FAMILIES
IMPACTED BY INCARCERATION WE
HAVE A TEN YEAR TRACK RECORD OF
SUCCESS WITH INDEPENDENT
RESEARCH STUDIES THAT SHOW THE
TRANSFORMATIONAL IMPACT ON
INDIVIDUALS. AND THE PRISON
CULTURE WE HAVE WE SERVICE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE CONTENT TO
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE AND LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE CURRENTLY IN
SIXTH GRADE IN CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE GRADUATED OVER NINE
HUNDRED STUDENTS WHICH HAS LED
TO NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS
BEING RELEASED WITH ONLY ONE
STUDENT RETURNING BUT THE
RECIDIVISM RATE UP 23% IN
CALIFORNIA COFFEE ONE THOUSAND
PER YEAR TO INCARCERATE A HUMAN
BEING BY NO LONGER INCARCERATED
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
GROUP GRADUATES TAXPAYERS SAVE.
OVER THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE
ROUGHLY THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
LIVE BIRTHS THROUGHOUT. THE
IT'S THIRTY FIVE PRISON. SO
LONG TERMS OF A- TO THEM
WILLING AND FOR CHANGE. IN
TEACHER. THE MAKE AVAILABLE R.
F. BASE TRAUMA PRO. THAT WOULD
BE A- IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
YOUR MUCH. AND OUR NEXT PUBLIC
COMMENTS COME FROM LINE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN SENATOR
DANIEL P. AND HAS ON BEHALF OF
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER IS
THE PART OF THE PROPOSAL AND
YOUR ISSUE NUMBER FOUR WE
SUPPORT THE FIFTY MILLION FOR
PROBATION DEPARTMENT TO SUPPORT
AN EMPLOYMENT OF JUVENILE AND
ADULT REFORM ACT BY THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR. HOW DOES
THAT IMPACT- OF THE REFORMS
HAVE BEEN IMMEDIATE UPON
ENACTMENT OF FOR EXAMPLE
COMMISSION HAD SIGNIFICANT ONE
TIME COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
PREPARING ALL OF THE CURRENT
PIECES WITH THE GRANTED
PERMISSION AND WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
PEOPLE OFF OF PROBATION
PURSUANT TO EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FIFTY. IN ADDITION WE KNOW IT
NEW PIECES ARE CONSIDERED BY
THE COURT WE NEED ROBUST
PROGRAMS IN PLACE SOONER I'M
REALLY DOING. IN ORDER TO AVOID
AN INCREASE. INCARCERATIONS AND
COMPARED. SB SIX EIGHT- THE
PROGRAM REALLY RECORD ONE OF
THE SUCCESSFUL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
FOR CONTROL. I DIRECTLY SUPPORT
AND ONE. OF EVIDENCE PRACTICES
BY KIRBY. TO PROVIDE ALTERNATE
TO. I THINK VERY IMPORTANTLY
ARE THERE IT'S BEEN OVER A
DECADE AND GOT IT TO REPORT.
THIS PROGRAM AND THE REDUCTIONS
IN PRISON POPULATIONS AND THAT
SAID SHE IS LEADING TO THE
STATE. AND THEN ACTING AND INTO
IN LARGE PART TO THE BODIES.
REPORT OF THE PROGRAM. WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ADMINISTER
TO MAKE SURE WE CONTINUE CAN
PROGRAMS AFTER CLASS IN A VERY
ROBUST WAY. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR CONVERSATION THANK. YOU FOR
THE TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR NEXT UP COMMENT COMES FROM
A LINE FIFTY. WE'VE AHEAD. HI
THIS IS MEANT FOR USE PROGRAM
COORDINATOR WITH THE PREVENTION
INSTITUTE. WE ECHO PREVIOUS
COMMENTS THAT THE PROPOSED
STAFFING AND BUDGET FOR THE
WHOLE LIFE YOU ARE INSUFFICIENT
MR THE POPULATION OF YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND IN ADDITION
TO THAT WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
ALL I SEE ARE ADVANCED
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. AND
HEALING AND PRO INFORMED
APPROACHES AND BEST PRACTICES
TO PROTECT AND IN BEST INTEREST
OF INVOLVED YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
LARGER CONTEXT OF THE STATE AND
THIS POLITICAL MOMENT THIS
OFFICE WILL SERVE A KEY ROLE IN
SUPPORTING THE STATE'S GOAL TO
ADVANCE HEALTH AND RACIAL
EQUITY. STEINORTH IS OPPOSITION
PRIORITIZED EXPERTISE THAT IS
GROUNDED IN TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE PREVENTION AND CULTURAL
HUMILITY INCOMPETENCE OVERALL
STAFF SHOULD PRIORITIZE.
STOPPING APRIL ACR SHOULD
PRIORITIZE PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE WITH THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM EXPERIENCE IN
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT BEHAVIORAL
AND HEALTH TRAUMA INFORMED
HEALING CENTER PRACTICE
CULTURALLY AND GENDER
RESPONSIVE PROGRAMMING AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICE
DELIVERY THANK YOU THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH FOR CALLING PRECIADO.
NEXT IN AN NEXT PUBLIC COMMON
COME FROM THE FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO ONE FORTY FOUR
YOUR BIKE AT THE OPEN- I'VE
ALREADY- GIVE MY COMMENT
EARLIER ISRAEL DEAL WITH THE
WORKING DAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND OUR NEXT PUBLIC
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE
FIFTY SEVEN GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOT WITH
THE CENTER ON JUVENILE AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE GIVING PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE THREE THE
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION CURRENTLY WE HAVE
NO CENTRAL AGENCY RESPONSIBLE
FOR OVERSEEING THE CARE AND
CUSTODY OF ALL USE IN
CALIFORNIA'S JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEMS- ALEXI ARE WE CREATED
TO FILL THIS LONG STANDING
NEED. TO BE CLEAR THE OFFICE OF
THE OMBUDSMAN ROLE SHOULD NOT
BE LIMITED TO USE WHO WOULD
HAVE OTHERWISE GONE TO DJJ IT
IS NOT REFLECTIVE OF SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE STATUTES NOR THE
BE THE CALL AN OMBUDSMAN
INVESTIGATES THE TREATMENT AND
CONDITION VIEWS ARE SUBJECTED
TO AND USE WITH A WIDE ARRAY OF
OFFENSES ARE SUBJECT TO LOCAL
FACILITY CONDITIONS. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN ACCORDING OF USING
LOCAL DETENTION WERE THERE FOR
MISDEMEANORS IF YOU'D
EXPERIENCE UNETHICAL TREATMENT
HOW LONG ISOLATION COUPONS AT
THE HANDS OF STAFF OR ANY OTHER
CONCERNS WELL THE ON BUTTON
ONLY FILL COMPLAINTS FROM THOSE
WITH A SEVEN ON SEVEN B.
OFFENSE. WHAT WILL THEY DO WITH
OTHER INFORMATION AND HOW
CONFUSING WILL IT BE FOR YOU
AND THEIR FAMILIES TRYING TO
NAVIGATE AN ALREADY COMPLEX
SYSTEM. THE MEASLY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS AND NINETEEN
STASHED ALLOCATED TO- I. T. R.
INCLUDING ONLY THREE FOR ITS
ROPE ROBUST OMBUDSMAN DUTIES
THAT'S THE AGENCY UP FOR
FAILURE. WE NEED MORE STASHED
QUALIFIED LEADERSHIP AND
RESOURCES FOR THIS OFFICE TO
SUPPORT OUR USE AND THEIR
FAMILIES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT ONE.
AN HOUR FINAL PUBLIC GO TO LAW
FIFTY SIX WE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAURA
RIDOLFI AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY WITH THE W. HAYWOOD
BURNS INSTITUTE I'D LIKE TO
GIVE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
NUMBER THREE. THE CREATION OF
THE OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION IS
WITHOUT A DOUBT ONE OF THE MOST.
IMPORTANT AND VISION COME AS
EIGHT THREE. FOR THE FOR TIME
EVER IN HEALTH. THERE WILL A MY
ME STATE AGENCY THAT OVERSEES
THE CARE AND CUSTODY OF ALL
YOUTH AND- WITH AND HARMED BY
THE JUSTICE. ALLEGED CHARGES
BROUGHT BONTA DELETING I GET PA
RECORD. TO IMPROVE OUR FOR
USING THE DRUG SYSTEM. BEST
PRACTICE EXPANDING LOCAL
DIVERSION OPPORTUNITIES. AND
SERVING IT ON THIS PERSON.
HOWEVER THE PROPOSED AND
STAFFING. FOR THE OFFICE IT. WE
THE- TO FOCUS ON ONLY ONE OF
THE MANY WERE. OF THE WE ARE
THE FIRST WE CAN SEE. THE
UNITED OF THE FUN. THE PROPOSED
ASKING OF THREE P. EVEN WITH.
TO RECEIVE INVESTING AND
RESOLVE COMPLAINTS YOU X. TO
MORE THAN. THOUSAND WHO ARE
DETAINED ANNUAL AND MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND PER YEAR WHO ARE.
FROM HOME A RESULT A QUARTER
JUSTICE. IN 9% STRAW THE STATE
IS. THERE IS NOTHING IN THE
STATE THAT WE THERE'S- OF THE
LIKE THE ARE TO THE AMBEDKAR.
TO THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WOULD
HAVE A- BEEN. TO J. J. THAT IS
M. OF LAW AND EVERYTHING.
POSSIBLE WAY FOR THE OFFICE TO.
EXECUTED BOTH MISSION THANK THE
PROPOSED FUND AND STAFF. WE
NEED A BUDGET THAT REFER YOUR
PRICE TO PROMOTE YOUNG IN OUR-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CALLING A
PRE. IT. MADAM CHAIR THERE ARE
NO FURTHER PEOPLE WERE TO COME.
COULD YOU. ASK MORE TIME.
DEFINITELY LADIES AND IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN BIGELOW.
KERRY WENT EIGHTEEN P. YOUR
LINE NUMBER IN LINE NUMBER
FIFTY EIGHT REPLY NUMBER FIFTY
EIGHT THEY WERE LIKE YOU KNOW
WHAT YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THAT IS
DIFFERENT MODERATOR. THE FOUR
FIFTEEN I BELIEVE THAT WAS OUR-
OUR OPERATOR- SHE WAS COMING
FROM THE MAIN CONFERENCE I'M
NOT SURE WHY- BUT WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE FIFTY EIGHT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL KESSLER
ON THE POLICY COORDINATOR WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN GIVEN A COMMON
PUNISHES THREE OFFICERS YOU
THINK ANY RESTORATION. OFFICE
NEED MORE STAFF AND FUNDING TO
FULFILL ITS DUTY TO OVERSEE THE
TREATMENT OF ALL USE IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM I SAW
ONLY ONE RESEARCH DATA
SPECIALIST. IS ASSIGNED TO
COLLECT ANALYZE AND REPORT ON
THE EFFICACY OF LOCAL PROPER
CRIMSON OUTCOMES WITH FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEMS ACROSS THE STATE THE
SINGLE PERSON CANNOT BE
REASONABLY EXPECTED TO FULFILL
THIS RESPONSIBILITY. I HEARD
DURING THE HEARING THAT- I SEE
OUR STAFF HAVE JUVENILE JUSTICE
PROGRAM POLICY AND DATA
EXPERTISE BUT THEY MUST DO MORE
TO PROMOTE TRAUMA RESPONSES
CULTURALLY INFORMED SERVICES
FOR YOU. IN THE SYSTEM BUT
SUPPORT THE USE EXCEPTIONAL
TRANSITION INTO ADULTHOOD IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT KEEPING YOU OUT
OF TROUBLE FOR REALLY HELPING
THEM BECOME RESPONSIBLE FOR IT
ENGAGE MEMBERS OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CALLING. MODERATOR AND MADAM
CHAIR. THERE ARE NO P. WISHING
TO COMMENT. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR HELP. OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT IS DONE THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY WE KNOW WAS A
LONG HEARING YOU HAD TO WAIT.
SEVERAL HOURS TO- COLIN BUT WE
APPRECIATE. ALL OF WHAT YOU
CONTRIBUTED. IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY. IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDAS FOR BOTH PART A AND
PART B. OF TODAY'S HEARING. THE
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE IS NOW
ADJOURNED.